THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
HEARING WILL COME TO ORDER.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE GOOD AFTERNOON AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISKS
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES SUFFICIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
IN ORDER TO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE
FOUR ZERO. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING IT IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR AFTER CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED SO WE CAN
STEP FOR CORN AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. THERE ARE SEVENTEEN
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. MAKE
NOTE THAT CENTER GROVE WOULD NOT
BE WILL NOT BE IN ATTENDANCE. AT
THE COMMITTEE HEARING THIS
AFTERNOON. ALSO PLEASE MAKE NOTE
THAT WE HAVE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS TODAY I WILL BE HEARING
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. I
CENTERS NUMBER AGAIN EGGMAN AT
THREE PM. SO WHEN WE COME TO AN
ITEM- WILL WRAP UP THAT ITEM.
AND AS AN ACTIVE EITHER THREE PM
OR SHORTLY THEREAFTER AS SOON AS
WE WRAP UP THAT THE LAST THAT
PRIOR AND WE'LL MOVE THEN TO- SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH- IS.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN. I WOULD MAKE
NO GIVEN THE PUBLIC AND IN THE
BILL- WE WILL VERY WE WILL ARE
ALSO VERY THE RULES FOR
TESTIMONY IN THAT PARTICULAR
BILL SAID DURING THAT HEARING-
EACH SIDE WILL BE ALLOWED TEN
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY FOR LEAD
SUPPORT AND TEN MINUTES OF
LEADERS MAY FOR OPPOSITION
BEFORE. PEOPLE ALSO- CAN
ANNOUNCE THEIR- AT OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL SO WE'LL
OUT TEN MINUTES OF TESTIMONY TO
EACH SIDE. ALRP WILL CONTINUE
THERE ARE REGULAR RULE. ANY
OTHER BILLS IN THE PANDEF WHICH
MAY CONTINUE TO BE FOUR MINUTES
OF- OF SUPPORT FOR ITS OF OPTION
TAX MONEY PER SIDE- I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NO THAT WE WILL NOT BE
HEARING TO BILLS. THAT CURRENTLY
ON THE AGENDA THAT'S- ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB TWELVE EIGHTY TWO
BY CENTER BATES AND ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY THREE
BY CENTER BATES. YEP FIVE ITEMS
IN A PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR
THOSE ARE ITEM NUMBER TWO. SB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER
EGGMAN. ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY CENTER
BATES. ITEM NUMBER NINE. SB
TWELVE THIRTY ONE BY SERIKAT BL.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY BY CENTER PAN ITSELF AND
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED WHICH IS THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE BILL. BEFORE WE BEGIN
OUR PRESENTATION BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BUT ANDREA
SUPPOSED. ONE ACTUALLY WE'RE WE
NEED SIXTEEN FIX THAT ONE ONE
SHORT NOW OKAY OKAY SO- WE DO
NOT QUITE YET A QUORUM- BUT
SINCE WE DO WILL CALL FOR A
QUORUM- YEAH I'M SORRY MISTER
CHAIRMAN HE TUTORED I JUST TO
MAKE SURE I'M CLEAR FOR S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. WE HAVE
CHANGE IT SO THAT- OPPOSITION IN
SUPPORT GET TEN MINUTES OH FIVE
MINUTES EACH LEAD WOULD LIKE TO
THINK LIKE THAT EACH SIDE GETS
TEN MINUTES OF PRESENTATION
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE BILL.
YEAH I KNOW WHAT I MEAN IS- IT'S
NOT TEN MINUTES IN TOTAL FOUR
PEOPLE CALLING PEOPLE THAT THE
FORMAL IT'S THE FORMER. YEAH THE
NORMAL BILL OUT MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE FOR THIS WOULD ALLOW SIDE.
MINUTES OF FOR PRESENT. AND IT'S
BEEN- NO AND THEN CAN ADD ON.
YOU NOW- HOWEVER. THE FOLLOWING
UP ON THAT BUT CAN. REGARDING
LENGTH OF HEARING AND TAKEN
CONSIDER. AGAIN COME CHAIRMAN
INSTITUTE TYLER ON TEST. IS I
MENTIONED AT THE SIDE BE
PERMITTED OF FOR MINUTES ON EACH
SIDE OF FORMAL. OTHERS ALL
OTHERS WERE TO TEST IN MUSLIM
COMMON THERE NAY A POLICE
POSITION THE MEASURE. WILL ALLOW
ME. OF FIFTEEN MINUTES EACH FOR
BOTH SUPPORT AND FIFTEEN MINUTES
FOR OPPOSITION FOR ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE. SO- HOPEFULLY WE THAT WAS
TO GET EVERYONE BEFORE THEN SO
WITH THAT- WILL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST BILL AND-
LIKELY CENTER EGGMAN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT ITEM NUMBER
ONE AS HE- BUT- BOTH ARE DODD IS
HERE OKAY. YES SIR EVEN IF YOU
DON'T MIND FOR CAN WE ALLOW SIR
DODD. IF MULLIN SEES SAID SINCE
HE NOT A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR
EGGMAN ALL RIGHT. I KNOW IT VERY
THAT SOMEWHAT SOMETIMES THAT.
THANK YOU ALWAYS GRACIOUS ALL
RIGHT ALWAYS OKAY SO WE'RE MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR DODD
WELCOME. WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ESPECIALLY THE ESTEEMED-
SENATOR EGGMAN FOR BEING SO
GRACIOUS. I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANK YOU ALL AND YOUR STAFF
FOR- YOUR WORK ON THE BILL I'LL
BE ACCEPTING ALL THE AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBED ON PAGE. SIX OF THE
PALACES LIMITING THE BILL TO THE
HEALTH INSURANCE PROVISIONS. SB
NINE SEVENTY NINE AS AMENDED
WILL CLARIFY THE GOVERNOR OR
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
THAT HEALTHCARE PLAN OR INSURER
MUST PROVIDE ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY. HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TO ENROLLEES WHOSE HELP MAY BE
AFFECTED BY THE EMERGENCY AND
NOT TO JUST THOSE PHYSICALLY
DISPLACED BY THE DISASTER. THE
BILL CLARIFIES THE AUTHORITY OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF- INSURANCE THAT'S DIEM AGENCY
OR CDI TO REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS.
TO TAKE SPECIFIED ACTIONS WHEN
THE EMERGENCY AFFECTS OR MAY
AFFECT. THE HEALTH OF THE
ENROLLEE OR INSURED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE LACK OF
FLEXIBILITY IN STATUTE MEANT
THAT THESE KEY STATE DEPARTMENT.
DID NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC. IT'S
PROVIDERS AND HOSPITALS
EXPERIENCE THE PATCHWORK OF
RESPONSES WITH MANY POINTS
DECLINING TO TAKE PROACTIVE
STEPS LIKE SUSPENDING PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR PATIENT
TRANSFERS BETWEEN HOSPITALS. SB
NINE SEVENTY NINE ENSURES THAT
IN THE FUTURE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IMPACTING PUBLIC HEALTH THAT
RELEVANT DEPARTMENTS HAVE CLEAR
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE THAT PLANS
INSURERS ENABLE PATIENTS TO GET
THE CARE THEY NEED WHEN THEY
NEED IT MOST. THIS WILL ALLOW
PATIENTS CRITICAL ACCESS TO OUT
OF NETWORK PER PERSON OR
PHARMACIES WHEN IN NETWORK
OPTIONS ARE UNAVAILABLE AND
RELAXED TIME LIMITS FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATIONS AND REFERRALS.
URGENCY IS LIKE THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC SHOWED US ALL-
JOE IS THAT NOT ALL DISASTERS
PHYSICALLY DISPLACE RESIDENTS IT
IS CRITICAL THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HAVE CONSISTENT ACCESS TO
CRITICAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
INSTANCES. I HAVE CHRISTY WEEKS
WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD I
WOULD MAKE NO SENSE YOU ONLY
HAVE ONE LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
ANDERSON TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- CHRISTY WE SELL
WELCOME YOU- WELL ACTUALLY
PERMITS YOU THE TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES YOU DON'T USE ALL THE
TIME YOU DON'T WANT THAT- FOUR
MINUTES TESTIMONY. CENTER TO
SOLE SUPPORT WITNESS. YOUR
SENATE ARE CHRISTY WE SAW AFTER
THE- HIGH. ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. OF APPRECIATE SENATOR
DODDS YOU KNOW DESCRIPTION OF
THE BILL AND ALL OF THE
ASSISTANCE THE COMMITTEE
PROVIDED US. AS HE STATED THE
BILL GIVES DMH C. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY IN A
STORY. THAT THEY MAY BE NEEDED
THAT WE THINK THEY WANT. IN THE
EVENT THAT THEY ARE DEALING
WITH. ANOTHER PANDEMIC A SENATOR
PAM LIKES TO REMIND US WE ARE
NOT OUT OF COPAYS YET. OR
ANOTHER SIMILAR TYPE OF HEALTH
EMERGENCY OR STATE OF EMERGENCY
WHERE ENROLLEES ARE NOT
PHYSICALLY DISPLACED. SO THE
BILL BEFORE YOU IS MODEST WE
WORKED THROUGH ALL THE ISSUES
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION WITH
THE HELP OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO MAKE SURE THAT.
HOSPITALS AND ARE REGULATORS
PLAN ABOUT THE FULL ABILITY THEY
NEED TO MAKE THAT PATIENTS GET
THE CARE THAT EVERYONE WANTS TO
GET IN THE CASE OF REGENCY SO WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. THANKS MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL. IN SUPPORT OF- SB
NINE SEVENTY NINE HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. WELCOME NAME
WORKSTATION SESSION. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTIE FOR HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DIALYSIS COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
A MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE SEVENTY NINE. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU AT LEAST GIVEN YOURS
ORDERED S HE NINE SEVEN NINE
HE'S PRESS ONE YEAR WHAT THIS
TIME. PRETTY GOOD A LOT NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT VIEWS BUT HAS.
MISTER CAR MEMBERS PARTICIPANTS
HELP REINFORCE THIS BOOK IF WE
ARE MOVING OUR OFFICE PHONE
BILLS AT BOTH ENDED YOU WANT TO
THANK AUTHOR AND MAYBE AFTER
WORK WITH THAT DO A PART. I
THINK THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE IT MIGHT TO OUR SUPPORT SB
NINE NINE HE'S BEST ONES. SIX
FIVE. HELLO I NUMBER SEVENTY
STATE IS FOR HAS.
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS HURDLE THE PROJECT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MODERATE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- AND I
THINK THEY'RE BOTH ALSO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. SO WE HAVE
JANET SOME ALLEY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
DIANA DOUGLAS FROM HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA YOU TWO MINUTES TO
BEGIN WITH YEAH SO MALLEY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
. THANK YOU CARE AND NUMBER
AGAIN CANNOT VALLEY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND-
WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE THAT- YOUR STAFF AND
AUTHOR FOR THIS IMPORTANT
EARNED. AND PEOPLE ACT EIGHTEEN
FROM MOVING OUR OPPOSITION THE
BILL HAS RESULTS OF THE READ AND
AMENDMENTS- AND AGAIN REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ON GOING YOU CAN
ADD THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
SOME MOVE ON TO DOUGLAS AND
HEALTH ARE HEALTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON. WHERE MEMBERS. OF
CALIFORNIA IT MIGHT OF- AT EQUAL
. BIGGEST PLANET OF BOTH MEN AND
UNITE. RIGHT OPEN WORK
EXPERIENCE AUTHOR AND IT
DEPARTMENT FOR INFORMATION. THAT
RIGHT IF YOU WILL NOT THE ACT.
THE FOR THE PROPOSITIONING IF
YOU THAT THANK. THANK THANK YOU
- WELL NOW TAKE THIS WITNESSES
OPPOSITE- NAME OR THE POSITION
WILL BEGIN HERE IN ROOM TWO
HUNDRED ONE. WELCOME. VEAL
AGUILAR FOUNDER FOR LOVE HOPE
DEALERS IN ACTION AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. SONORA'S
APPROACH A MICROPHONE WITH
CIRCUIT TELL A MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE TELECONFERENCE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB
NINE SEVENTY NINE. NAME OR
POSITION POSITION. THANK YOU A
GENERAL CURED OPPOSITION AT THE
NINE SEVEN NINE HE'S PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE START BUT OPPOSITION
TO THE NINE SEVEN NINE BUT ONE
SEVEN ZERO AT FIVE THIRTY ALIVE
NUMBER. SEVENTY THAT IS BY HAS.
I CAN'T REMEMBER. LOCKED UP THE
THAT CALIFORNIA AND HEALTH
NETWORK IN WHICH GIVE WE WOULD
LIKE TO WITHDRAW OUR- AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND AS A REMINDER LES AND
GENTLEMAN IF YOU AREN'T. TO SB
SEVEN NINE. ONE ZERO FIVE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROTECT
PARTY. YOUR PATIENCE WILL BE
JUST ONE MORE MORE. BIGELOW AYE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE THE BILL HAS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A FOUND
OUT HE WAS AT THE IDC COUNCIL
AND THEN RESPECTFULLY REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION. I THINK THE
AUTHOR I THINK MANY DOCTORS THAT
WORK. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE BUILT COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH MODERATE WILL BE AFFECTED
TOO MANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT CENTER
EGGMAN I WOULD JUST A THANK GOD
THE SENATOR FOR ALL THE GOOD
WORK THAT HE DID TO GET
EVERYBODY WHO WAS OPPOSED TO
WORK EVERYTHING OUT THAT'S WHAT
WE LIKE TO SEE IN COMMITTEE
SOONER THAN LATER AND I KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM IT BUT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
MOVE THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SENATOR MELENDEZ THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND SO WITH
RESPECT TO WAIVING THE
REQUIREMENTS OR REGULATIONS FOR
HEALTH FACILITIES IS THAT ALSO.
COVER TEN BOMBS. NO NO OKAY.
TECHNICAL EXPERTS NO IT DOESN'T
INCLUDE TESTING LABS THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS SPECIFIC
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE AND THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE AND ENTITIES THEY
REGULATE THEY DON'T HAVE ANY
JURISDICTION OKAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK THANKS
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SAYING NONE OF SARDAR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING OTHER
COMMITTEE STAFF. AND THAT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND SO AT THAT
LEVEL TO SUPPORTING THE BILL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THAT WE ARE ONCE AGAIN- THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE STAFF. AND
ALSO FOR MY STAFF AND OUR
SPONSOR FOR DOING THE HEAVY
LIFTING I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
VOTE FOR YOUR VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU- THE FORTUNE WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM YET SO. WHEN WE DO THAT
SAID THE CENTER EGGMAN WILL BE
MOVING IT AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT THANKS VERY MUCH. ARE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO FACT TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB NINE SEVENTY BY
SIR EGGMAN THANK YOU WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND- AND MY COLLEAGUES SITTING
HERE. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY WHICH
WOULD STRIKE THE PROVISIONS THAT
WOULD EXTEND THE PLANNING
PROCESS FROM THREE TO FIVE
YEARS- THIS BILL E'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT MADE THE PACKAGE IS
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE THOSE
BILLS. AND AGAIN THIS ONE LOOKS
AT MORE OF SOME OF THE FRONT
END- ISSUES ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY DEALING WITH THE
MHSAA- THE BILL REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO SET AMBITIOUS GOALS
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT PROGRAMS. IN THE STATE TO
MONITOR AND PUBLICLY REPORT
THEIR PROGRESS. SINCE ITS
PASSAGE IN TWENTY OH FOR THE
MHSAA HAS PROVIDED MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS A BROAD SPECTRUM OF
PREVENTION. EARLY INTERVENTION
AND SUPERIOR SERVICE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH AND AT RISK OF
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH AND.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CONDITIONS. OVER
HOW ONLY ONE THIRD OF QUE.
LIVING WITH A MENTALLY ILL
RECEIVED TREATMENT THEY NEED.
AND WITH OUR EVER WORSENING
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS WE ARE
EXPERIENCING NOW'S THE TIME TO
LOOK. AT WAYS TO IMPROVE OUR
SYSTEM HOW WE CAN USE OUR MONEY
MORE EFFECTIVELY. THIS BILL
WOULD MODERNIZE MHSAA BY
APPLYING A CONTINUOUS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT APPROACH REFINED
THROUGH OTHER STATE PROGRAMS.
WITH INPUT FROM THE STATE
COUNTIES WILL ESTABLISH
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES THAT ADDRESS
THE TOP PUBLIC PRIORITIES. THAT
COUNTIES IN REACHING THESE GOALS
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCY WILL TEST THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR
PREMIER. THINGS WERE SO LUCKY TO
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE. TO
REPAIR ANALYSIS OF DATA
CURRENTLY COLLECTED BY THE
COUNTIES THAT MEASURES THE
IMPACT OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ON LIFE OUTCOMES. BASED ON THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE GOAL
SPECIFIED IN THIS BILL THE
AGENCY WILL ESTABLISH A SUITE OF
MEASUREABLE OUTCOMES FROM WHICH-
EACH COUNTY IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS. THAT WILL
IDENTIFY IT'S AN HSA PRIORITY
GOALS- COUNTIES WILL TRACK AND
REPORT ON THEIR PERFORMANCE
FOLLOWED BY A SELF IMPROVEMENT
PLAN AND REGULAR PROGRESS
UPDATES. THE STATE WAIT ONLINE
DASHBOARD WILL MAKE THAT
INFORMATION EASILY ACCESSIBLE
CREATING MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ALLOWING US. AS POLICY MAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND AND COMPARE COUNTIES
PROGRESS. THE STATE WILK SUPPORT
COUNTIES IN REACHING THEIR GOALS
TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INCLUDING CREATIVE. CREATING
COLLABORATIVE SPACES FOR
COUNTIES TO LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER. SETTING AMBITIOUS GOALS
COMBINED WITH ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COLLABORATION WILL SPARK THE
INNOVATION WE DESPERATELY NEED.
A AND INSISTENCE ON
ACCOUNTABILITY IMPROVEMENT WILL
FOCUS MORE ENERGY ON RESEARCH
AND RESOURCES ON FACILITATING
THE RECOVERY AND THRIVING OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS EVERY
DAY. WITH ME TODAY IS THE AUTHOR
OF THE ORIGINAL. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT THERE. MAYOR DALE
STEINBERG AND ON THE PHONE IS
TARGET BONE EASTMAN SENIOR
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF THE SPINE
SENATE. STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN MODERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE- THE
HONORABLE MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG MAYOR OF THE CITY
SACRAMENTO AND THEN WE'LL OF
COURSE ASSEMBLY TERRA GAMBLE
EASTMAN IS HERE PRESENT SO-
MAYOR STEINBERG GOOD TO HEAR
FROM YOU YOU HAVE. TWO MINUTES
WE HAVE A TOLL FOUR MINUTES OF
YOU GO OVER THAT TAKES AWAY FROM
THE OTHER TESTIMONY FROM
DECEMBER GETS ITS A WELCOME.
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN- AND THANK YOU TO
SENATOR EGGMAN FOR NOT ONLY
HEARING SB NINE SEVENTY BUT FOR
HER WHOLE PACKAGE- MENTAL HEALTH
REFORM BILLS- THIS IS THE YEAR-
FOR REAL CHANGE AND PROGRESS AND
NINE SEVENTY. IS AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THIS PACKAGE- THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT IS NOT
GENERATING PROJECTED GENERATE
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. IN CALIFORNIA IT
IS RAPIDLY BECOMING THE LARGEST
PUBLIC SOURCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
FUNDING IN THE STATE. OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FIFTEEN PLUS
YEARS. I THINK IT IS FAIR TO SAY
IT IS BEEN A GREAT SUCCESS. IT
HAS- PIONEERED THE IDEA OF FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO OPEN WELLNESS CENTERS
THROUGHOUT. THE STATE THERE HAVE
BEEN TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INNOVATION AND- THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OF GOD HELP THE ONE
CRITICISM. CONTINUED CRITICISM
FRANKLY THAT WE'VE TAKEN A HARD
I THINK HARD ABOUT FOR DECADES.
IS THE IDEA THAT. THE STATE AND
THE COUNTIES. SHOULD BE THAT
DEVELOPING AN- MARC. OUTCOME SO
THAT THE PUBLIC UNDERSTANDS. HOW
THIS- GIFT FROM THE VOTERS. IS
ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE. THIS IS NOT A NEW IDEA
WHEN I WAS A YOUNG ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FIRST YEAR ACTUALLY I
BELIEVE I AUTHORED EIGHTY SIX
THIRTY SIX BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. TO BRING AN
OUTCOMES BASED FOCUS TO THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM- THERE WAS
SOME CONTROVERSY BUT IT PASSED.
AND IT IS TURNED OUT TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT PERFORMANCE CHILD
WELFARE BECAUSE NOW ALL THE
COUNTIES TOGETHER WITH THE- ARE
CONSISTENTLY REPORTING. OF THE
OUTCOMES THAT THE PUBLIC WANTS
TO WANTS TO SEE IT IS DRIVEN
INNOVATION. IS DRIVEN CHANGE AND
I THINK APPLYING THE SAME
APPROACH. TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT OF WOULD GO ALONG
WAY TOWARDS MAKING THIS. GREAT
ACTING EVEN- I HAVE EVEN MORE OF
THAT I SIGNIFICANT IMPACT FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE WERE. TRYING TO SERVE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
I THANK YOU AGAIN THANK- NOW
WILL THAT ACTUALLY BEFORE WE
HAVE YOU UP. BUT DON'T PLEASE
STAND THE LIGHT AND- I'D LIKE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO- THAT
MIGHT TAKE A PAUSE HERE-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO STATUS QUORUM. PAN HERE HAND
HERE MELENDEZ MULLIN THIS YEAR
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ
GROVE FURTADO. LEYVA YOUR FLAVOR
HERE LEE MON. BROTH YOUR BREATH
HERE RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENT WIENER
OKAY A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
THANK YOU AND AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR PAUSING FROM OUT THERE LET'S
NOW LET'S BRING UP THE TERRIBLE
EASTMAN FROM THE SAME AGAIN TO
WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TARGET BY EASTON WITH
THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
I WILL NOW TAKE A- TAKE
TESTIMONY FOR A DISH AND
ADDITION WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE SEVENTY BEGINS HERE IN
ROOM TO- TWELVE HUNDRED. NAME ON
STAGE POSITION WELCOME. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YOU'VE SEEN ME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE. I
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BUT WILL BE
PLEASE INTRODUCE IT AGAIN I'M
SORRY MORE GOSH PANAY ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF AND MY FAMILY. I AM WE
NEED MORE FACILITIES. AND THAT'S
WHERE THESE BILLION SHOT HE
COUNTY BECAUSE I KNOW SENATOR
ROSS IS GOING TO BE ABOUT IT BUT
BECAUSE I APOLOGIZE. THE RULES
ARE WE HAD TWO. PEOPLE TESTIFIED
IN SUPPORT SO I JUST NEED THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATIONS OKAY IN THE
POSITION. SO I'D APPRECIATE THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN MORE FACILITIES
IS WHAT'S NEEDED THANK YOU. FOR
THE FIRST THANK YOU END UP FEEL
FREE TO PLEASE SUBMIT A LETTER
TO OUR THIRD WITH MORE DETAIL I
APOLOGIZE. WELCOME MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS NICOLO
DELUCA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MAYOR WHO SECURE THE BIG
CITY MAYORS. PROUDLY CO
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND THE
MANY OTHERS IN THIS GREAT
PACKAGE. HERE TO OFFER A PART
THANKS FOR THE LEGISLATION IN
OUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK. YOU
NEXT THANKS WITH THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER MM MY RIGHT HERE ON. OF
DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA WAS
AWESOME OF THE BIG CITY MAYOR
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST
BECAUSE SPONSOR AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HI MY NAME IS
DOCTOR SUSAN PARTISAN THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR HOMELESS
HEALTH CARE LOS ANGELES AND I
SUPPORTED. THANK YOU. MICHELLE
COVETED I WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED REALLY
HAPPY TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON SOME TWEAKS BUT
HAPPY FOR THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
COMING UP FOR THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. THANK YOU BEIJING
JANET YOUR SUPPORT OF SB NINETY
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
MUNDELEIN NUMBER SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOUR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YOUR LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
MEMBERS ARE ROUGH ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF STOCKTON IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. JUST ONE MORE MOMENT.
NOT GOING TO LIE NUMBER FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RANDALL HECKER
REPRESENTING EXCEL THE- STAFF
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
THE CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT ONLY
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
THAT WERE ALSO CO SPONSORS OF
THE A. L. I PACKED IT FOR
SENATOR EGGMAN AND WEAK DEMAND
THEM ALL TO USE BUT THANKS STAY
PARTICULARLY THANKS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANKS A
LOT NUMBER TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS ALLISON
MONROE- I'M IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOMB AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
ALONG WITH SENATOR EGGMAN
PACKAGE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO OTHER PARTIES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND A BELIEF AND THE
TOP OF INDIAN PERSON YES- IN
PERSON- WE HAVE RICH TRADITION
THE MAC GALLAGHER FROM CAL
VOICES- WILL GIVE YOU UP TO FOUR
MINUTES YOU DON'T USE AT ALL-
BECAUSE THE- THE PROPONENTS HAD
THAT THAT OPPORTUNITY SO
WELCOME. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MAC GALLAGHER WITH
COWBOYS IS- I DO APPRECIATE
CENTER EGGMAN'S. AMENDMENTS IN
THE IN THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS WITH SB NINE SEVENTY AS
IT'S DRAFTED. THE PREMISE OF THE
BILL REALLY RAISES TWO ISSUES
THAT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. THE
FIRST IS WHO SHOULD PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT DAMAGES SAY. AND HOW
SHOULD THAT OVERSIGHT BE
CONDUCTED. THE WAY IT HAS BEEN
FRAMED IN RECENT WEEKS- TO THE
FIRST QUESTION IS. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES OR THE IMAGES SO
EASY. BUT WHEN WE LOOK TO WHAT
THE VOTERS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR WHEN THEY PASSED
NOW SERVICES ACT. IT WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH. IT WAS THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH THAT
WAS ESSENTIAL IN AB THIRTY FOUR
AB TWENTY THIRTY FOUR THAT WILL
WERE THE PRECURSORS TO MENTAL
SERVICES ACT. AND ONE VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA PASSED PROPOSITION-SIXTY THREE THE DEPARTMENT
MENTAL HEALTH. WAS THE CRUX OF
THE BILL. AND WHEN THE DRAFTERS
DRAFTED PROP SIXTY THREE THEY
DID NOT SEE HER IN THE COULDN'T
FORESEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH WOULD BEEN ONLY.
ELIMINATED AS A WAS IN TWENTY
ELEVEN. AND SO WHILE WE STRUGGLE
TO DETERMINE WHAT AGENCIES
SHOULD PROVIDE PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
TO THE IMAGES SAY I'D AT THIS
POINT I ASKED FOR THE PART AND
I'LL BE BROUGHT BACK I BELIEVE
THAT IS THE BEST AGENCY OR
SHOULD BE THE BEST A TO SEE
EQUIPPED TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT.
FOR THE IMAGE SAY. MOVING TO THE
SECOND POINT HOW SURE THAT
OVERSIGHT BE PROVIDED. WHEN THE
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY
THREE THEY WERE TOLD THAT THREE
YEAR PLANS WILL BE REVIEWED AND
APPROVED BY THE STATE. THAT HAS
BEEN SENSE ELIMINATE. TO DATE
THREE YEAR PLANS GO TO THE STATE
AND THERE IS NO APPROVAL PROCESS
DONE WHATSOEVER. AND I JUST LIKE
TO SHARE SOME NUMBERS WITH YOU.
TWO POINT FOUR. POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IS CURRENTLY M.
HSA UNSPENT FUNDS ACCORDING TO
THE AND IT JUST ALWAYS SEES
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY SO ASSUMING
THAT'S ACCURATE. FIVE FIVE
COUNTIES HAD NOT SUBMITTED THREE
YEAR IMAGES SAY PLANTS ASSUMING
AGAIN DCS IS DATA IS CORRECT.
AND A HUNDRED SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
A HUNDRED SIXTY ONE THOUSAND.
PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS ACCORDING TO
TWENTY TWENTY HOMELESS
STATISTICS. I STRUGGLE TO SEE
WHAT SB NINE SEVENTY AZRAN DOES
TO ADDRESS THOSE NUMBERS. WHEN
THE IMAGES THAT WAS ORIGINALLY
DRAFTED WE HAD OVERSIGHT
MECHANISMS WE HAD STATE
OVERSIGHT I STRUGGLE TO SEE WITH
SB NINE SEVENTY DOES THAT DHS
ALREADY COULD BE DOING. WHY DO
WE NEED TO CREATE ANOTHER SYSTEM
OF A MODEL GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT. AS IT
STANDS IF IT'S PAST WILL HAVE
HHS. THE OAC. DH CS AND WHEN
THINGS GO WRONG FINGERS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE POINTED AMONGST
THE STATE AGENCIES AND WILL
STILL BE PROVIDED IN THE SAME
POSITION WE ARE NOW. A COMPLETE
LACK OF OVERSIGHT WITH THE
IMAGES THAT. HI I KNOW THIS IS
TOUGH. THE FIRST TIME I MET
DARRELL STEINBERG I WAS FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD ON THE STEPS. OF THE
WEST AND IN THE WEST TO THE WEST
OF THE CAPITAL ADVOCATING FOR
THE PASSAGE IN THE HOUSE
SERVICES ACT. I WAS A YOUNG
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD KID WALKING
AROUND WITH THE L. A BALLOT
INITIATIVE ASKING PEOPLE FOR
SIGNATURES. I MADE A PROMISE
THAT WE WILL TRANSFORM MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. BUT TO DO THAT.
BUT LET'S DO THAT BY PROVIDING
REAL MEANINGFUL OVERSIGHT IN THE
OVERSIGHT THAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED FROM THE PAST THIS ACT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
SEVENTY- NAME ORANGE ASIAN
POSITION. HELLO VELAR AGEE LARS
REPRESENTING HOPE DEALERS IN
ACTION AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING A MICROPHONE
HERE WITHOUT THERE'S AND OKAY
ROOM TWO HUNDRED. PLEASE COME
OUT AND MICROPHONE.
SO- NEWS CHEN CRYSTAL CLEAR
COUNTY SAN JOSE CALIF CROW FOR
NEW ARM WITH THE YOUTH IN PURE
MENTAL HEALTH PEER PRESSURE
MOVEMENT- I. AGREE WITH THE
SYSTEM'S BEEN REDESIGNED INSIDE
AND REDESIGNED BY PHARMA OKAY WE
HAVE A REALLY GREAT MA'AM WE
WOULD RATE TAKEN TESTIMONY SO
THAT TO SIMULATE YOUR IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL CORRECT
OKAY AND I HAVE A LETTER FOR THE
GOVERNOR AND FOR ALL OF YOU DO
YOU CAN YOU CAN SUBMIT THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE. HELLO THANK YOU
THANK THANK YOU THIS IS. CONCERN
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU SERAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR. THANKS
THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'RE WITH
pTO THE- COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ALL RIGHT.
MISTRUSTED HOLLY AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. OKAY THANK YOU. SEE
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE WILL NOW GO TO
TELECONFERENCE LINE- MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB NINE SEVENTY NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. THANK YOU
AT LEAST IN GENERAL IF YOU'RE
INTO OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO EUROPE THIS
TIME. TO GO TO LINE NUMBER FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WHATEVER
THAT IS MY NAME IS A LIMITED.
I'M A CONSUMER OF THOSE FACTORS
HUNDRED OF MENTAL HEALTH AND A
PERSON WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE
THAT IMMERSES BASIC OLDER AND I
LOOKED AT EACH LINE SEVENTY FOR
THAT WE PROVIDE EARLIER. I TO
THINK THANK YOU NEXT WHAT. WHAT
CAN LATER ON IF YOU AREN'T
OPPOSITION TO ASK NINE SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE BUTTON. ONE SMALLER
PLEASE. RESEARCHER PATIENTS BE
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. THANKS TO A
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS TAMMY ROMERO
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT LITTLE LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JODY CAIN
ALSO CONSUMER OPPOSITION. HI
THANK YOU THANKS WITNESS THANK
YOU. AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHER PARTIES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE OR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. THURMOND AS- M. THANK YOU SO
CENTER EGGMAN THERE IS SOME
CONCERN THAT THE- FUNDING FOR
OTHERS WHO ARE ALREADY COVERED-
IN THIS PROGRAM THERE FUNDING
WOULD BE VULNERABLE- I THINK THE
DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE BELIEVE THAT THE CHANGE
IN MHA SAY FUNDING OPENS THEM UP
TO. A RATE ON THEIR FUNDING GIVE
ANY COMMENT ON THAT IS THAT
RESULT FROM BEFORE THE BILL WAS
AMENDED- I DON'T KNOW IT'S NOT
THE LATEST ANALYSIS THAT I HAVE-
ALTHOUGH I DON'T RECALL THAT
THE- SMOKE TODAY BUT I JUST. DID
YOU MAKE SOME CHANGES THAT WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR FINES
AREN'T TOUCH THERE WERE THERE
WERE ORIGINALLY WITH THE BILL
SOME- SOME BREAKING DOWN OF SOME
BUCKETS THAT WERE REQUIRED
FUNDING BUT THAT THAT IS NO
LONGER PART OF THIS BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THE BILL
RIGHTS BEEN MOVED BY SERA. ASSUR
EGGMAN- REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
THIS BILL AND AGAIN YOU KNOW BUT
THIS IS THE LIGHT OF THE ENTIRE
PACKAGE- I CERTAINLY HEAR THE
OPPOSITION- IT'S PERHAPS IT IS
PERHAPS A CONVERSATION THAT
NEEDS TO BE HAD BUT ALSO. IN MY
MIND THAT BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL NOT SAYING
THAT THAT'S NOT IMPORTANT
SESSION WE NEED TO HAVE FUTURE I
KNOW THAT YOU. SERVE AS CHAIR OF
OUR BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE HEALTHY
NEWMAN SERVICES I SERVICE CHAIR
OF HEALTH WE BOTH SERVE TOGETHER
ON EACH OTHER'S COMMITTEES-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY
I HAVE IN MY TIME HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE STRUGGLED A BIT WITH
AND US YOU DON'T THE DESTRUCTION
HAS GROWN OPINIONS ABOUT HOW
THINGS SHOULD BE ORGANIZED AND
SO FORTH. AND I KNOW THAT- YOU
PUT YOU PERHAPS HAVE SOME IDEAS
AS WELL BUT- I ALSO THINK THAT.
BY APPRECIATE WHAT THE
OPPOSITION IS TALKING ABOUT IT'S
A BIT BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SO CERTAINLY
YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS- WHICH ARE CLOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INTENT THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR WORK
ON THIS AND TO THE WITNESSES TO
THE HONORABLE MAYOR STEINBERG
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LIFETIME OF
WORK ON THIS ISSUE- AND I WOULD
AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH COME BACK I'VE BEEN
SAYING THAT. SINCE WE SINCE WE
GOT RID OF IT LIKE SEEMS LIKE
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN WORSE SINCE
WE GOT RID OF IT SO- AMEN I
AGREE- BUT THAT'S NOT THE SCOPE
OF THIS BILL AND SO WE WERE
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN WITHIN
THIS AND I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT
WE DID I DIDN'T LIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR. THAT GAVE
THE OVERSIGHT COMMISSION UP MORE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT ALL THE MONEY
THAT GOES INTO SERVING THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE SO WE DID GIVE THEM
MORE- OVERSIGHT ENTITIES- LAST
YEAR. AND THIS YEAR WE JUST
THINK THAT THE AGENCY HAS MORE
AUTHORITY TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS
AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU SO THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFER TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS HAS BEEN SECONDED
BY CENTER ROCK. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HAND BY
HAND HI MELINDA'S LINDA'S HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ GROVE
HER TADO. LEYVA AYE FLAVOR I.
ROTH HI ROTH I RUBIO. AYE RUBIO
AYE WIENER. SIX MONTHS BY YOUR
VOTES KERN SIX Z. HOLDOVERS. OF
FEDERAL OPEN FOR APPS MEMBERS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- SO LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB ELEVEN FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
ROB. THANKS THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS THIS BILL ESTABLISHES A
REVOLVING LOAN FUND THAT WOULD
PROVIDE BRIDGE FUNDING TO BUILD
ADDITIONAL ACUTE INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC BEDS ONE CRITICAL
PIECE OF OUR ESSENTIAL MENTAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM OF CARE THE
BILL PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
COUNTIES TO ADDRESS A CRITICAL
NEED FOR INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC
CARE WITH THE PROVEN FINANCIAL
METHOD. THAT WORKS IN DEVELOPING
PUBIC INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE AT
A CRITICAL JUNCTURE IN OUR STATE
ON HOW TO ADDRESS THE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. THEY DO
NOT HAVE THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS TREATED FOR SOME.
UNTREATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS SYMBOL OF THEM
DESTITUTE AND HOMELESS.
MEANWHILE IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING
CALIFORNIA IS NOT KEPT UP WITH
DEMAND. A RECENT RAND STUDY
REPORTS THAT CALIFORNIA REQUIRES
FIFTY POINT FIVE INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC BEDS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ADULTS. TWENTY SIX PER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND AT THE
ACUTE CARE LEVEL WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
NOT THERE AND IN MANY CASES WITH
UNFORTUNATE RESULTS. THIS LACK
OF PSYCHIATRIC BED
INFRASTRUCTURE IS PARTICULARLY
ACUTE N HIGH DEMAND AREAS. SUCH
AS THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IN
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOR
EXAMPLE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE
COUNTY HAS EIGHT POINT THREE.
ACUTE CARE PSYCHIATRIC BEDS PER
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE FOR
THE STUDY AND SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
EVEN WORSE AT SIX POINT EIGHT.
THE BILL IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL
THAT CAN PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH
THE CRITICALLY NEEDED FUNDS TO
JUMP START THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE CUTE. PSYCHIATRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE. WANT TO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL AND I'M
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THAT
INCLUDE. THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
DESCRIBED INCOME IN TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS AS TO THE PARTICULAR
CODE SECTIONS. INVOLVED AS WELL
AS AMENDMENTS TO PERMIT COUNTIES
TO APPLY FOR FUNDS TO ADD OR
EXPAND INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC
BEDS AT GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS. AND ACUTE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS BOTH OF WHICH ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL TO EXPAND PSYCHIATRIC
INPATIENT CAPACITY IN A HOSPITAL
SETTING. MOREOVER I INTEND TO
WORK TOWARD ENDING COUNTY
PSYCHIATRIC HEALTH FACILITIES
PHS TO THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL AND CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THE OTHER ISSUES NOTED
IN THE POLICY COMMENTS SECTION.
OF THE ANALYSIS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
. HE SAID A ROUGH- THERE'S
ACTUALLY NO LEAD REGISTERED
SUPPORT- WITNESS FOR TESTIMONY
SO WILL NOW JUST OPEN I UP FOR.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN FORTY THREE PM ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOSH PANAY ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL AND I COMMEND
SENATOR OFF FOR IT WE NEEDED
VERY BADLY THANK YOU. ASSUME
THAT THE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GEORGE SOURIS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU SEE. TWO
MEN REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR.
L. A. R. K. ADLER WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF
AMENDED THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU. DOCTOR SAYS IN PART TO THE
WITH THE HOMELESS HEALTHCARE LA.
AND I SUPPORTED THANK YOU. A
SINGLE NOTES COMING UP TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY THREE NAME OR
POSITION POSITION. THANK YOU.
GERMAN AT YOUR SUPPORT AT ELEVEN
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. OKAY
TAT'S ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT. YOUR
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND YET THE STATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
TRANSPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. I NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES WITH A LINE
NUMBER FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON HELLO.
AFTER A MINUTE THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE YOU GET MADE
IN GENERAL IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AT
ELEVEN FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE ONE WAY FOR NEXT
PARTY THANK YOU. PRETTY LITTLE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TO THE NORTH IN
SIMMER FAVOR. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS THANK YOU THANKS TO A
LIVE NUMBER NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DIDN'T GROSS ON BEHALF
OF THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXPERTNESS.
NEXT WHAT A LINE NUMBER FORTY
NINE THE STORE HAS. FIND FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
WITH A LINE FOR NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES IS THE LIST
THAT I KNOW HARPER I'M CALLING
TO SUPPORT SB ONE ONE FOUR THREE
I APOLOGY WITH SOME SACRAMENTO
AND I AM IN THE FAMILY PROGRAMS.
I'M AND I'M A MOTHER OF A MAN
WHO HAS BEEN IN NEED OF A NEXT
TO HAVE THEIR CARE AND HAD TO
WAIT TOO LONG TO GET ONE THINK
THAT THIS IS A PART THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WITNESS. WHAT'S MORE LATE
INTO IF YOU SUPPORT THAT YOU
FORTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND- AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO
PARTIES IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH MODERATOR WILL NOW
MOVE TO. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN FORTY THREE WE DO
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS REGISTERED SO. WELL DOWN
MOVE IT TO THE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. TINO APPROACHING A
MICROPHONE MATER HELP BUT STIR
SOMEONE PRETTY MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR I'M
- MY NAME IS JANE CRYSTAL CENTER
KERR COUNTY UP HERE WITH FORTY
YEARS LIVED EXPERIENCE
AUTHENTIC- I'M WITH THE USE AN
ARM HERE. OKAY HER EFFORT
SPECIFICALLY FOR FOLKS IN LOCKED
INSTITUTIONS. AND I AM I HAVE
THIS FOR THE SENATORS- YOUR YOUR
POST HELLO I'M I'M- I'M I'M- I'M
OPPOSE. TWO TWO. IT EVERY FAVOR
OF IMPROVING THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ARE LOCKED ON SITUATIONS SO YOUR
CUT YOUR POSTED SB ELEVEN FORTY
THREE CORRECT WE HAVE A STAFF
VACANCY RATE AT 935% THANK YOU
THANK YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN FORTY THREE PM ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. SAYING NINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN
FORTY THREE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'RE NOT
OPPOSITION SPLM FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. THAT'S
ONE ZERO HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
S. P. ONE ONE FOUR THREE. AT THE
TIME WE HAVE NO PARTIES IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE OF
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES CENTER
EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I AM
I'M REALLY PLEASED WITH SENATOR
ROSS BILL A- I. THIK IT SHOULD
BE PART OF MY A BILL PACKAGE.
AND I JUST THINK IT'S ONE MORE
THING THAT WE NEED WE ARE WE ARE
SENDING A LOT OF MONEY DOWN. BUT
THERE ARE WE KNOW THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THIS THIS IS A GREAT KIND OF WAY
TO DO IT SET UP UNDER THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE WHERE. THESE
KINDS OF THINGS EXIST ALREADY-
AND SO. I MOVED ABOUT OKAY THE
MOVE ETCETERA EGGMAN ALERT
POSITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
SEEING NONE. SERA THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND APPRECIATE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS WE TRY TO SURE WE
KEPT THE BILL FOCUSED ON. WHAT
YOUR ORIGINAL TENTS I DO
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE REACHING
OUT TO THE IS TO BE A HEALTH
DIRECTORS AND- AND IN TERMS OF
THEIR- DESIRE TO INCLUDE PRESS
AN ADDITIONAL FACILITIES THE
PARKS AS WELL SO THANKS VERY
MUCH. CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL- GOOD. LOOKING FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU TRYING TO FIND
GET FUNDING IN LINE AS WELL THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD TO LIKE CLOSE.
TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER KERR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO.
ISSUE A VOTE OKAY EXCELLENT SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS AND
SENATE SECONDED BY CENTER EGGMAN
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HAND BY HAND HI MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S AYE EGGMAN. AYE
GONZALEZ GROWTH HER TADO LEYVA
HI LEAVE A HIGHLY MON ROTH AYE
FROTH AYE. RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WIENER. SIX RIGHT TO THE FOR THE
SIX ZERO WILL DOUBLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT.
ALL RIGHT- SO WE ARE WAITING FOR
AUTHORS THE WHILE WE'RE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS LET'S GO BACK
OFFICER PORTANTINO OUT THERE YOU
ARE OKAY EXCELLENT WELCOME ALL
RIGHT I WAS GOING TO GO AND- DO
. ALL RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB TWELVE OH
SEVEN BY CENTER PORTANTINO
WELCOME. THANK YOU- DOCTOR PAN
AND MEMBERS- HAPPY BE PRESENTING
S. B. TWELVE OH SEVEN WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS. JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
WILL PROVIDE THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS TO ENCOURAGE
SCREENING DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT AND MORE REFERRALS.
THE BILL ALSO PROMOTE HEALTH
COVERAGE FOR TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTRACTING
OBSTETRIC PROVIDERS IN EDUCATION
FOR ENROLLEES IN INSURED ABOUT
THE PROGRAM WITH A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CASES OF POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION BEING REPORTED EACH
YEAR. ADEQUATE SUPPORT AND
SERVICES ARE CRUCIAL CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH REPORTS ONE IN FIVE WOMEN
SUFFERED FROM IT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. COVE IT ADDS ANOTHER
LAYER OF COMPLEXITY IN ISOLATION
THAT COULD SUSTAIN SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE THE CREEK RATES OF
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION AND OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS WOMEN
OF COLOR. ARE AMONG THE MOST
AFFECTED SYMPTOMS OF DEPRESSION
ARE TWICE AS COMMON FOR BLACK
AND LATINA WOMEN COMPARED TO
WHITE ASIAN PACIFIC AND WHITE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER WOMEN'S
ADDITIONALLY MOTHERS MAY ALSO
HESITATE TO SEEK HELP BECAUSE OF
STIGMA ASSOCIATED WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ILLNESS. AS WELL AS
CULTURAL EXPECTATIONS
SURROUNDING MOTHERHOOD AND
TRADITIONAL AND OTHER
TRADITIONAL ISSUES. VITAL TO
PROVIDE EXTRA SUPPORT FOR
WOMEN'S MENTAL HEALTH DURING
PREGNANCY AND AFTER CHILDBIRTH
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES TODAY I HAVE
WITH ME SARAH BRIDGE FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
HEALTH DISTRICTS. ALSO THE PRESS
BY SUPPORT ALLIANCE AND
OBVIOUSLY WHEN APPROPRIATE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. HI. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH-
A FIFTY ALL IN ONE MOMENT HERE.
C. SHE SAYS. ALL RIGHT- BACK TO-
HELLO GIVE ME PAUSE HERE. JUST
WAIT THERE FOR A MOMENT OKAY YOU
ARE THE CHAIRED OKAY NOT LONG
AGO NOT ONLY AS LONG AS WITH THE
NECESSARY JUST OKAY SO- THERE
BRIDGES AT THESE PLEASE BEGIN
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES- FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR BOTH WITH THE
SUPPORT WELCOME FREE I THANK YOU
TO DR PAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IS THERE BRIDGE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
HERE BROAD SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE
OH SEVEN BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
I HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ARE A
CRUCIAL PART OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HAVE PUT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND THEIR TOP
THREE PRIORITIES. WE KNOW THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INCIDENT SINCE
COVER NINETEEN ARE EXTREMELY
PERVASIVE AND WE KNOW THAT THEY
ARE PERVASIVE AMONGST MOTHERS
INVOLVED PRENATAL AND POSTPARTUM
AND HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS ARE
SERVICE PRIMARILY UNDER RESOURCE
COMMUNITIES AND RELYING ON THE
STATE TO INVEST IN TOOLS AND
RESOURCES TO SERVICE THEIR
POPULATIONS A MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH THROUGH ISSUES THROUGHOUT
PREGNANCY AND POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION ARE COMMON AND
PERVASIVE THE CDC REPORTS THAT
ONE IN EIGHT WOMEN EXPERIENCE
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION AND OVER
HALF OF WOMEN WITH THESE
CONDITIONS GO UNTREATED. SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN WOULD REVISE THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAM TO INCLUDE
QUALITY MEASURES TO ENCOURAGE
TRAINING DIAGNOSIS REFERRAL
WHICH WILL PROVIDE NECESSARY
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT HOW TO ACCESS
MENTAL MATERNAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS AND
REAFFIRMING THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
HOLISTICALLY IT IS FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT ACOG URGES YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH NOW-
BRING- BEFORE THAT PAUL SIMON
SERVE FROM THE OPPRESSION
DEPRESSION BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IS ON THE
LINE TO MODERATOR TO BRING A
PAUL SIMON'S- ON TO THE LINE. UP
ON TIME AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. OKAY
WHAT PERMANENT HELP YOU MEMBER I
THANK THE UP BEAUTIFULLY
COMMITTEE ARE AT B. FOUR FOUR
SEVEN I AM ALL. OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PROFESSIONAL BY
FORCE FOR FINDING. THINGS OUT
FOR YOU. WE'RE THE LEADING HER
DIRECT TARGET DATE OF THE MOST
PREVALENT AND OFTEN IT. AND FULL
OF WHICH- FOR THE TWENTY ONE
MILLION AMERICAN AT THE A LOT OF
WOMEN IN THEIR CURRENT YEARS.
RECOVERED AND IS FAIRLY HAVE
AFTER THE FROM THE OF PEOPLE
LOOKING AT UP FOR SHE BROUGHT BE
SUSPENDED PREPARED WORKING WITH
PRESS YOU HAVE TO OF PRESIDENT.
OF THE BUTTE PUT. BEING VERY BY
WOMEN THE CARE HERE. BERMAN
HISTORICALLY TO. GROWN FROM THE
PREDNISONE MOTHER MOVED TO. AND
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN MOTOR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE FOR THE CLICK THE
STOP. YEAR'S.
THERE'S A FOLK MUSICIAN WEALTH.
THE PRODUCT OF OFTEN FIFTH
DIDN'T DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
TRAUMATIC FOR. AND A FULL THE
WEEK WANT. AND FINALLY PROVIDE
THE FOOD FOR FREE OAKLEY ENABLE
FOURTH THE LEVEL OF AND VOEPEL
THE PRETTY WOMEN IF IN ORDER TO
BETTER DOCUMENT REPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT. YOU RATHER THAN OF
OFFICE DUE NORTH. THE FIRST PART
OF FRESHMAN HELLO AUTUMN BECAUSE
ALL ALL. THE TIME FREE FOR AND
DID WELL BEFORE PER WHAT. BEEN
OFF.
SEVEN WILL BEGIN HERE ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED ST ON APPROACHING
A MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE OH SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. AND WITH
YOUR SUPPORT SB TWELVE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIDN'T DO IT
THIS TIME. IN THE ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF THAT FEET. WILD
SEVEN. YOUR LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
TWO IT FOR HAT. TAKE CARE RIGHT
AND I'M A HAPPY. HOLIDAY OBGYN
NINE FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. EXTRA LINE NUMBER
NINETY SIX IT HAS. AFTERNOON I'M
FOR IT MALI YES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC IN SUPPORT
DETAILS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NECKED WITH A LINE FOR NINE
STAFF BUT HAS. MCCALL FROM
TWENTY MOM IS FORT. THANK YOU
NECK WITNESS. BUT NUMBER LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN IS WHAT HAS
. JODY BUT NOW CONSUMER. IT
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BUT NOT A LINE NUMBER FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE ARE MANY
MIGHT BE PERMITTED BY THE NUMBER
OF THE I THOUGHT I DID A PROBLEM
I FELT SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WHAT MADE IN GENERAL
YOUR- OF S. B. FOLLOW SEVEN
THESE PRESS ONE UNTIL IT ON. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO PARTY THANK
YOU I THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE A SEVEN- THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS- FOR
TESTIMONY SOLD NOW WAS GO TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AN
OPPOSITIONAL BEGIN HEARING ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. SEEN ON
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONES
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WE SHOULD TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE THOSE
SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
. THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
YOUR OPPOSITION SB TWELVE SEVEN
THESE PRESS ONE BUTTON WHAT SIGN
. OKAYA ONE ZERO PROPER THAT
YOU WANT TO THAT. AT THAT TIME
WE HAVE NO PARTY THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU FOR- ALL RIGHT- SIR
PLEASE COME TO MY PHONE. NAME OR
POSITION POSITION. BACK UP- MY
NAME IS DUSTIN HOLLY- MY FATHER
. A LOT OF THE THAT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ARE CAUSED BY A
LOT OF. SO WHERE DOES THE NAME
WORKSTATION EDITIONS. SO THE
REGULATIONS THAT YOU GUYS PUT IN
PLACE IN OUR SISTER PEOPLE VERY
HARD TO OKAY CERTAINLY JUST
TAKING NAME ORGANIZATION. PLEASE
BUT IT'S YOUR LAWS YOUR
REGULATION RIGHT SORRY SIR.
SORRY SIR SIR OKAY AND FEEL THAT
AGAIN- YEAH YOU CAN SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
SO- PLEASE PLEASE. PUT YOUR
THOUGHTS IN WRITING AND
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE RECORD THANK YOU. AT THIS
POINT WE'RE ONLY TAKING NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION. CASE SAY
NO OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
LET'S BRING BACK MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THERE RUBIO
JUST REALLY QUICKLY I WANT TO
JUST- COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
THAT JUST MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
IS IMPORTANT WE KNOW THAT WOMEN
HAVE STRUGGLED THROUGHOUT
GENERATIONS BUT I KNOW THAT IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE HEARD THE
INCREASE IN MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
AS IT PERTAINS TO- COVE IT IN
KNOW WHEN THEY WERE GOING
THROUGH A PREGNANCY DURING THAT
TIME AND SO MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO BE MINDFUL THAT- WE NEED
TO ENCOURAGE TREATMENT EARLY ON.
AND SO I'M ALSO PROUD CO AUTHOR
AND SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FOR AN ITEM OF THE BELL
OKAY SEVEN MOVE AND RUBIO AND
THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OKAY
THE NINE- SIR PORTANTINO'S AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND- AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE WORK- AND WE'LL
BE SUPPORTING BILL WHICH IKE
THE CLOTHES JUST THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY. SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS HAS
BEEN SECONDED BY CENTER RUBIO
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
PAN HI CAN I MELINDA'S EGGMAN
GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE LEE MON ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO. AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER.
THANK IT'S ZERO PUT THE ON CALL
FOR THE NUMBERS. OKAY SEA CENTER
BECKER HERE. WELCOME SO- WE'RE
GONNA MOVE OUT THE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BY
CENTER BACKERS. WELCOME THANK
YOU. IF YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. THESE MEDICATION WORTH
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS END UP IN
THE GARBAGE EVERY YEAR COULD
RESEARCH CITED BY THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE LEGISLATORS
. POSSIBLE DISCORD OVER THREE
BILLION WORTH OF MEDICATION AND
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES TO
AWAIT ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION
WORTH OF MEDICATION. INSTEAD OF
DISPOSING OF UNUSED MEDICATION
SIX WITH REPOSITORY PROGRAMS
MATE DONATED. TEN OVER TEN YEARS
AGO SANTA CLARA COUNTY BEGIN THE
FIRST COUNTY THE STATE TO SET UP
A REPOSITORY PROGRAM THIS
PROGRAM RECEIVES UNUSED UNOPENED
UNEXPIRED MEDICATIONS FROM
LICENSED HEALTHCARE FACILITIES.
THAT DISPENSE IS AT NO COST TO
PATIENTS WITH A VALID
PRESCRIPTION. BY CLICKING THESE
UNUSED PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
REDISTRIBUTING THEM TO QUALIFY
INDIVIDUALS. PRESCRIPTION DRUG
DONATION AND RES PROGRAMS
INCREASE MEDICATION ACCESS.
ESPECIALLY FOR UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS AND THEY REDUCE
MEDICATION WAY SUCH WAS OUR
FIRST BECAME AWARE OF THIS
ISSUE. TWENTY YEARS AGO THROUGH
NONPROFIT CULTURE MUST BE ONE OF
OUR- WITNESSES BEFORE AND- AND
HAVE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON IT
SINCE THIS TIMES REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS. PROGRAM THE DESPITE
THE GOOD THESE PROGRAMS DO
COMMON OBSTACLES TO PROGRAM
SUCCESS INCLUDE NUMBER ONE
PERSON REQUIREMENTS WHICH IS
PATIENT. TO INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN FOR
AGENCIES AND FACILITIES AMONG-
AND- AMONG OTHERS. THIS IS TO
THINK PERSON REQUIRES VISION AND
CHRISTMAS SHOULD BURDEN AMONG
OTHER ISSUES OKAY WITH THIS BILL
DOES PROVIDE OPERATIONAL
FLEXIBILITY AND ELIMINATES TASKS
THAT DO NOT ENHANCE THE PROGRAM
THE LESS IS UNNECESSARY
RECORDKEEPING REQUIREMENTS. NEWS
OVERLY TRINGENT INVENTORY
REQUIREMENTS. IT WILL THUS
INCREASING OF ENTITIES THE
OPPORTUNE OPERATE A VOLUNTARY
DRUG REPOSITORY PROGRAM. THE
BILL SPONSORED BY SENATOR COUNTY
AND RECEIVE NO RICHARD
OPPOSITION THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THE LINE WE HAVE DOCTOR CON
PHARMACEUTICA COUNTY AND SYRUP
ZERO TWO REPRESENTING ZERO.
THANK YOU CENTER BECKER- ON THAT
SCIENTOLOGY'S LOOK LIKE- AND OF
FOR US SO SHOULD BEEN A MUTE-
SO- MODERATOR OUT PLEASE BRING
ON THE LINE I THINK BOTH
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ARE OUT ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE SO-
BRING FIRST- DOCTOR. AND PHAM
FROM THE COUNTY OF- FAN FROM THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA FOLLOWED
BY ZERO THE BERNARDO FROM ZERO
TO BEGIN WITH DOCTOR FAMINE YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES A TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN BOTH WITNESSES.
I HAVE. NOT AN- ACCOUNT AND A
THIRD. SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
OUR PROPERTY SENATE BILL. THAT
FAMILY WE HAVING SOME HEARING
YOU CAN YOU SPEAK BECAUSE TO THE
MICROPHONE PERHAPS IN YOUR
DEVICE. HELLO YOU HEAR ME- YEAH
CAN YOU DO AS- WE CAN KIND OF
HEAR YOU- THIS. KITA OF YOU
THERE'S A WAY TO SPEAK CLOSER TO
THE MICROPHONE- YEAH I CAN HEAR
YOU NOW YEAH. OKAY AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM NOT PHARMACISTS
AT THE COUNTER CLARA COUNTY
HEALTH SYSTEM THANK YOU
EFFECTIVE FATHER THE SENATE BILL
FIFTEEN SIX AND THANK YOU 4% PAN
MANY MEMBERS BUT UP WITH TO
SPEAK WITH YOU. SENATE BILL
FORTY SIX THE COUNTY FROM THAT
EXTRA LIFE AND IT MADE TO AN
UPPER. BURDENS BY FOR TO PAY AND
- THAT OPERATE MEDICAID THOUGH
NAY NUMBER ISSUED PRO. THE
CHANGES. THOUGHTFUL PROGRAM OF A
WITHIN THE BAND BELLEVILLE OF
THE IS CLARA COUNTY OTHER COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA. THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CLARA HEALTH SYSTEM IS
FULLY INTEGRATED AND
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. OUR SYSTEM
PROVIDES HIGH QUALITY
COMPASSIONATE AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE FOR ALL COUNTY
RESIDENTS AND OFFER HELP IF THIS
IS THE MEDICARE BENEFICIARY AND
OTHER VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. IN TWENTY TEN TO
COUNTY ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
DEDICATED THROUGHOUT THE NATION
PHARMACY IN CALIFORNIA THE
BETTER HEALTH PHARMACY WHICH
AIMS TO INCREASE MEDICATION
ACCESS FOR ALL AND THIRDS
PATIENT. WHO CANNOT AFFORD THE
MEDICATIONS. THAT RECEIVE AND
USE AN OPEN AN UNEXPIRED
MEDICATIONS FROM LICENSED
HEALTHCARE FACILITY. TO DISPENSE
THE DRUG ASIAN WHO HAVE A VALID
PRESCRIPTION AT NO FIVE. THE
FIFTEEN- TO THE END OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWO PERFORM HAS BEEN.
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND FISCAL AND THEY'VE
FOUND. APPROXIMATELY EIGHT FIVE
BILLION INTO OFF. DESPITE THE
FACT THE LETTER PROGRESS THAT IS
ONLY OFF ONE OF THOSE UNDER
COUNTY. APARTMENT A BREAK AT THE
END ALONE FICTIONAL. THAT ONLY
DO DONATED FORMS THAT HAS FOR.
ADMINISTRATIVE AN OPERATE
REQUIREMENTS LOOK AT THAT AND
SHOW THE PROGRAM THAT I FOUND
THE OTHER PHARMA LOOK. AND THE
VERGE MORE AND IT THE
PARTICIPATING IN THE- AND OF THE
FORTY SIX BLOOD BETTER
COMMERCIAL FOR AS AN AS-
OPERATION WITH. SUCH A OVERLY
SPEND AND INVENTORY FROM AS WELL
UNLESS THAT AND ONEROUS I FOR
KEEPING REQUIREMENTS. THIS ISSUE
ARE EXPECTED ONLY FOR THE
FABLESS THE FIVE WITH OTHER
COUNTY FOR ISSUE. BUT BUT IN
ACCESS MEDICAID FOR THE
VULNERABLE AND MEDIC INDUCED
ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU NOW BRING ON SERRA THE BAR
FOR SERRA YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND
THIRTY. SIX SECONDS LEFT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CARE FOR THEM BACK
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THEY'RE BACK THERE I'M FIGURE
OUT TO A POLICY OF THE YOU IF
YOU ON. THE NATIONAL NUMBER
WITHIN THE TO HELP SAVE I NEED
MEDICINE FAMILY IN NEED FEEL AT
TEN YEARS IN THE OPERATE ISING
DRUG FROM ON THE COUNTRY A YEAH. IN PROVIDE EXPERT ADVICE ON
OVER TO BILL REGULATIONS AROUND
THE- INTO THE- FOR ABOUT FIFTY
IS THAT. WATER EXPERT FROM
EXPANSION EFFICIENT. EVER DELETE
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF ALBUM-
BEST REQUIRE PLACED UNNECESSARY
AND COVERED BIRD AND THAT. LIKE
CLARA COUNTY AND- HELP EACH AT
RISK EVEN. HANDED ABOUT THAT.
RAM NUMBER OF ACTIVE ELECTING TO
OPERATE A PROGRAM REDUCE
HEALTHCARE COSTS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF
PHARMACEUTICAL WASTE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY EXPAND ACCESS TO NO
COST MEDICATIONS FOR OUTLOOK
PATIENTS SO THAT THEY CAN BE
HEALTHY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANKS VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX YEAR ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITIONS WELCOME
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL RAT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SPONSOR- DR- THANK YOU THANK YOU
. GEORGE SOROS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SEE NO ONE ELSE COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ZERO SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. WHAT A ONE OVER SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT SHALL
RIVAS BUT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. SIX ONE NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO SIMILAR
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. IT WAS VIOLATED JANET
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO PARTIES IN Q.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FOR
TESTIMONY- REGISTERED SO WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED NAME WORKSTATION
POSITION. AGILA ARE LATE
RESIDENT OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY
A. K. A. THE BELLY OF THE BEAST
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. I THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. GEN CRYSTAL
PIER FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY. ON
DRUGS DO NOT EQUAL RECOVERY. AYE
OPPOSED ON ON THAT POINT THANK
YOU I'D SAY NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR IT
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. NAME ORGANISATION VISIT.
REGULATE GERMAN IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITION AS HE THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND DO IT
THIS TIME. OKAY ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB. THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. AT THE TIME WE HAVE BILL
PARTY THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
WELL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SERRATA SIR
RUBIO. S. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR JOINING- TO BRING FOR THIS
MEASURE OF THIS IS- OF SOMEWHAT
A GREAT COMPLIMENT TO A BILL I
HAD LAST YEAR THAT. ARE CREATED-
CANCER MEDICATION RECYCLING
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S JUST A
TRAVESTY THAT THERE'S SO MANY
PEOPLE IN NEED THAT ARE DYING
THAT THE MEDICATION. AND YET
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE THROW AWAY
SUCH. NO GOOD ON USE MEDICATION
AND SO I THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE
START CONSIDERING. I KNOW THESE
TYPES OF PROGRAMS IN A MUCH
BROADER WAY BECAUSE- WE NEED TO
SAVE LIVES- LAST YEAR WHEN I
SPOKE TO A GENTLEMAN HE HAD. I
BELIEVE IT WAS THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS WORTH OF CANCER
MEDICATION FOR HIS WIFE THAT
HAD. PASSED AWAY BUT HE AND
TRANSFER. TRANSFERRED OVER TO
SOMEONE THAT ACTUALLY NEEDED THE
MEDICATION SO. YOU KNOW A LOT
OF. OUR LIVES ARE GOING TO BE
SAFE SO I AM A CHOI- I'M SORRY A
CO AUTHOR AND I'D LIKE TO OF
SOME OF THE BILL THANK YOU VERY.
ARE EXPENDABLE MOVED- OPPOSITE
R. REVEALS. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SEE NONE OF THEIR
BAKER ADDS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND
AG ADN REALLY APPRECIATES THE
EFFECTS AND RUBIO. CAPTURED A
LOT OF WHAT I'M ALSO THINKING AS
WELL- AND SIMPLY SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WHICH LIKE CLOSE. YEAH
THANK YOU CENTER ROOM THREE
WORKING CAN MEDICARE. AND FOR
THE- THE SUPPORT HERE TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH- SO IT'S-
SO THE MOTION IS. TO PASS ON
BEFORE I GET THAT RIGHT JUST TO
PASS IT HAS BEEN SELECTED BY
BOTH CENTERS ROTH AND RUBIO-
CONSOLE WOULD YOU LIKE TO COULD
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN BY
PAN BY MELINDA'S. ON THIS AYE
EGGMAN. GONZALEZ GROVE HER TADO.
LEYVA HI LEYVA HIGHLY MON ROTH
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE. RUBIO AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. SO YEP OKAY-
CARRILLO TO SIX ZERO HOLD THE
BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
K. THIS I DON'T SEE ANY OTHERS
IN THE ROOM- SO WE'LL GET LET'S
GO BACK TO ACTUALLY CENTER DODD
STILL BECAUSE SAID THE TIME WE
DID NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER THREE. SB NINE
SEVENTY NINE I GUESS TECHNICALLY
CENTER EGGMAN SAID SHEETS MOVE
THE BILL WHICH IS NOT PRESIDENT
BUT- OKAY WILL BE. SCIENCE
CENTER OFFICE WITH THE BILL.
NONE OF THE NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM
THE THIRD. AND WE DIDN'T GET
ENOUGH THAT'S WHY. THAT'S WHY WE
THE ISSUE CENTER ON NOW TO BUILD
WILL HELP CELLS THE THREAT YES
TO DOING. THAT CREATE THAT OKAY
SOME BILLS AND MOVE AYE SERA
THAT'S WHAT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN HI CAN
FIND MELINDA'S BELINDA'S AYE
EGGMAN GONZALEZ HELLO. HER TADO
LEYVA. LEAVE BEHIND THE MOON
ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WE- HI WIENER HI OKAY SO THAT
CURRENTLY SIX AT SIXTEEN HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
OKAY SO WE ARE NOW WAITING FOR
AUTHORS- PLEASE HAVE THE ITEM
NUMBER TEN SERVE THEM MCGUIRE
WITH THE NEXT IF HE SHOWS UP. HE
SAID HE OVER RIGHT NOW
EXCELLENCE AND THEN I JUST MAKE
NOTE THAT CENTCOM LONGER WOULD
BE FOLLOWING AFTER THAT IN THE-
AGENDA. AND.
CENTER MCGUIRE WELCOME. SO WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY
SIR MCGUIRE WELCOME. FOR I WOULD
TELL YOU NOT TO RUSH BUT I THINK
THE RUSSIAN EVERYWHERE. WE LIVE
WITH EVERY DAY. HEY FIRST AND
FOREMOST JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF MISTER CHAIR- AND
WAS JUST COMING OVER FROM EQ
SIDE COLLEGE ICE ABOUT KEEPING
YOU WAITING. FIRST AND FOREMOST
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE CHAIR IN HIS TREMENDOUS
STAFF FOR THE WORK ON THIS
LEGISLATION WE WOULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY WITH A BETTER BAIL OUT
WITHOUT DOCTOR PAN AYE AND OF
COURSE WE WILL BE TAKING. THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY.
MEMBERS YOU DO NOT NEED TO WALK
FAR OUT OF THIS BUILDING OR IN
YOUR HOME TOWN YOU KNOW THAT
WE'RE FACING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS
ARE STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE AND FOR RIGHT REASONS.
MANY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT WHICH CAN LEAD TO
INCREASED. RISK OF UNEMPLOYMENT
HOMELESSNESS SUICIDE IN
SUBSTANCE ABUSE. IN ONE OF THE
LEADING MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
THAT CAN IMPACT A PERSON'S
ABILITY TO LIVE A NORMAL LIFE.
IS WHEN A PERSON EXPERIENCES OF
PSYCHOSIS EPISODE. BECAUSE THIS
IS A FEW SEVERE MENTAL DISORDER
WHERE THOUGHTS AND PERCEPTIONS
ARE SO IMPAIRED THAT INDIVIDUAL
TRULY LOSES TOUCH WITH REALITY.
EARLY PSYCHOSIS IS CONFUSING AND
FRIGHTENING FOR THE PERSON WHO'S
EXPERIENCING IT. AND RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THAT THREE OUT OF EVERY
ONE HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE AN
EPISODE AT SOME POINT IN THEIR
LIFE. IT WITHOUT MEDICAL
INTERVENTION CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCING PSYCHOSIS. HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. THE MOST
EFFECTIVE IN ONLY EVIDENCE BASED
SUPPORT FOR THIS CONDITION IS
CALLED COORDINATED SPECIALTY
CARE. IT'S ALSO CALLED THE C. S.
C. S. C. S. C. MODEL FOR SHORT.
IT CREATES A PERSONALIZED
TREATMENT PLAN. RAVAL SERVICE.
TO GET LONGER MIDDLE HEALTH CARE
ACT TO HOUSING ASSISTANCE WITH
THAT YOU. AND VOCATIONAL GOALS
THE PROBLEM IS MOST PRIVATE PAY
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND HEALTH
PLANS DON'T PROVIDE THIS TYPE OF
TREATMENT. SO THIS IS WHAT THE
BILL WOULD DO IT ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND HEALTH PLANS COVER CSE AS A
TREATMENT FOR EARLY PSYCHOSIS.
BY JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. CURRENTLY THERE
ARE MANY YOUNG PATIENTS TO
EXPERIENCE- THE PSYCHOSIS
THEY'RE NOT BEING TREATED AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO THIS
MODEL WHICH REASSURED RESEARCH
SHOWS CAN HELP. PATIENTS LIVE
HEALTHY FUNCTIONALIZED IN EARLY
PSYCHOSIS IF YOU HAVE NOT SEEN
IT. YOU HAVE A PERSONAL FRIEND
WHO IS EXPERIENCE IT. IS HEART
BREAKING. AND PARA IMPACTS TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS. SO WE KNOW
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE WE NEED TO
GUARANTEE ACCESS TO MIDDLE
HEALTHCARE IN COORDINATED
SPECIALTY CARE IS A LIFE SAVING
TREATMENT WHICH CAN LITERALLY
SAVE A PERSON'S LIFE AND IT'S
TIME FOR HEALTH PLANS IS. YOU
KNOW NOT TRYING TO CALL ANYONE
OUT BUT I JUST WANNA SHARE THE
FRUSTRATION PERSONALLY. SO WITH
HOLDEN IS MEDICALLY NECESSARY
CARE TO THOSE SUFFERING FROM THE
TRAUMATIC DISEASES APPALLING. IN
IN THE CSU MODEL TEAM THAT
INCLUDES A PRIMARY CARE
CONDITIONS LIKE HIGH INTEREST
THE CASE MANAGER ALL GO TO WORK
TO BE A TO HELP THOSE GOING
THROUGH THE EPISODE. FOR EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT FOR EVERY DOLLAR
SPENT ON CARE DELIVERED IN THE
CCS MODEL THERE'S A SIX DOLLAR
AND FIFTY CENT RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IN IMPROVED HEALTH
AND PRODUCTIVITY. COMMERCIAL
HEALTH PLANS MAY SAY THAT THIS
BILL IS TO DETAIL BUT THANKS TO
THE AMENDMENTS THAT DOCTOR PAN
IS OFFERED- IT GREATLY REDUCES
THE DETAILED NATURE OF THIS
BILL. CAN YOU MAY ALSO HEAR THAT
WE SHOULD WAIT UNTIL TIED THE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
AND IS GOING TO SHARE MY
FRUSTRATION WITH THAT. NONE OF
US NEED ANYMORE STUDIES. YOU
DON'T NEED ANY MORE PROJECTS TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. IN OUR STATE
TODAY. THE ACA. THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT IN THE MIDDLE HEALTH
CARE TO. MIDDLE HEALTHCARE
DIRECTIVES CLEAR. MENTAL HEALTH
CARE MUST BE COVERED YET A
DECADE LATER WE'RE HERE. IN
DOCTOR PAINS HEALTH COMMITTEE
STILL DEBATING WHAT'S IN AND
WHAT'S NOT. AND IN THE MEANTIME
THOUSANDS IN THE CITY CONTINUE
TO SUFFER. AND THIS BEING HONEST
WE PUT PROFITS OVER PEOPLE. WITH
OVER EIGHTY STUDIES
DEMONSTRATING THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THIS CARE MODEL. WE MUST
MOVE. IN WE NO LONGER CAN DELAY.
IN ENSURING THAT THIS JOB IS
DONE- AND WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF A PAIN WE DO HAVE.
TWO WITNESSES WHO. HERE IN
SUPPORT TODAY. OKAY THANKS VERY
. SIR REQUIRE- WE HAVE ACTUALLY
THINK BELIEVE THEY'RE BOTH IN
PERSON SO WE HAVE BODY HOLDS A-
AND ALSO DOCTOR TERRA. IN THEM-
SO EACH OF YOU HAVE. TO CLOSE
WITH A FEW OF TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
EACH TO HAVE TWO MINUTES WELL
TWO MINUTES BOTH SIDES OF FOR
THE FIRST BIGGER SPEAKS WHEN IT
TWO MINUTES I'LL SAY TWO
MINUTES. ANY ADDITIONAL TIME
GOING OVER THAT COMES OUT THE
OTHER PERSON'S TIME SO. JUST
KEEP THAT BE VERY CONSCIOUS OF
THAT- BUT YOU KNOW IT'S TWO
MINUTES SO WITH THAT- WELCOME
AND THAT PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND BEGIN. THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON. WHEN I WAS
INVITED TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT MY FAMILY'S EXPERIENCE
WITH THE COORDINATED SPECIALLY
CARE MODEL FOR FIRST EPISODES
PSYCHOSIS. I IMMEDIATELY SAID
YES AND WHY BECAUSE MY DAUGHTER
IS ONE OF THE LIVES THAT IT WAS
SAVED BY THIS INNOVATIVE
TREATMENT MODEL. RACHEL WAS JUST
FOURTEEN AND IT JUST STARTED
HIGH SCHOOL. WITH ALL HER DUCKS
IN A ROW SHE WAS PROUD OF A FOUR
POINT OH GPA. SHE HAD A PASSION
FOR MUSIC AND WON AWARDS STATE.
WIDE AND LOCALLY FOR HER FLU
PLANE SHE WAS A TALENTED
VOLLEYBALL PLAYER. WITHIN A FEW
SHORT MONTHS THOUGH ALL THIS
STARTED TO CHANGE AS DID RACHEL
HERSELF. ONCE LOVING HIGH
ACHIEVING AND FOCUSED SHE BECAME
WITHDRAWN DISORGANIZED. AN
AGGRESSIVE ALARMED MY HUSBAND
AND I DID WHAT ANY PARENTS WOULD
DO WE'D MET WITH HER TEACHERS
THE SCHOOL COUNSELOR WE
CONSULTED WITH HER PEDIATRICIAN
TOOK HER TO A PSYCHIATRIST
ENGAGED HER IN THERAPY. ALL TO
NO AVAIL NOTHING HELPED. WHEN WE
STUMBLED UPON THE UC DAVIS EAT
OUT CLINIC ALMOST EIGHTEEN LONG
MONTHS LATER. RACHEL WAS DEEP
INTO SELF HARM AND THOUGHTS OF
KILLING HERSELF. YET THE CSU
TEAM THERE WAS ABLE TO QUICKLY
ROLL BACK HER MOST SERIOUS
SYMPTOMS AND SET HER AND US HER
FAMILY ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY.
CSC WORKS IT DOES. I KNOW THIS
FROM THE UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OF A
PARENT WHO HAS GONE THROUGH CSE
TREATMENT WITH HER OWN CHILD. AS
WELL AS A RATHER UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE AS ALSO LATER HAVING
WORKED AS PART OF A CSU TEAM AT
UC DAVIS. HELPING OTHER FAMILIES
NAVIGATE THIS VERY DIFFICULT
ROAD WITH THEIR CHILDREN WHEN
THE TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
APPROACHES THAT THEY- TRIED HAD
FALLEN SHORT. AS A SENATOR
REQUIRE SAID THE ONSET OF
PSYCHOSIS IN A CHILD. IS
DEVASTATING IT DISRUPTS OUR
DEVELOPMENTS THEIR EDUCATION AND
THEIR FUTURE AND CAN BE
OVERWHELMING FOR THE STRONGEST
OF FAMILIES. EARLY INTERVENTION
WITH CSC OFFERS THE BEST CHANCE
FOR RECOVERY SO ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TWO
MINUTES DESPERATE FOR THIS LIFE
FLYING LIKE MY FAMILY WAS SO
MANY YEARS AGO I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ARE NOW WITH THE DOCTOR AND
THE NUMB- YOUR LOW SHORT ON TWO
MINUTES HRE THAT'S OKAY- THANK
YOU SO MUCH- I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
PROGRAMS AT UC DAVIS HEALTH I
JUST NEED TO BE CLEAR THAT I'M
HERE TESTIFYING TODAY AS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND NOT
REPRESENTING THE UC'S
PERSPECTIVE. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
WHAT SENATOR MCGUIRE SAID THIS
DISORDER CONTRIBUTES TO
HOMELESSNESS INCARCERATION LOST.
LIVES IN TERMS OF WORK AND
SCHOOL ATTAINMENT I AM SO PROUD
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE FAMILIES
LIKE BONNIE'S FAMILY AND HELP
THEIR YOUNG PEOPLE RECOVER AND
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR I HAVE A MEDIC CAL
PROGRAM IN A COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE PROGRAM I CAN GIVE THE
ROLLS ROYCE OF CARE IF YOU WALK
IN AND YOU HAVE MEDICARE. IT IS
A REVERSE DISPARITY IF YOU COME
IN WITH INSURANCE I TRY MY BEST
TO COBBLE THINGS TOGETHER BUT MY
CLINICIANS DON'T GET PAID IF YOU
CALL ME IN CRISIS THEY ONLY GET
PAID IF THEY SEE YOU IN PERSON
OR VIA TELEHEALTH. SO WE CAN'T
PROVIDE THE SERVICES I NEED TO
HELP ALLIES DOES YOUR- SO I
REALLY WANT TO COMMEND SENATOR
REQUIRE FOR SUPPORTING US IN
THIS BILL BECAUSE 60% OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE. 60% OF KIDS WHO CAN'T
GET CARE. 2% OF KIDS WHOSE
PARENTS CRIED CALLED ME CRYING
WHEN I TOLD THEM THEY CAN'T
ACCESS MY CLINIC IT IS SO
UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU ALL HAVE
THE POWER TO MAKE THAT CHANGE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU GUYS
FOR A BOOK AND READ UP ALL
RIGHT- SO- NOW IF YOUR FROM
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. MICHELLE
CABINET WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS THIS
. OF CALIFORNIANS. SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THIS MEMBER- PAUL WE HAVE
CALIFORNIA SO. SAIKAI TO BE
PARTNERING WITH MCGUIRE THIS
BILL- DR- THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR SUSAN PART TO BE FROM
HOMELESS HEALTH CARE LOS ANGELES
THE SOUNDS GREAT AMAZING. ALL
RIGHT EXCELLENT SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONES-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
. THANK YOU THE GENTLEMAN AT
YOUR SUPPORT AT THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN IT'S PAST. DUE AT THIS
TIME. THAT'S ONE ZERO CHOSE
ORDER SB THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE.
BRING A LARGE NUMBER NINETY. THE
SPORT. ONE BUT NUMBER NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BARTY
COUNTY FARM FONG REPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. EXCELLENT ONE
FOR FIFTY AHEAD. AFTERNOON
ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR FOLLOW
UP REPURPOSE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. EXCELLENT
NUMBER SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON I'M IN THE BILL WITH
THE COUNTY COUNCIL NEEDS IF
HEALTH AGENCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER ONE
NUMBER EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BUT ALL
THROUGH. BUT MOST OF ALL BUT THE
CHILD WITH THIS MONEY DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU
THANK WITH THIS. AND IT REMINDED
LATE GENEROUSLY BY SUPPORT OF S.
THIRTY THIRTY HE'S PRESS ONE TO
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE NO PARTIES IN Q. RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
NOW MOVE INTO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WE DO HAVE TO REGISTERED
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE A BEGIN WITH
THE NECKLACES FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS PRESS
AND YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. TWO MINUTES
FOR MEDICAL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NICK LOUISE'S WITH A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS AND- I REGRETTABLY WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN- STARTING GLOBALLY- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- YOU KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS GENERALLY OPPOSES NEW
BENEFIT MANDATES- AND THE REASON
WE OPPOSE HIM IS BECAUSE THE
IMPACT THE AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH HEALTH CARE. OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM RECENTLY ISSUED A
CUMULATIVE IMPACT REPORT OF ALL
OF THE MANDATES THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR. AND THAT TOTALS A PREMIUM
INCREASE OF ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS- AND THAT
DOESN'T EVEN COUNT S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE WHICH WILL BE
HEARING LATER ON IN COMMITTEE
TODAY WHICH ADDS ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
PREMIUM INCREASES. ON
INDIVIDUALS AND EMPLOYERS. NOW
ZEROING IN ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL- YOU KNOW IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT YOU KNOW HEALTH PLANS
ARE REQUIRED TO COVER EVERY
CONDITION IN THE DSM FIVE- IN
SUBSEQUENT EDITIONS OF THAT
MANUAL FOR PSYCHOSIS IS ONE OF
THOSE DISORDERS. ON THAT IS
INCLUDED IN THAT MANUAL SO THE
CONDITION IS COVERED THE ISSUE
WE HAVE WITH THIS BILL IS THAT-
WELL YOUR STAFF ANALYSIS
ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW HITS THE NAIL
ON THE HEAD. THERE IS A LACK OF
EVIDENCE OF THIS MODEL'S LONG
TERM EFFECTIVENESS SO WHAT THIS
BILL TRIES TO DO IS. TAKE WHAT'S
ALREADY COVERED AND A
STATUTORILY MANDATE A
PARTICULAR- MODEL OR MAP OF
COVERING THE DISORDER AS OPPOSED
TO- YOU KNOW MANDATING. A
SERVICE AND SO THE MEDICAL
DIRECTORS AND OUR PLANS ARE
OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE- SCIENCE EVOLVES- YOU
KNOW RESEARCH EVOLVES THERE
COULD BE EVIDENCE BASED.
TECHNIQUES BETTER BETTER IN THE
FUTURE AND SO WE WOULD TO DO TO
PUT LAW. THE SPECIFIC MAN. ANY
SPECIFIC MODEL OF CARE- THAT MAY
CHANGE OVER TIME I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING TAKEN
TO THEY'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT IT'S STILL REFERS TO A-
SPECIFIC- MANUAL AM IN IN MY IN
MODE OF CARE SO THAT THAT THAT'S
WHAT CONCERNS OUR MEMBERS- YOU
KNOW ON THE- BACK ON THE COST
ISSUE YOU KNOW THE- THIS DOES
REPRESENT A SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLAR PREMIUM INCREASE. FOR
PLANTS NOT IT'S NOT THE MOST
EXPENSIVE MANDATE BILL- BUT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THESE BILLS
SO WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE IT YOU
LOOK FOR TO. FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS OF STAFF AND SPONSORS
REACHING OUT EARLY ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH ANOTHER SPRING
UP- PERSON YOUNG FROM CALIFORNIA
RECOVERS WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AS IT.
APPEARS IN PRINT. LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR STAFF COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT HAS GONE INTO THIS BILL.
I'M IN AN EFFORT TO AVOID
REDUNDANCY- YOU. MISTER LOUISA'S
TALKED ABOUT COST CONCERNS WITH
THE MANDATE BILLS CORRECT THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE IN OPPOSITION IS
BECAUSE OF THE COST CONCERNS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL THAT
YOU BERMAN ALICE'S FOR EMPLOYER
RELATED PREMIUMS. PAID THAT
INCREASE OF THE BILL WENT INTO
EFFECT AS IT WAS ANALYZED AT THE
TIME. AS BEING A FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE IN THE EMPLOYEE
PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE OVER
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS SO- IN
ISOLATION OBVIOUSLY NOT A HUGE
DEAL. COLLECTIVELY IN IN THE
AGGREGATE WITH ALL THE ME IN THE
BILLS WE SEE THIS YEAR. THAT
DOES HAVE A BIGGER IMPACT SO
THAT'S THE CONCERN- IN THE
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE COMING FROM
HERE. AGAIN A RESPECT THE
INTENTION BILL. AND APPRECIATE
THE TIME OF THE CONSIDERATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK FOR
NOW TAKE ON IT- THIS WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. SHARE MEMBERS JOHN
LINGER ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS ARE JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS A CAP. I THANK
YOU. THE AGILA FOUNDER OF HOPE
DEALERS IN ACTION AND WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY. J. CRYSTAL
PIER SENATE HER CARRY ON IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THERE ARE
BETTER MODELS THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATED. OKAY SEEN ON US
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
WITHOUT A MODERATOR- PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES THE FOUR WITNESSES WHO
WOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY IT'S PAST WANTON
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IT'S
ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE OPPOSITION TO
SB. THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. BRING
THE LINE FOR ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAMBERS HE WHAT
INVOLVED THE HAPPIEST OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE NEEDS AND OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SIX WITNESS. AND OCE
AGAIN MADE IN GENERAL IF YOU ARE
OPPOSITION S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE NO
PARTY THANK YOU. I THANK YOU FOR
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THINK- THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD I
THINK IT'S REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOUR TO. LEAVE WITNESSES
FOR REALLY BRINGING HOME THE
ISSUE AND JUST REALLY GIVING US
AN EXCELLENT EXAMPLE OF WHY THIS
IS NEEDED SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE. OF THE
BILL INAPPROPRIATE ALL RIGHTS
BEEN MOVED BY- SIR LEYVA A
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- I AS I
WORKED A LITTLE BIT IN THIS
SPACE BEFORE AND VISITED THE
VERY FINE PROGRAM AT UC DAVIS
SO. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND I WAS UP THERE IN
ANOTHER MEETING AND MY STUFF
THAT I SHOULD GET DOWN HERE. SO
I CAN HAS TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY.
SARATH THANK YOU MISTER JUST
CURIOUS I'VE READ THE VARIOUS OF
. BILL ANALYSIS HAVING TO DO
WITH MANDATES ON THE- INSURANCE
HEALTH CARE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
AND CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND AND
RESPECT THE OPPOSITION IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO PROCESS THOUGH THE
IMPACT ON EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE
PREMIUMS WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FORTY ONE MILLION OR
SEVENTEEN MILLION COULD SOMEBODY
. SO TO BOIL THAT DOWN FOR ME
AND TELL ME WHAT THE- ACTUAL
IMPACT WOULD BE ON AN EMPLOYEE
WHO'S HAVING TO PAY A PREMIUM OR
AN EMPLOYER WHO'S HAVING TO PAY
A PREMIUM. SO ACTUALLY I BELIEVE
WE DO HAVE SUCH ABOUT THE
QUESTION UP- JOHN LEWIS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM- THAT KILL IS
MISTER LEWIS IS JOHN LEWIS ON
THE LINE. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM. THIS IS
JOHN LEWIS ALL RIGHT I'M- OF
THOSE WHICH BURKE YOU HEAR ME
YES IF YOU WISH TO PLEASE A
ADDRESS US A ROUGH QUESTION.
OKAY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
REPORTED TO WORK LOOK AT IT FOR
NOW THERE'S- ACTUALLY GIVES THE
MEMBER PER MONTH. INCREASE OF
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE. IN
THE AREA- MARC EGGMAN. SO IT'S-
JERRY IT'S PROBABLY THE DANGER
OF. EIGHT AM REMEMBER FROM- UP
TO. FIFTY TWO YEAH REMEMBER PER
MONTH THE KIND OF INCREASED THAT
WOULD BE EXPECTED. HELPFUL
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS TO FIFTY TWO
CENTS PER EMPLOYEE PER MONTH- ON
THE EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTION WHAT'S
THE EMPLOYER SHARE- THAT WOULD
VERY FIRST ON P. THE EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE RELATIONSHIP NUMBERS
THE TOTAL WOULD BE SHARED
BETWEEN THE EMPLOYER BUT HE-
WHEN THERE IS AN EMPLOYER LIKE.
WILDLIFE INDIVIDUAL MARKET WITH
THE- WORN BY THE PERSON THIS
PROJECT AND BY THE- ICC THE
THIRTY EIGHT CENTS TO FIFTY TWO
CENT PER MONTH INCLUDE PREMIUM
INCREASE WOULD EITHER BE BORNE
SOLELY BY THE EMPLOYEE OR SHARED
OR SPLIT BETWEEN THE EMPLOYEE
AND THE- EMPLOYER IF THERE'S A-
PREMIUM SHARING ARRANGEMENT.
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU THAT
ANSWERS MY QUESTION THANK YOU MR
. ALL RIGHT OKAY YES- SO RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ANYTHING
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT ACCESS TO
A GOOD CARE IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I ALSO WANT TO JUST THINK
THE FAMILY WHO STRICTER PERSONAL
STRUGGLES AND STORIES I KNOW
SOMETIMES WE- WE DON'T
NECESSARILY GET TO HEAR SOMEONE
LIKE YOU KNOW THAT THE LADY WHO
SHARED THE STORY ABOUT HER
DAUGHTER I KNOW I HAVE CASES YOU
KNOW AS A- FORMER TEACHER OF
STUDENTS WHO. YOU KNOW OUR HIGH
PERFORMING HIGH FUNCTIONING AND
THEN YOU KNOW SOMETHING HAPPENED
BETWEEN THE ONLY THING THAT I
WOULD ADD- DID THIS JUST IN
LIGHT OF SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE JUST EXPRESS RIGHT NOW
IS YOU KNOW MAYBE THE ABILITY TO
INCLUDE A REVIEW PROCESS IN
LIGHT OF EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY
PROGRAMS AND THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW. THAT WE LEARNED LATER SO
SOME KIND OF REVIEW PROCESS THAT
MAYBE YOU KNOW LOOKS BACK AND
SEE IF YEARS FROM NOW IF IT'S
BEEN EFFECTIVE IN IS THERE
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE
IS A LEGISLATIVE BODY BUT THAT'S
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD THAT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE
YOU KNOW ACCESS AND TAKE THE
FAMILY FOR COMING FORWARD AND
SHARING THEIR PERSONAL STRUGGLES
THANK YOU. THANK ARE SEVERAL
OTHERS. THANK YOU MISTER. I'M A
SINNER. IF YOU WOULDN'T AND IN
THE- HAS- MADE CLAIMS THAT THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL
ARE DUPLICATIVE AND I WONDER. IF
THEY COULD ELABORATE ON THAT-
AND THEN PERHAPS HEAR YOUR VIEWS
ON THAT. I MEAN I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU SAID THAT THERE ARE
ALREADY SOME PROGRAMS IN PLACE
BECAUSE JUDITH A LITTLE MEAT ON
THE BONES FOR MEDIA ASHER
SENATORS SO- IN TERMS OF BEING
DUPLICATED I THINK WHAT I MEANT
WAS THAT PSYCHOSIS IS CURRENTLY
COVERED. YOU KNOW AS A DISORDER
UNDER THE DSM FIVE- IN
SUBSEQUENT. EDITIONS OF THAT OF%
THAT MANUAL- AND AGAIN WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT MANDATES A SPECIFIC
MODEL OF CARE FOR THAT DISORDER.
AND YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW ALL
THE DETAILS BUT ONE OF MY HEALTH
PLANS THE KAISER PERMANENTE A
IS. OPERATING A PILOT PROGRAM
CURRENTLY- IN THE NAPA SONOMA-
AREA. I ACTUALLY BELIEVE MIGHT
BE A LITTLE BROADER THAN THAT
GEOGRAPHICALLY BUT ANY CASE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IS THEY'RE TESTING
OUT THIS PARTICULAR MODEL OF
CARE IN TO SEE IF IT WORKS AND
SO- DO YOU TO YOURPOINT ABOUT
WHETHER THIS IS PREMATURE NOT I
THINK YOU KNOW. SINCE THERE IS
AN EXISTING PILOT PROGRAM IN
PLACE YOU KNOW WE SHOULD SEE
WITH THAT YIELDS YOU KNOW BEFORE
WE ACTUALLY GET TO THIS LEVEL
SPECIFICITY INTO LAW. THANK YOU
. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER.
WOULD YOU MIND- ALSO GIVING
COMMENT ON YOU KNOW THE FACT
THAT PSYCHOSIS IS ALREADY
COVERED- AND HOW THIS BILL WOULD
IMPROVE THE SITUATION. SO HERE'S
WHERE I AGREE I'M GOING TO TURN
OUR ATTENTION TO THE CENTRAL
HEALTH BENEFIT UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT. MIDDLE
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENTS MUST BE COVERED
UNDERNEATH THAT. THIS ISN'T.
IT'S NOT BEING COVERED WE CAN
REFER BACK TO THAT KAISER STUDY
NAPA SOLANO AND SONOMA COUNTIES
THE TIE THE PROJECT LET ME JUST
BE REALLY CAN'T DENY LIVES IN
THAT REGION. THAT REGION OF
KAISER AND I'M A FULL DISCLOSURE
KAISER PATIENT THEY HAVE HAD
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES WHEN IT
COMES TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WITHIN THAT REGION OF KAISER.
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES. AND JUST
BEING REALLY BLUNT ABOUT IT HOW
MANY STUDIES IMPACT THEIR PARTY
SO WE NEED TO KNOW WHAT WE NEED
TO DO. WE KNOW THAT THE ONLY THE
ONLY PEER REVIEWED. TREATMENT IS
C. S. C. S. AND IT'S NOT BEING
PROVIDED. THE ONLY WAY TO BE
ABLE TO IF AN INDIVIDUAL HAS OUR
FIRST PSYCHOSIS EPISODE IS TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEM THE WRAPAROUND
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
AND WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IF WE
DON'T GET THAT WRAP AROUND
TREATMENT. IS THAT IT LEADS TO.
LOSING A JOB. HOMELESSNESS IN
SOME CITIES. AND THAT'S REMEMBER
WHAT WE'RE SPENDING THIS YEAR
FOR HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
FOURTEEN BILLION. FOR WILLING TO
WRAP MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
SERVICES AROUND EACH OF THOSE
FIFTY THOUSAND UNITS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE DANCING BUT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO SPEND THIRTY EIGHT TO
FIFTY TWO CENTS A MONTH TO BE A
PROVIDE THE REFERENCE SERVICES
SOMEONE NEEDS TO HAVE A
PSYCHOSIS EPISODE. THE POLY.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT. PEOPLE IT'S
TALKING ABOUT PROFIT IT'S
ALREADY COVERED WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IS RIDICULOUS WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE DEBATES
WHEN WE KNOW THE ACA SUPPOSED TO
BE COVERING THIS SO I'M NOT AT
ALL TRYING TO GET HOT SYMBOL IT
IS A YOU AT ALL- BUT I'M JUST
SHARING MY FRUSTRATION THAT
LITERALLY WE HAD THE MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY ACT THAT WE
THOUGHT WERE GOING TO GET THIS
SOLVED THEN WE HAVE THE ACA AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SOLVE. AND
NOW WE'RE BACK HERE IN HEALTH
COMMITTEE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IF THIS IS GONNA BE COVERED BY
THE HEALTH PLANS OR NOT IT NEEDS
TO BE AND WOULD ASK FOR AN ADULT
SO WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IT OR
YOU'RE NOT DISPUTING THE FACT
THAT IT IS. TECHNICALLY COVERED
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS. THE PLANS
ARE ACTUALLY PROVIDING. THE
COVERAGE IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE-
SAYING OKAY- SO- I. WELL WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PROVIDERS
REALLY TO ADDRESS THE NEED I
MEAN. I KNOW YOUR BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT BUT WE JUST WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
ATTEND TO THE NEEDS OF ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT AND I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT- WHEN YOUR BILLS
NOT TRYING TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
I'M JUST SUGGESTING THAT- WITH
THIS BILL. THOUGH IT REQUIRES
THE PLANS TO PROVIDE THE
COVERAGE IT'S NOT A GUARANTEE
THAT ONE WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY LIVE BUT
AGAIN THAT'S NOT WHAT YOUR BILL
IS TRYING TO SOLVE- THAT THE
ONLY ONE I WOULD SAY ON THIS HE
SAID. I MEAN THIS IS THIS IS FOR
PRIVATE PAY INSURANCE SO IF YOU
ARE- IF YOUR PAIN WE KNOW THAT
60% OF THE POPULATION THE STATE
ARE COVERED BY SOME TYPE OF
PRIVATE PAY INSURANCE. YOU WOULD
EXPECT THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE. THE CARE NEEDED AS
PROMISED WITH IN THAT PREMIUM
WELL I'LL TELL YOU THAT- DELAY
IN MY DISTRICT AND FROM WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM PARENTS AND FRIENDS
THAT. IT IS VERY HARD TO FIND
SOMEONE TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES PARTICULARLY TO
ADOLESCENTS- I MEAN THERE'S JUST
NOT ENOUGH OF THEM AROUND AND
THEN WHAT THEY'VE DONE. MOST
RECENTLY AS THEY'VE CHANGED THE-
THE CARE TO- NOT IN PERSON. THEY
WANNA DO REAL NINETY ASSUME.
WHICH IS KIND OF WHAT GOT A LOT
OF THESE ANYWAY- SO IT'S
DIFFICULT YOU KNOW DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU LIVE IF THEY'RE NOT
PEOPLE BUT- AGAIN THAT'S- THAT
THAT IS NOT YOUR PROBLEM TO
SOLVE RIGHT NOW I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF HIGHLIGHT THAT THAT THIS
IS NOT GOING TO BE- YOU KNOW THE
SILVER BULLET THAT. THAT TO
HANDLE THIS PROBLEM- BUT I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH YOU THAT IF THE
PLAN SAY THEY'RE GOING TO- COVER
SOMETHING LIKE THIS THAT YOU
KNOW THEY SHOULD PROBABLY DO
THAT SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND- THE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CETERA THANK YOU
MISTER- YOU KNOW SOME OF THE-
OPPOSITION TENT. SEEMS TO BE
FOCUSED ON EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY
AND- IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY
PER. INDICATING THE PREPS IS
BILL OXIS INTO A PARTICULAR
TREATMENT PROTOCOL WHEN.
TREATMENT PROTOCOLS MAY CHANGE
IN A- FOR FARM SUPPORTING THE
BILL. OF THE BILL. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- IT'S SORT OF
BEEN MOVED GOOD SO THEY PUT ME
ON THE LIST- I GUESS MY
SUGGESTION IS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD PERHAPS. YOU COULD
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
THAT SUGGESTS THAT IF MORE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT PROTOCOLS
ARE SUBSEQUENTLY IDENTIFIED.
THOSE MIGHT BE AS MAY BE
SUBSTITUTED IN PLACE OF THE ONE
SPECIFIED IN THE BILL. HEY HAPPY
TO DO THAT I THINK THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW AND AGAIN
HAPPY TO DO THAT AND- LOOK AT IT
THERE BEEN EIGHTY DIFFERENT PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES- THAT SAYS IT
C. C. REALLY IS THE- ONLY AND
MOST EFFECTIVE. WHEN IT COMES TO
A AN EARLY PSYCHOSIS EPISODE
BUT- HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT RENDON IF
THAT REMAINS THE CASE AND I
GUESS. YOU KNOW YOU HAVE WHAT OF
WHAT YOU FAST FOR IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU- THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SAYING
NINE- FIRST OF ALL SIR MCGUIRE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH MY- COMMITTEE STAFF I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVE ME THE
CREDIT BUT MY COMMITTEE STAFF
THE SYSTEM. IS MOST OF THE WORK.
ALTHOUGH I DID TRY I DID TRY TO
GIVE THEM SOME SUGGESTIONS- FOR
MY BACKGROUND- BUT- YOU POINTS
THAT I ALSO LIKE TO MAKE- SO-
AND AGAIN AS YOU POINTED OUT- IN
TERMS OF. YOUR TREATMENT FOR
THIS CONDITION- NO THERE THERE'S
A BASE OF EVIDENCE THAT YOU. DID
IN ITALY SOME BILLS SO MISSILE
MAKES BUT LET'S LET'S POINT OUT
THAT SUPER FAST AND THE
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE WHICH
IS ACTUALLY PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
IN ORDER TO. SAY PROVIDES
EVIDENCE THAT- COMPARED TO USUAL
OUT L. CHIEF INFORMATION AS
USUAL- THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING HERE AND PRODUCED
FEMALE INSURANCE IMPROVES
POSITIVE NEGATIVE CUTTING.
BROUGH JENNER. NAY REDUCES
EMISSIONS TO SIGN. COST THERE'S
LEVINE- EARNS EVIDENCE THAT.
WELL TERM. BUILD LESS CERTAIN
RIGHT TALKED ABOUT THE LIMITED
EVIDENCE BUT SOMETIMES IT'S
LIMITED EVIDENCE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE STATE BUT WE DO
HAVE A PROFOUND SENSE FROM SOME
PRETTY GOOD THINGS TO HAPPEN.
RELATION TO THAT. ALSO I THINK
MAKE NOTE THAT- WILL CERTAINLY
WIN IN THIS BILL WE'RE SAYING
THAT. THE IS CSE SHOULD BECAUSE
- IF THAT IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
IT'S THE ONLY THING THAT'S
COVERED THERE FOR YOU REALLY
PSYCHOTIC THAT'S THE ONLY SO I
MEAN WE DO LEAVE THAT. OUT WE DO
WHAT THE JUDGMENT OF THE- OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
PROVIDING CARE AND THEY SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT THE EVIDENCE AND-
AND THEY IMMEDIATELY SURE THAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO FIGHT YEAH
THEY'RE SAYING THATTHIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. AND THAT'S
GOING TO GET COVERED I WOULD
ALSO POINT OUT THAT WELL
CERTAINLY I AGREE THAT THERE'S A
SHORTAGE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WHAT'S WHAT'S EVEN MORE
FRUSTRATING WHEN YOU'RE A-
PHYSICIAN OR OTHER PROVIDER IS
THAT EVEN WHEN YOU HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF ANY OF THE PATIENT
FRONT IF YOU. IN THE FACE OF
VALUE GETS TO YOU. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INSURANCE WILL COVER THE
TREATMENT THAT YOU THINK IS BEST
FOR THE PATIENT. WHICH IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE SO YES WE NEED
MORE. WE NEED MORE PEOPLE
CRAFTED DISSING US OF ALL THE
ACCESS PROBLEMS. BUT THE ONCE IT
BUT BUT WE CERTAIN CERTAINLY
SHOULD BESTOPPING TO PROVIDERS
AND ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE.
SPREAD TO CARE- YOU KNOW I WOULD
ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT YOU KNOW I
AM SENSITIVE. TO THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT.
YEAH ADDITIONAL MANDATES AND SO
FORTH- WE LOOK AT THESE
CAREFULLY THAT'S YOU KNOW AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE. YEAH WE ARE CONSCIOUS
OF THAT- I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE
AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO. TALK
ABOUT CONTROLLING HEALTH CARE
COSTS ULTIMATELY. WHAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF HEALTH INSURANCE
WON'T COVER THE CARE. THAT YOU
NEED RIGHT I MEAN PEOPLE PAYING
PREMIUMS. ON THE ACTUALLY NEED
TO CARE. AND IT'S GONNA SAY SO
YOU KNOW WE DEFINITELY WANT TO
LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE WE DON'T
WANNA BE COVERING THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO WORK IT CETERA BUT-
CERTAINLY- AT LEAST. I FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT THERE ARE. NO
SUFFICIENT BENEFIT TO MAKE THIS.
YOU KNOW- MORE DIFFER AS THE-
FOR COVERAGE AND SO WITH THAT
CERTAINLY WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
WORKING COMMITTEE WITH LIKELY.
RESPECT FAST THANK YOU IN A VERY
BUSY DAY. OKAY THANK YOU ALRIGHT
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS BEEN SECONDED BY
SEVERAL LEYVA. CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL HAND HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S. EGGMAN EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ CONSOLES I GROWTH HER
TADO. LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE LIMÓN
LIMON I ROTH. ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO. AYE WIENER WIENER HI.
EIGHT THANK. THE CURRENT VOTES
KERN EIGHT ZERO HOLDER OPEN FOR
MEMBERS. OF HE'S- CAN TO CAPTURE
OUT OKAY NOW WE SHOULD YEAH
BECAUSE YEAH ALL RIGHT SIR COME
LONGER WELCOME. AND JUST A
REMINDER FOR EVERYONE- SUSIE
FINISH SERIK MY GUESS IS THAT
SUSIE FINISH CENTCOM LONGEST
BILL WILL BE READY FOR A SPECIAL
ORDER THOUGH WHICH IS- AGAIN
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN SP THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT WILL BE FOLLOWING
THIS ITEM SO WE WILL SO WE ARE
CURRENTLY ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY CENTER COMMA WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE REFORMING
PRESCRIPTION REBATES I HAVE TO
SAY I DO LIKE THAT THIS IS TALL
ENOUGH. FOR THE TALL PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM I WANT TO FIRST START
BY SAYING. BUT I ACCEPT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YOU SIR
INNER BURKE. S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE SOLICITOR I WANT TO
SAY AGAIN EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
MINISTER THANK YOU OKAY SO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE WILL ENSURE
PATIENTS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
AFFORD THEIR MEDICATIONS BY
REFORMING THE STATE'S
PRESCRIPTION DRUG REBATE SYSTEM
TO BENEFIT THE PATIENT AND NOT
HEALTH INSURANCE. RATIONS
CURRENTLY THE PATIENT PAYS FOR A
DRUG AND THE DEDUCTIBLE PHASE OR
PAYS COINSURANCE AT THE PHARMACY
COUNTER. THE AMOUNT THEY MUST
PAY IS BASED ON THE FULL PRICE
OF THE DRUG EVEN IF THEY'RE
HEALTH INSURERS. AND
PHARMACEUTICAL BENEFITS MANAGER
ARE PAYING A LOWER AMOUNT THEY
NEGOTIATED WITH THE
MANUFACTURER. SO IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE REPORTED THAT HEALTH
PLANS RECEIVED MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
REBATES UP 57% FROM TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. BECAUSE THERE ARE A
TRANSPARENCY IN THE SYSTEM
PATIENTS HAVE NO IDEA HOW MUCH
IF ANY REBATE MONEY GOES TOWARDS
LOWERING INSURANCE PREMIUMS. OR
LOWERING OTHER OUT OF POCKET
COSTS. WITH PRIOR LEGISLATION
ONLY PROVIDING TRANSPARENCY TO A
PORTION OF THE SYSTEM SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE WILL ADD MUCH
NEEDED ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY PROVISIONS TO NOT
ONLY ENSURE DISCOUNTS ARE
BENEFITING THE PATIENT. BUT ALSO
TO ALLOW FOR A CLEAR PICTURE OF
THE TRUE PRICE THE DRUGS AND
THEIR IMPACT ON PREMIUMS.
SPECIFICALLY IT WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
AGGREGATE DOLLAR AMOUNT OF ALL
REBATES FOR ME LARRY DESIGN
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT AND
GRIEVANCES AND APPEAL PROCESS
SEES. CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA
PBMS ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
EXERCISE GOOD FAITH AND FAIR
DEALING WITH THE HEALTH PLANS
THAT THEY CONTRACT WITH. IN FACT
CALIFORNIA'S STATUTE PUTS THE
ONUS ON THE HEALTH PLAN TO
ENSURE THE PBM ACTS IN GOOD
FAITH MEANING THERE IS NO
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT FOR THE
PBM TO DO SO. SO S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE REQUIRES A PBM TO ACT
IN GOOD FAITH AND FAIR DEALING
TO ENROLLEES HEALTH INSURERS
PLANS AND PROVIDERS. AS SUCH S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE REMOVES
THE ABILITY FOR PBMS TO RETAIN
EXTRA REBATE DOLLARS BASED UPON
THE LIST PRICE OF A DRUG. THE
AMOUNT OF REBATES COLLECTED OR
PATIENT OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
AGAIN THESE DISCOUNTS WERE NEVER
INTENDED TO FLOW TO THIRD PARTY
PBMS THESE DOLLARS ARE MEANT TO
DIRECTLY LOWER THE COST OF A
PATIENT'S PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AT
THE PHARMACY COUNTER. BY SHARING
90% OF REBATES WITH PATIENTS AT
THE PHARMACY COUNTER SB THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE WILL IMMEDIATELY LOWER
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COSTS HELPING
CALIFORNIANS BETTER ACCESS THEIR
MEDICINES. AND BETTER IT HERE TO
THE TREATMENTS THAT THEY NEED TO
STAY HEALTHY. AT TWENTY TWO
COOPER REPORT OF A SIMILAR
POLICY MEASURE FOUND THAT IT IS
CLEARLY POSSIBLE FOR PHARMACY
SOFTWARE TO BE UPDATED TO SHARE
REBATES AT THE POIT OF SALE AS
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL. THE
SOFTWARE ALREADY ALLOWS FOR
POINT OF SALE VARIATION IN
PRICES COST SHARING AMOUNTS
BENEFIT COVERAGE AND FORMULARY
INFORMATION. SO WITH ME HERE IN
SUPPORT I THINK BOTH BY PHONE.
OUR DOCTOR LEON DRUG CLARK
HARVEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACCESS COALITION AND
DR GINA WARREN A CLINICAL
PHARMACIST WITH TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE AND CO
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD WELLNESS
FOUNDATION AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU CENTER COME UNDER
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE DOCTOR LEE ANDREA CLARK
HARVEY. AND DR GINA WARREN WE'RE
GONNA BEGIN WITH DR LIAN LI
ANDREA CLARK HARVEY YOU HAVE.
TWO MINUTES- BETWEEN THE BOTH OF
YOU YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES. THANK
YOU AIR AND MANY MEMBERS. I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF HEALTH NEEDS
HELLO. BOB HERTZBERG D. ONE. OUR
MISSION IS TO BRING YOUR
REPRESENTATIVE DID NOT GET HER
TO JOINTLY CREATE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR PATIENTS AFTER
HEALTH TREATMENT ELEVEN INDUSTRY
PARTNERS AND DO THE RIGHT THING
FOR PATIENTS WE SUPPORT IT NO
MATTER IF IT WILL SAVE JUST FIVE
HUNDRED OR OVER THIRTEEN MILLION
PATIENTS MONEY AT THE PHARMACY
COUNTER AT THIS BILL WITH
ESTIMATED TO DO. SIMPLY ARTICLE
OF THE LOWER PATIENTS OUT OF
POCKET COSTS FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS AND I WAS AMAZED HEY THIS
IS NOT IMPOSSIBLE. IN PREMIUM
WILL NOT ROCK. IT'S BEEN DONE
VOLUNTEER BY TV AND THE MORE
SPRING LEAD TO. HAVE PASS IN
ANOTHER STATE. LET'S LOOK AT.
TWENTY TWENTY BY- FOUND THAT 51%
OF. SKIPPED OR POST HERE DUE TO
. OF THOSE WHO PUT OFF HERE FOR
ONE PER SAID DOING SO. IN THEIR
CONTENT THERE. ACCORDING TO A
STUDY BY CHIPPER. POLICY WOULD
SEE AT LEAST HUNDRED AND THIRTY
SIX THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
SEVENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR ALONE. MOST IMPORTANT THIS
TREND OF FORGOING HEALTH CARE
DUE TO HIGH CALL IS UNTENABLE.
SB. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE PROVIDE A
REMEDY. IN TWENTY NINETEEN-
ALONE PBMS IN THE US BECAUSE SHE
DID EIGHTY NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN A REBATE OVERALL IN A
RECENT REPORT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE FOUND THAT. TWENTY TWENTY
HOW CLINTON CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
AND REBATES FROM MANUFACTURERS.
WHAT PBMS AND INSURERS MAKE
BILLIONS PATIENTS OFTEN END UP
PAYING MORE FOR THE PRESCRIPTION
AND THE PDN AN INSURER PAID FOR
IT. THE PATIENTS WHO HAVE NOT
MET THEIR HEALTH PLAN TO DOCTOR
BILL AND MUST PAY OUT OF POCKET
AT THE PHARMACY COUNTER ARE
OFTEN FORCED TO PAY THE FULL.
PRICE OF THE MEDICATION NOT THE
REBATE. IT WAS NOT. TO LOWER.
MEDICATION COSTS FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING THE
THOUSANDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES TO A HIGH
DEDUCTIBLE PLAN. HI OUT OF
POCKET COSTS. MAKE IT DIFFICULT
AND OFTEN IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO
FOR THEIR MEDICATIONS. ALL OF
THIS IS INTENSIFIED BY PANDEMIC
THAT IS HITTING PEOPLE WITH
CHRONIC CONDITIONS. WHO ARE IN
NEED OF MEDICATION THE HARDEST.
SO I IMPLORE YOU AS A
PSYCHOLOGIST AN ADVOCATE AND OF
THE PATIENT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
AND PASTOR SB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. WITNESS- IT
DR WARREN ARE YOU HAVE A MINUTE
AND FORTY SECONDS. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THE PARENTS WE MEMBERS
BY DOCTORS YOU KNOW WARREN HERE
I MAKE DR APARTMENT BE FINITE
AMONG THE CO FOUNDED EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE WITH THE BONUS.
DEL PASO HEIGHTS WE CAN NO MANY
ARE YOU ARE FAMILIAR IN ORDER
SACRAMENTO I AM HERE HONOR HE-
HE TODAY DEADLINE REQUIRED AT
EITHER. ONE TWENTY YEARS COMICAL
PLAN THANK SIX OF THEM HERE AND
ADDED NAY- MEDIA- I DIRECT LOCAL
PUB AND WITH POSSIBLE
RESPONSIBILITY INCLUDED BEING
PRIVILEGE FIVE TIMES CURRENT YOU
BECAUSE IT IS. HAD LOTS
EXPERTISE OF FUN I NOW INCOME
ABOUT.
THE GROUND AND REMOTE. JOINT
SACRAMENTO- THERE CAN
OPPORTUNITY HILL TO IMPROVE THAT
BUT THE CANTON THE SYSTEM TRYING
TO LOWER IT OCCUPATION- THE
REASON FOR THIS IS A VERY AND HE
KNOWS WHAT. HE SAID THANK YOU
KNOW THAT WE NEED A PLAGUE WELL
INCLUDE DRUG PRICES THERE ARE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES WILL MAKE
CHANGES ON TWENTY- REPORTEDLY
TOO FAR EIGHT I THINK THE MOST.
MOST IMPOVERISHED FACE BOOK THE
FROM. I'M NOT SYSTEMATIC OUT BUT
THOSE OFF ON THE CAR EIGHT
INFORMED IN A AS.
ONE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. I SEE PEOPLE GETTING
UP JUST RIGHT. JENNIFER CENTER
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRED NOWHERE FOR
PHARMA ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER TURN MEMBERS
WERE TOP HERE ON BEHALF OF BY A
CALM CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SAY NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
IS TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE MIN ZERO. YOUR FIRST
LINE. ONE OH FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
CALLING ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE SIXTY SIX. HELLO JONATHAN
GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING ITS REPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU AT THE TIME
BERMAN WHAT. OKAY. OUR NEXT
WITNESS- YEAH. NINE ONE ELEVEN.
WAS IT DESIGNED EVEN SHOW OUR
PREPARATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXANT WITH THIS. SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AARON CALLAGHAN IN THE DIABETES
PATIENT ADVOCACY COALITION
ADAPTATION POCKET PROTECTOR
COALITION FROM PORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE SEVENTY
SEVEN. SEVEN SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SUBLABEL CALIFORNIA FARM
THE FACILITATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
SEVENTEENTH. BY ONE SEVENTEEN
ARE YOU ON MUTE. WILL MOVE ON
THE LINE ONE THIRTY TWO. THE
STOPPAGE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE LUPUS FOUNDATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE PROVIDE
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING ELAINE
INLAND EMPIRE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB ONE THREE
SIX ONE THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS
. BY ONE THIRTY THREE. MY NAME
IS KATIE WILSON I'M WITH THE
CATERED AND FAR MORE THAN
CALIFORNIA I'VE WORKED IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR INCLUDING JAILS
PRISONS AND COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICS THROUGHOUT MY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS CAREER I AM VERY MUCH
IN FAVOR OF YOUR BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. EXPERTNESS BY. ONE
THIRTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
CHARLES CONNABLE AND THE- FATHER
OF PUBLIC YOUNG MAN WITH THE
CONTROL FACTOR BELIEVES HAS
LITTLE PROBLEMS AND- I AM
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF LOS ANGELES
THE POLLS THAT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BLIND. EIGHTEEN
KLAIN ONE EIGHTEEN. HOME OF THE
LINE ONE THIRTY AND- HELLO THIS
IS LINDA SCHIRO. I'M A PARENT OF
A THIRTY THREE YEAR OLD SON WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. FINE EIGHTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALL BURKE AND KAREN
DAHLE HI BUT IF THE OWNER AND
LYFT STRONGLY. YEAH THANK YOU
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITH. HI.
ONE FOUR SIX. THANK AND IT. HE
HAS FIVE. HE IS COMMITTED TO
EIGHT EIGHT BALL DURING. HEALTH
IS IN IT- I AM. WHAT IS IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU KNOW
WITNESS. FINE. ONE TEN- SUPPOSED
FOR THE DEPRESSION BY SO
ALLIANCE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OKAY THANK YOU FIX THIS ONE
THANK YOU ONE FORTY TWO- CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. AND PARTY FERGUSON I
AM THE MOTHER OF A MAN WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS. CURRENTLY IN
JAIL FOR VANDALISM BECAUSE OF
OUR FOLKS IN BATTLE HEALTH
SYSTEM YOU SHOULD NOT BE IN JAIL
RIGHT NOW MA'AM HELLO SEPTET
STILL IS THE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION SO I SOME YEARS ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU A MONARCHY
YOU INDICATE HOW MANY HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE WAITING ON THE LINE.
WE HAVE THREE. LET'S SEE A
CONTINUE. ONE FORTY FIVE CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YES. GOOGLE IS DONE
MEMBER OF NAMI CONTRA COSTA AND
MENTAL HEALTH COMMISSIONER OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY INSURERS
FINANCE COMMITTEE STRONG SUPPORT
OKAY THANK YOU AND REMINDER DISS
S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE CELL.
NEXT WITNESS. ONE FIFTY THREE.
ONE FIFTY THREE ARE YOU ON MUTE. FORTY ONE FIFTY TWO. NINE ONE
FIFTY TWO DO YOU WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THE DALLAS
THAT WOULD BE A BILL OF AROUND
ONE FIFTY TWO BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY DO IT. YOU ARE FISCAL
AT. WONDERFUL MY NAME IS
SPONSORED ACCURATE AND IT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ACOSTA THE
HURDLES WE HAVE. OF NOT JUST OUR
THIRTY OKAY YOUR AND YOUR NAME
FROM. SORRY YOUR. OKAY ONE
MOMENT RIGHT AND ALSO JUST A
REMINDER- WE ARE STILL WRAPPING
UP OUR TESTIMONY ON S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE SENATOR COM
LAGER AFTER WHICH WE WILL THEN
MOVE TO OUR NEXT BILL WHICH IS
THE SPECIAL ORDER DEBTS SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT BY CENTER-
BURKE. SO MANY OF YOU MAY BE
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT I SORT OF
MIND YOU WE ARE STILL INCLUDING
OUR WORK ON S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE BY CENTER COM LAGER WHICH IS
A BILL ON- PBMS- PRESCRIPTION.
SO AND THE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
SUCH AS WHITE PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT THE TESTIFYING ON. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE BY SARAH
COMMON EITHER. ON DRUGS. OUR
RESEARCH EDUCATION. SETTLE BUT
SORRY. BRIAN ONE FIFTY TWO OKAY
IS THE BILL YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF- NO I WITH
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT OKAY THANK
YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE ON THE
LINE. I HAVE TWO MORE OKAY. LINE
ONE SIXTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS
ERICA EMERSON WITH THE GUY HE'S
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL CALLING IN
TRUMP FOR OKAY THANK YOU THANKS
WITH THIS. WE HAVE LINE ONE
EIGHTEEN. ONE ONE EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IF THAT PIPELINE
YES IT IS YES. A PERFECT HI MY
NAME IS SCOTT YOU GO IN THE
CORPORATE THING FOR EIGHTEEN
AFTER UNITED IN INDIA COUNTY AND
I SUPPORT AT THE ONE THREE SIX
ONE AND- THE COMMITTEE TO
APPROVE IT I THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS OVER THE LINE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE NOW MOVE TO THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE- SO WE HAVE-
I THINK ON THE PHONE AS BILL
HEAD FROM THE PHARMACEUTICAL
CARE MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION. SO
PLEASE BRING HIM ON TO THE LINE
AND THEN FOLLOWED BY PRESSING
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONVIRTIERON PERSON SO. I CAN
PLEASE BRING- BILL HEAD. FOR
TESTIMONY TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOR
MINUTES BETWEEN BOTH OF YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
. A NATIONAL TV AND
TRANSPOSITION AND WE ARE
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE. I WOULD CHOOSE THE
IMMEDIATELY HIGHRISE- COMMON BY
ONE THE PROPONENTS OF THE- FROM
SAID THAT WE AT INCREASE-
MEDICATION. MANAGEMENT- I AM
RUNNING. THE CREATION OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL MY- THE CASE THEN
WHY SHOULD BOTHERED FOR
ELIMINATE OF OP. IT IS POSSIBLE
OBTAIN WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING
ABOUT THE COST KNOW THAT WE OUR
IMPACT. THERE WAS A TIME TO
SHIFT INTO ALSO. YOU KNOW THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED
SOMETHING SIMILAR FOR MEDICARE.
FIFTY BUDGET OFFICE THAT IT
WOULD POP TO MEDICARE PROGRAM
SEVENTY ONE INTO. IN YEARS THAT
WON'T. LAST SEPTEMBER FOR.
BENEFITS REGIONAL. ALL FISHERIES
WELL FOR CALLING HOMEOWNER. YOU
MENTIONED THE DMS. SEVENTY AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT DID. BUT THAT
IS ACTUALLY MAKES DID HOW
QUICKLY GO DOWN BUT JUST UNDER
TWO. WE HAVE A PART IMPACT FOR
EVERY- PREMIUM- IF SUPPORTERS
THAT WE ARE ON EVERY DROPS
MICHELI OFFERING IN ITS FIRST OF
THE FACT. FOR IT IS REALLY THE
ONLY. PROBLEM OF PEOPLE WHO
OFTEN DO PAID. MONEY FOR DRUGS
DO NOT FOR THE UNIT WHO ARE TO
PAY FOR PRICE. I DO NOT FOR THE
PEOPLE ARE- SINGLES ARE STILL
ISN'T NOT. TO OKAY IN THE- PRICE
BECAUSE- PROBLEM HAS NO. TO
OPERATE A MOTOR THAT PERHAPS.
SOMEONE WILL WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE COPS DRIVER
SIMPLY AS OPERATOR REBATE. LOWER
POSSIBLE DRUG BUT THEY WOULD
GIVEN THEM. BUT LITERALLY JUST
MINUTES- I WOULD JUST SIMPLY A
SECTIONS OF THE NEW STRUCTURE ON
PLAN AND REALLY CONTRA. IT
REALLY ON STRATEGICALLY BEGIN OF
THE TWO- SHARE INCOME SAVINGS
ARE WE YOU HAVE A HIGHER IS TO
HELP PLANT TODAY. AN ISSUE SAID
LAST LEGALLY WE FOR NO VOTE. HE
WON THANK YOU.
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE- I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FROM AN EMPLOYER
BASED PERSPECTIVE AND IT'S
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES THAT ARE
GOING UNFORTUNATELY FACE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
WILL COME ALONG WITH THIS BILL
AND THOSE ARE THE COSTS THAT
WOULD BE ASSOCIATED WITH AN AYE
PREDICATED THAT UPON THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ANALYSIS OF A
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR BILL THAT
WAS HEARD EARLIER THIS YEAR-
ACCORDING TO THE SUBURBAN
ALICE'S EMPLOYER PREMIUMS. UNDER
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE-
INCREASED A HUNDRED NINE MILLION
DOLLARS EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS WOULD
HAVE RISEN APPROXIMATELY FORTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS- THE CONCERN
IS THAT THE COSTS- THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE BILL IN THE
PREMIUMS FOR EMPLOYERS DESPITE
PHARMACEUTICAL PRICES REMAINING
ON OF. A CONCERNING AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE WILL BENEFIT ONE GROUP
OF PATIENTS ALL PATIENTS WOULD
HAVE TO PAY MORE FOR HEALTH
CARE- ADDITIONALLY AS MENTIONED
EARLIER IN ANOTHER BILL- THE
COST NEED TO BE VIEWED IN THE
AGGREGATE. WE'RE LOOKING AT
ELEVEN MANDATES HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED THIS YEAR WITH A TOTAL
VALUE PREMIUM INCREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS ACCORDING TO-
CHIPPER ADDITIONALLY
AFFORDABILITY AS A WHOLE NEEDS
TO BE CONSIDERED UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE AVERAGE FAMILY HEALTH
PLAN PREMIUMS FOR JOBS COVERAGES
INCREASED TWENTY TWO PERCENT. A
TWO THOUSAND. THE FOUNDATION.
HEALTH BENEFITS SURVEY INDICATED
THAT FOR JOB BASED COVERAGE THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL PREMIUM FOR
FAMILY COVERAGE IS 220-002-0020
ONE DOLLARS WHICH IS A 4%
INCREASE. COMPARED TO THE YEAR
PRIOR SO CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE AUTHOR
AND THE AUTHOR STAFF- FOR THE
WORK BUT AS THE BILL APPEARS IN
PRINT TODAY WE ARE POSE FOR
THESE REASONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU- WILL NOT TAKE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE NAME WORKS A POSITION-
OF THE MICROPHONE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
MISTER MEMBERS NICK LOUISA MAY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS OPPOSED I THANK
YOU. THE LITTLE AGILA ARE FORMER
RECOVERY OF SAN FRANCISCO FOLSOM
STREET HARDCORE PARTYING ALONG
WITH WIENER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I SEE NO ONE
ELSE WILL BE OFFERED THE
MICROPHONE- WE ARE NOW GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE AND- YEAH
OUT INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS SELL- SO
WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE
CONFERENCE LINE- FULLER-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH THAT'S FINE
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE. A PRESS ONE
ON THEIR OWN. WE'LL GO FIRST
LINE. ONE SIXTY ONE.
WHAT WILL UNDERLINE ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE WALK IN
I'M GAP YES THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE IT'S NOT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
SEVENTY. LINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT
ARE YOU ON MUTE. EIGHT FATHER
COMMITTEE HELP NETWORK. A LOT
PART FOR OF. AND THAT COULD IN
IT OKAY A MORE ON A WE'RE ON OUR
TO SB SIX ONE BY CENTER LAGER WE
HAVE NOT YET BEGUN OUR CUSTOMER
ON- SB THIRTY EIGHT. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER PHONE YEAH BASED OR NO
OR THE LINE THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU BRING BACK COMMITTEE CALL
COME FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SECONDS OF. I MISSED ASHER HERE
FORTY. AS ANSWER THANK YOU SIR
GONZALEZ. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SENATOR COME LONGER
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
THINK ANYWAY THAT WE CAN LOWER
COSTS ESPECIALLY AS THE
KNOWLES'S- POINTS OUT THE LONG
TERM- FOLKS THAT HAVE SRT OF.
LONG TERM- CONDITIONS I THINK
EVEN MORE REASON TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEM ANYWAY AND ANYHOW-
I'D LOVE TO BE OUT OF THE CO
AUTHOR AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU- TO ENSURE THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT FOR PATIENTS. THANK YOU
OKAY. THE SERVER RUBIO. AT THE
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I ALSO KNOW
THE YOU KNOW OUR ECHO MY THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE THAT
JUST AND TIME WE CAN HEALTH
LOWER THE COST IT IS IMPORTANT
AND YOU KNOW THE COSTS KEEP
RISING AND PEOPLE ARE HAVING A
HARDER AND HARDER TIME GETTING
ACCESS TO IT TO MEDICATION BUT
YOU KNOW I JUST WANT- AND THIS
IS NOT FOR THE AUTHOR BUT MAYBE
FOR YOUR SUPPORTERS ARE
PROPONENTS THAT THEY CAN ADDRESS
HOW. THIS BILL CAN INTERSECT OR
PERHAPS YOU KNOW- IMPACT I KNOW
AS A BODY WE HAVE FIVE PUT CAPS
ON COAL PIECE I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT. IT DOESN'TCOME
COLLECTED CAN THEY ADDRESS THE
COPAYS AND WE'VE CAPPED AN END
OF THIS IS GOING TO BE AN ISSUE
. OKAY TWO ONE A DRESS STYLE LET
SARAH YES. OKAY BECAUSE I DON'T
BELIEVE SO BUT RIGHT IF YOU WISH
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF THANK
YOU ISSUE REALISTIC FROM PHARMA
FOR THE RECORD SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION IN
THE STANDARD PLAN FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
ARE CAPPED- COST SHARING IS
CAPPED AT TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS IF YOU'RE IN A STANDARD
TIER PLAN THAT COULD BE BASED
OFF OF CO INSURANCE OR ON
COPAYMENT- AND SO. YOU COULD
STILL BE PAYING OFF THE LIST
PRICE OF THE DRUG EVEN IF- IF
YOU HAVE THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLAR CAP IF YOU'RE PAYING ON
CO INSURANCE IN ADDITION WHEN
YOU'RE IN THE DEDUCTIBLE PERIOD
YOU HAVE A FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
CAP DEDUCTIBLE HEARING
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN STILL BE
PAYING OFF OF. THE LIST PRICE
FOR THOSE DRUGS SO THIS BILL
WOULD ENSURE THAT- DAY. BENEFIT
AND THEN IT GOES. TO REPAY PRICE
OF THE AT THE POINT OF SALE NOT
THE HIGHER LIST PRICE AND THERE
WAS- SOME AMENDMENTS ADDED. BY
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN SENATE
HEALTH TO MAKE SURE THERE
WOULDN'T BE A CONFLICT WITH THE
EXISTING PROTECTIONS OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLAR CAP. IN THE
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR TO CAP ON
DEDUCTIBLE THE PATIENT WE GET
WHATEVER THE LOWER ONE WAS. VIEW
UP HERE CAN YOU ELABORATE ON ONE
MORE OTHER ISSUE AND I'M SORRY
STEPPED OUT FOR A LITTLE BIT-
YEAH I KNOW THAT THAT THERE'S
CONCERNS AND I'M SURE YOU'VE ALL
HEARD. IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
POSSIBLY INCREASE THE COST
ACROSS THE BOARD IN OTHER AREAS
SO HELP SOME BUT NOT OTHERS CAN
YOU. RESPOND TO THAT. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY SO THAT YOUR BOURBON
ALICE'S FOUND THAT PREMIUMS
WOULD INCREASE ABOUT. POINT 3%
BUT SAVE THE AVERAGE CAN- THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR- WE'VE
DONE OUR OWN ANALYSIS I HAVE
FOUND THAT AN AVERAGE DIABETIC
WOULD SAVE SIX HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS A YEAR. ON THEIR
INSULIN AND WE THINK THAT MAKE A
REAL THAT. THANK SPON IS. I ALSO
WANNA ASK AT THE OPPOSITION CAN
I HAVE SOMEONE TO ANSWER SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS. WE CAN EITHER HAVE
MISTER HAD COME BACK AS IT IS ON
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE ARE WE A
PERSON YOUNG HERE'S WELL AND
SELF AND I GUESS YOU GET OUTSIDE
WHO WANTS ANSWER QUESTIONS UP.
TELL YOUR PLEASE COME OF THE
RECORD ON THE FREEDOM GARDLER IF
YOU WISH TO DEFER TO MISTER HEAD
OF ASK HIM TO COME ON OVERHEAD
SO. YOU'LL HAVE TO CALL HE'S
FROM FROM THE CHAMBER I'M NOT
SURE YOU YOU MAY BE ABLE TO AND
OKAY BUT WE CAN TRY BECAUSE I
ALSO. BECAUSE I'VE BEEN HEARING
THE OTHER SIDE RIGHT AND SO I
WANT TO GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RESPOND TO. YOU KNOW BE DO
YOU SEE DIFFERENTLY OR AT THE
OPPOSITION SEES A DIFFERENTLY
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'VE
BEEN HEARING IT GOING TO BE
SCOTT WHILE. DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE IN YOU CAN.
DILLONLIAM YEAH MR HEADS I'VE
HAD A- CENSUS ON THAT SO. YES WE
CAN PLEASE IN PLEASE PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE QUESTION
AND IN OUR- POSITION IS VERY
SIMILAR TO BURKE AND TO.
PRESSURE BUT YOU'RE A WHEN SCORE
THE FEDERAL- THIS. YES SOME
PATIENTS WILL AND THEY MONEY.
I'M INTERESTED. ALL PATIENTS
FALL. THEIR COST SAVING. SEVERAL
OF THE PEOPLE FOR BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING BUT YOU KNOW INTO LIKE
WHAT PURPOSES HOSPITAL REMAIN.
OKAY I. YEAH BECAUSE I KEEP
COMFY YOU KNOW NUMBER OF SUPPORT
BILL JUST SO YOU I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
LOWER THE COST FOR PATIENTS BUT
I'M TRYING GET NOTICED FIVE
OTHER SOMETHING WOMEN IS KEEP
HEARING THE SAME COIN TO
DIFFERENT SITE POINT BY THERE IS
A DISCREPANCY AND I'M AND TO.
SUPPORT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
OR AT I'LL ON THE OPPOSITE GATE
LATE COMER AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE OF AN OFFER THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE CARD ABOUT. THE
CAN NOW ABOUT SKINHEAD. MORE
WE'RE AT USE. THAT MEMBERS
CONCLUDED SO WE'RE MY ON NOW. SO
YOU GIVING YOUR- SIR RUBIO. SERA
THANK YOU MISTER MAYBE SOME
COULD NOT. QUITE BEFORE AND
MAYBE. IT'S BEEN STATED- AS A
RESULT THIS PROPOSED CHANGE IN
THIS BILL WHAT IS THE AVERAGE
INCREASE. ON AN EMPLOYEE'S
PREMIUM IN AN EMPLOYER SPONSORED
PLAN. FOR THE INDIVIDUAL'S
PREMIUM IN AN INDIVIDUALLY
PROCURED. PLAN SO ACTUALLY DOING
SO I'LL LET THE WHAT I WHAT I
THE INFORMATION I HAVE AS AN
EXAMPLE M. IS THAT YOU KNOW IT
COULD GO UP BY POINT 3% SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE PAYING TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS IT COULD GO UP
BY 60% BUT I MEAN BY SIXTY AND
PRICE IS. THAT'S WHY PRYING TO
GET IS I HEAR THESE BIG NUMBERS.
AND AN ICE WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
TRYING TO GET AT IS WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE INCREASE GOING TO BE
TO THE INDIVIDUAL WHO'S HAVING
TO PAY. FOR HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS FIFTY OR SIXTY CENTS A
MONTH- I DON'T KNOW. I CAN'T GET
MY ARMS AROUND THE FACT THEY
WERE OVERCHARGING SOME. WHO NEED
PHARMACEUTICALS TO BENEFIT
OTHERS. THAT'S WHAT'S GETTING ME
AND MAYBE THAT'S THE WAY THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WORKS.
ACTUALLY THIS IS AN OF JOHN
LEWIS FROM TROOPER PARR SOMEONE
ELSE INSURE BURKE IS ON THE
PHONE- TWO MIGHT BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION OF DOCTOR CENTER. OKAY
WE DO HAVE ANYONE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ON. BLIND. SO
WHAT I WILL SAY WHICH SORT OF
CAME OUT OF THE RIVER ANALYSIS-
IS THAT IN THIS IS A AS IT
RELATES TO INSULIN WHICH IS A
COMMON DRUG THAT MOST PEOPLE
NEED THAT MANY PEOPLE NEED- SO
INSULIN HAD AN 80% REBATE OFF
THE LIST PRICE THAT WAS PAID FOR
BY THE PBM. AND SO RIGHT NOW FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA
AND YOU NEED IT- YOU'D BE PAYING
AT THE PHARMACY FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR THE
INSULIN. SO IF THIS WERE TO
GOING TO AFFECT YOU WOULD ONLY
BE PAYING A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DOLLARS SO MY UNDERSTANDING AND
I AM VERY NEW TO THIS SPACE BUT
IT IS IN THIS WORLD IS
INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED AND
HAIRY- AND- TRUTH BE TOLD
PATIENTS ARE IN A CHOKEHOLD-
BETWEEN. PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS
AND INSURANCE PLANS- AND THE
PBMS WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT
THIRTY SIX OTHER STATES ARE
TRYING TO EXTRICATE THEMSELVES
FROM THIS CHOKEHOLD AS IT
RELATES TO REBATES BECAUSE THE
REBATES WERE DESIGNED. TO GO TO
THE PATIENT OR THE CUSTOMER NOT
TO THE PBMS AND SO THERE HAS
BEEN THERE I KNOW THERE ARE ARE
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT. I GUESS
LATE PRICE BREADING ARE SHIFTING
THE COST TO GO TO SOMEONE ELSE
SO THAT THE PPL ESSENTIALLY YOU
CAN RECOUP THE COST THAT YOU
WOULD BE LOSING. THEM IF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WERE TO GO
INTO A FACT AND THE INFORMATION
THAT WE GOT WAS THAT AID THE
SAVINGS HAVE BEEN UNDER
ESTIMATED THROUGH CHIPPER. BUT
IF THERE WERE TO BE A PRICE
INCREASE IT WOULD BE LESS THAN
POINT FIVE PERCENT. SO I'M
CERTAINLY ONLY. MEANS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO LOWER THE COST
OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH THE AT
RESPECTFULLY TO THE OPPOSITION
THERE'S BEEN NO CONFLATION OF A
LOT OF ISSUES BECAUSE YES THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE IS INCREDIBLY
HIGH AND YES THE COST OF
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS IS
INCREDIBLY HIGH. AND YES REBATE
GOING DIRECT. TO THE PATIENT OR
TO THE CUSTOMER WHO NEEDS THAT-
I DON'T KNOW THAT ALL OF THOSE
THINGS CAN GET ADDRESSED AND I
KNOW THAT YOU ALL PROBABLY
ADDRESSED ALL OF THOSE ISSUES IN
VARIOUS FORMS WITH PIECES OF.
LEGISLATION THAT COME BEFORE
YOU. WELL THANK VERY MUCH YOUR
RISK YOU CERTAINLY ANSWERED MY
QUESTION AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL SIX. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
I'LL TO GET PROMOTION YET. OKAY
IT'S BEEN MOVE A CENTER LEYVA-
THIRTY COME EITHER AT THE END
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE STAFF- TO
ADDRESS MANY ISSUES- INTERVIEW
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH- THE
OPPOSITION. AS WELL- TO DRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THEY
RAISE BUT AGAIN THAT YOU I THINK
THAT THERE ARE. WHAT I GUESS
MAYBE SHORTHAND I'D SAY IS THAT.
FROM MY UNDERSTANDING THIS BILL
WOULD ACTUALLY WELL THERE ARE.
TWO GROUPS THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME OVERALL. IN TERMS OF ON THE
PREMIUM SIDE THERE MAY BE SOME
UPWARD PRESSURE. BUT ACTUALLY
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY NEED
THE MEDICATION- THE ABOUT COST
SHARES YOU SAID RIDICULOUS MORE
DIRECTLY TO THEM ACTUALLY
DECREASES. SO IF YOU'RE THINKING
INSURANCE SHOULD REALLY HELP YOU
WHEN YOU'RE SICK. THE SERVER
HEADS IN THAT DIRECTION- BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED THAT BUT I'M SORT OF
GETTING THE SHORTHAND- SO
CERTAINLY I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL. WITH THE AMENDMENT SAYS
THAT YOU ACCEPTED- WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. IN A MINUTE KEEP IT SHORT
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO GET IN
TROUBLE AND I JUST WANNA BLESS
ALL OF YOU ALL FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU DO ON THIS COMMITTEE- BUT IF
THIS BILL WERE TO PASS. ALMOST
FOURTEEN MILLION PATIENTS COULD
BENEFIT BECAUSE AT SOME POINT IN
TIME FOURTEEN MILLION FOLKS WILL
BE NEEDING TO FILL A
PRESCRIPTION. ALMOST NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOLKS IN
CALIFORNIA TAKING BRAND DRUGS
AND ARE IN PLANS WITH
DEDUCTIBLES AND COINSURANCE AND
SO THEY WOULD BE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED WITH LOWER COSTS. AND
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
FILLED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD BE MADE MORE
AFFORDABLE. I ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THIRTY SIX OTHER
STATES ARE LOOKING AT BILLS THAT
CAN ADDRESS THE FACT THAT THE
REBATES ARE GOING TO THE PBMS
AND NOT TO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED
THEM MOST PEOPLE THAT WERE. LOVE
AND CARE FOR. WHO AT SOME.
ANOTHER I NEEDING TO FILL A
PRESCRIPTION. AND WHEN THE
STATE'S AREN'T ABLE TO DO WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO ACTUALLY THE
SUPREME COURTS HAVE STEPPED IN-
TO ALSO SORT OF. TAP DOWN ON.
WHAT MANY PEOPLE SAY SOME GROSS
NEGLIGENCE HAPPENING AROUND
REBATES GOING TO THE WRONG
PEOPLE. OR ENTITIES SO WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH-
SO- THE BOSTON. THE BELLS THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE
FIRST. AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- IT'S BEEN SECONDED
BY CENTER LEYVA. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE BALL HAS. TO GO
HAND IN. HAND HI MELINDA'S.
EGGMAN EGGMAN I CAN SALAS. SALAS
I GROW FURTADO LEYVA. LEYVA AYE
LEÓN. LIMON AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE
RUBIO. WE AYE. EIGHT OKAY THE
ROLE KILEY A ZERO THE ROLE OPEN
FOR AT MEMBERS THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NUMBER OKAY THANK ALL
RIGHT AND UPON FOR WHO'S- WE
WERE NOW MOVE TO SPECIAL ITEM I
NUMBER AS THIRTY THIRTY EIGHT
CENTERS AMBER AND I COMMEND-
WELCOME- S. ACTUALLY JUST QUICK
QUESTION STAFF YOU AND WE HAVE
MULTIPLE WITNESSES TESTIFYING
WE'RE GONNA HAPPEN TESTIFIED THE
MICROPHONE. OKAY I THINK SHE'S
CLOSE AND RIGHT NOW SHE'S GOING
TO MAKE RIGHT NOW OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT SO- ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO AHEAD
AND HAVE YOU. THANK YOU BEFORE
YOU BE JUST REMIND AND OUT AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING-
GIVEN THE NAY THE INTEREST IN
THIS TOPIC WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO. ALLOW TEN MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY FROM EACH SIDE IN
TERMS OF- IN TERMS OF ACTUAL
TESTIMONY AND THEN AND THEN OF
COURSE AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO.
PRESS FOR ALSO. THE DISH YEAH
THERE PERSONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO THAT'S SEVEN USUAL
FOR- I WILL KEEP THE TIME IT
WILL BE TEN MINUTES ON BOTH
SIDES- SO I KNOW WE HAVE
MULTIPLE WITNESSES- FOR EACH
SIDE. JUST BE CONSCIOUS THAT THE
MORE ONE PERSON GOES OVER DEBTS
LAST TIME FOR THE REMAINDER SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE OPPOSITION
UNDERSTANDS FIVE WITNESSES. IT'S
THE FOURTH USE THE L. THE TIME
RUNS OUT THE FOURTH ONE IT WILL
STOP THERE AND THE FIFTH ONE CAN
SIMPLY SAY THAT THEY'RE AN
OPPOSITION LIKE A THAT SELF JUST
WANT PEOPLE TO BE CONSCIOUS OF
THE USER. SO THAT WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE AUTHORS OF
THE BILL COMES ON BURKE AND
EGGMAN- PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU-
A MISS. I WILL TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AN
IMPRINT. THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT REYES DHEAS FOR THEIR
HARD AND BENEFICIAL WORK ON THE
BILL- TODAY AND JOIN WITH JOINT
AUTHORS SENATOR EGGMAN AND THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS BETTER THAN
PERHAPS ANYONE ELSE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- THAT CENTER EGGMAN
HAS BEEN BOTH INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
THE LEGISLATURE A CHAMPION WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE WITH MENTAL.
ILLNESS UP. CANACCORD IS A
PROPOSED FRAMEWORK SPONSORED BY
GOVERNOR TO DELIVER BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO THE MOST
SEVERELY IMPAIRED CALIFORNIANS
THOSE SUIT TOO OFTEN LANGUISH
SUFFERING IN HOMELESSNESS OR
INCARCERATION. AND- IT IS ALSO.
IF FRAMEWORK TO SUPPORT THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE WERE SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL THE FAMILIES THE
KNOW THE ANGUISH OF LOOKING FOR
A LOT OF LOVE WANTED FOR IN THE
MORNING WHEN THEY CAN'T SLEEP
THE FAMILIES THAT KNOW THE
ANGUISH. OF RECEIVING A PHONE
CALL IT MIDNIGHT IN ACTUALLY
HOPING IT'S FROM THE JAIL VERSUS
THE HOSPITAL. THE ANGUISH OF
WONDERING WONDERING WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS GOING TO BE THE
ANGUISH OF THINKING THINGS HAVE
GONE WELL AND FINDING OUT THAT
PERHAPS THEY HADN'T GONE AS WELL
AS ONE WOULD HOPE- THE- THE
RESPONSE THE- FOR INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS FOR IN A INDIVIDUALS
WERE SUFFERING WITH UNTREATED.
SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM INSIDE
CAL PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS ALL
HOUSE IN OUR COMMUNITIES FACE
HIGH RISKS FOR REPEATED
HOSPITALIZATION INCARCERATION
INSTITUTIONALIZATION MENTAL
HEALTH CONSERVATORSHIP AND
PREMATURE DEATH A COMPREHENSIVE
CARE MEDICATION HOUSING HAVE
BEEN CLINICALLY PROVEN TO
SUCCESSFULLY TREAT AND STABILIZE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. WHAT ARE TOO OFTEN-
AVAILABLE ONLY AFTER RESTORE IN
SECURE FACILITIES THERE FOR S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY IT WILL
CREATE A PROGRAM TO CONNECT A
PERSON IN CRISIS. WITH COURT
ORDERED CARE PLAN. TO TWELVE
MONTHS WITH THE ABILITY EXTENDED
FOR ANOTHER TWELVE MONTHS. THE
PROGRAM PROVIDES INDIVIDUALS
WITH A CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE
COMMUNITY BASED SET OF SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS THAT ARE CULTURALLY
AND LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT.
THIS INCLUDES SHORT TERM
STABILISATION MEDICATIONS
WELLNESS AND RECOVERY SUPPORTS
AND CONNECTION TO SOCIAL
SERVICES INCLUDING HOUSING. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A JOURNEY
OF THE JOURNEY THE LEGISLATIVE
JOURNEY BEGAN YESTERDAY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CONTINUES
TODAY BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL MORE
STEPS IN THE PROCESS AND THE
CHAIR AND I HAVE HAD A
CONVERSATION I KNOW TEACHERS
DISCUSS WITH OTHERS. SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL AND WE
EXPECT THE BILL WILL IMPROVE AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS-
THE CONCERNED CONCERNING HOUSING
IS ONE. WE ALL SHARE THESE
DRESSED- BUT I WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS DOES NOT DO. CARE COURT IS
NOT A CONSERVATORSHIP THERE IS
NOT A IT'S NOT A SUBSTITUTE. OF
FOR THE DECISION MAKER FOR THE
FOR THE PERSON WHO IS. ILL CARE
COURT DOES NOT CREATE A PATH TO
OPPRESS CARE COURT IS A CIVIL
COURT NOT A CRIMINAL COURT CARE
COURT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR FORCED
INVOLUNTARY MEDICATION. CARE
COURT DISPENSED CANNOT BE FORCED
TO PARTICIPATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL NOT ARREST THEM IF THEY DO
NOT COME TO COURT. CARE COURT
DOES NOT INVOLVE SECURE
FACILITIES. CARE COURT DOES NOT
TAKE AWAY RIGHTS DUE PROCESS IS
PROTECTED SELF DETERMINATION
IS OFFER A NEW PARADIGM IT
OFFERS A- NEW- NEW TOOL. TO
ADDRESS THOSE SEVEN TO TWELVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE CURRENTLY
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL AND WHO WE
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO REACH-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TODAY WE
HAVE- DR MARK GALLI SECTOR
CALIPHS FOR CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY DR.
ALEX COUPLE WHAT'S OF PROFESSOR
OF PSYCHIATRY IN A BIO
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AT UCLA IS
ALSO MEDICAL DIRECTOR SAN
FERNANDO. MENTAL HEALTH CENTER
AND CHIEF OF PSYCHIATRY AT THE
SISTERS TO XIN ALL OF YOU
MEDICAL CENTER AND FINALLY
CRISTINA ROB. CORRECTIVE
PROGRAMS FOR CRISIS INTERVENTION
TRAINING INTERNATIONAL IN A
NOMINEE CALIFORNIA BOARD MEMBER
AND I'D LIKE TO TURN OVER THE-
MICROPHONE TO THE JOINT AUTHORS
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SARAH BURKE'S ENTERTAINMENT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M VERY HONORED
TO BE HERE TODAY WITH. THAT WAS
CENTER- BERG. OUR OUR DAY TO OF-
OF TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL WITH
OUR WITH OUR COLLEAGUES- YOU ALL
YOU PROBABLY MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
MY A BILL PACKAGE AND- HAVE SEEN
FROM THE BEGINNING FROM
INTERVENTIONS. ALL THE WAY TO
THE VERY END A CONSERVATORSHIP
WE ARE TRYING TO FIX AND REPAIR
OF FRAGMENTED AND BROKEN MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. OTHER I. AM
LEADING FULLY INTO THAT AND
HOPEFULLY YOU AGREE THAT MY
FIXES WORLD WILL IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM. BUT WHAT I CANNOT DO AS
AN INDIVIDUAL LEGISLATOR OR WHAT
CENTER- BERGEN I CANNOT DO IS
CREATE THIS WHOLE NEW.
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COME UP WITH-
TO MY ROLE AS BUDGET CHAIR I'VE
BEEN ENGAGING WITH DOCTOR GALLEY
FOR. FEELS LIKE I GUESS YEARS
NOW- AROUND THIS ISSUE ABOUT A
NEW PLAN A NEW PARADIGM A NEW
WAY OF DOING THINGS- WE PASSED
LPS LAWS AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. LORD KNOWS- OUR WORLD HAS
CHANGED SINCE THEN WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THE TROPICS WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT. A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES-
JUST THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
RUSTIC WHICH- IS ANYBODY SITTING
IN THIS. THIS HASN'T BUT SO AT
SOME LEVEL WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
WITH A SEVERE PERSISTENT MENTAL
HEALTH OR KNOW SOMEBODY WHO HAS
OR HAS NOT TOUCH. JUST NO IT
DEPENDS OUT WE A PROBLEM WITH
HOME AND MEANT HEALTH ISSUE AS
THEY AS THEY AND THE NOT
EVERYBODY WAS HOMELESS HAS
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES NOR NOR
CONVERSELY BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
THERE IS A- A POPULATE. ONE
SEVEN TWELVE THOUSAND THAT THIS
BILL WOULD APPLY TO AND AGAIN
THIS IS NOT FORCED THIS IS A NEW
PARADIGM OF INVITING PEOPLE INTO
A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS. AND
HOLDING OUR SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE
YOU ALL HEARD WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SETTING IT DOWN TO
OUR SYSTEMS AT SOME POINT WE
HAVE TO HOLD THE SYSTEMS AND
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
DOLLARS THAT WE SPEND. I THINK
THE DARK CONSTITUENTS EXPECT
MORE- ON THE STREETS DESERVE
MORE. SO WITH THAT- ASK YOU TO
LOOK AT THIS WITH THE OPEN
HEARTS AND MINDS AND I WOULD
INVITE THE CHAIRED INVITE UP OUR
FIRST WITNESS RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH
COURSE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF-
WILL BEGIN WITH A- DOCTOR MARK
ALL THE SECRETARY OF. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS- WE HAVE A TOTAL OF TEN
MINUTES FOR THE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY I NOTICED THREE
WITNESSES I'M JUST GONNA CALL UP
EVERY TWO MINUTES SO YOU KNOW IF
YOU PLAN TO GO OVER THAT JUST.
JUST KEEP GOING CELTIC TO PETS
AND INFORM AT SIX SO THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE HAVE AT LEAST SOME
MARKERS. AND WHERE THEY ARE IN
TERMS OF THE SPEAKING BUT- AND I
KNOW THE OTHER TWO IN THIS IS
DRAWN THE LINE SO- SEPARATELY.
WELCOME THANK YOU A MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU- TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SENATORS EGGMAN
AMBERG. THANK YOU FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP. TIM O'CONNELL
DEEPLY COMPASSIONATE PHYSICIAN
AND FOUNDER OF BOSTON'S HEALTH
CARE FOR THE HOMELESS PROGRAM IS
REFERENCED IN THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
ARTICLE TITLED LIBERTY VERSUS
NEED OUR STRUGGLE TO CARE FOR
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS. IN THAT ARTICLE DR
O'CONNELL TELLS THE STORY OF A
WOMAN HE ENCOUNTERED WHO LIVED
ON A STOOP FOR TWO AND A HALF
YEARS BUT WOULDN'T ALLOW THE
OUTREACH TEAM TO GIVE HER A
SANDWICH OR SOCKS. WOMEN
INCESSANTLY WHENEVER SHE WAS
APPROACHED ONE DAY SHE BECAME SO
WHEN WE WERE IN SICK THE POLICE
BROUGHT HER TO THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. AND SHE WAS
ULTIMATELY CONSERVE. O'CONNELL
RAN INTO WERE YEARS LATER AT A
MEETING AT A NONPROFIT. SHE WAS
A BOARD MEMBER ALL DRESSED UP IN
TOTALLY TRANSFORMED. YOU LOOK
FABULOUS HE SAID. AND SHE SAID
SCREW YOU SCREW YOU. YOU LEFT ME
OUT THERE FOR ALL THOSE YEARS
AND DIDN'T HELP ME ONE BIT.
TODAY CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIANS
HAVE A DECISION TO MAKE. KEEP
TALL IN SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
SICKEST. CANACCORD REPRESENTS
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO STAND
TALL WITH AN ESTIMATED SEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND PARTICIPANTS
STATEWIDE CARE CORE CLINICAL
CRITERIA PROVIDE A NARROW ENOUGH
GROUP OF CALIFORNIANS WHEN WE
CAN ABSOLUTELY MEET THE NEED TO
MAKE A LOT ONTO MAIN DIFFERENCE.
TAKE A MOMENT DIFFERENT
YESTERDAY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS I HEARD THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THOSE WHO
OPPOSE CARE COURT. FIRST WHY DO
THIS THROUGH THE COURTS LET'S
BEGIN BY THE TRUE REALITY OF
WHERE WE ARE TODAY THE COURTS
ARE OFTEN IN THE CROSS HAIRS OF
THE LIVES OF THOSE SUFFERING
FROM SEVERE DECOMPENSATED MENTAL
ILLNESS. OFTEN IT'S THE CRIMINAL
COURTS AND NOT THE CIVIL COURTS
CAN ONLY AFTER WE WALKED BY
INDIVIDUAL SCREAMING OUT FROM
THE STOOPED I MEAN TIME AGAIN.
THE CRIMINAL COURT PATHWAYS ARE
NOT AN ENVIRONMENT FROM ANYONE
WITH IMPAIRED JUDGMENT FOR
INSIDE. DOES DISEASE SYMPTOMS
MAKE EVERY NEW VOICE EVERY NEW
SOUND A FURTHER DISORIENTING
CHALLENGE. THE CARE CORD IS A
VEHICLE FOR COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION NOT JUST COMPLIANCE
SECURE CORE PROCESS CAN BE
PROTECTIVE SUPPORT OF SUPPORT OF
PLACE THAT WILL START WITH A
PERIOD OF ENGAGEMENT CALL THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IN THE
LEGISLATION ALLOWING FOR THE
CURE CORPORATISM IN TO WORK WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM TO ARRANGE A
COMPREHENSIVE CARE PLANS. IF
OVER A SIXTY DAY PERIOD THE CARE
PLAN. CAN BE COMPLETED IN ON THE
ROAD IMPLEMENTATION THE COURTS
ONGOING INVOLVEMENT MIGHT BE
SMALL. IN THE CASE EITHER
BECAUSE OF THE KIND OF THE
CLIENT CAN'T PARTICIPATE OF THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES CAN'T
IMPLEMENT INAPPROPRIATE CARE
PLAN THAT'S PERSON CENTERED THE
COR WILL DEEPEN ITS ENGAGEMENT
IN OVERSIGHT. ALSO WE ARE NOT
TOUGH ASKING JUDGES TO BE
CLINICIANS WE ENSURE THAT THE
JUDGES HAVE CLINICAL SUPPORT TO
DO THE WORK- THAT IS NECESSARY.
SECOND ISSUE FROM YESTERDAY.
WHAT ABOUT THE WELL DOCUMENTED
IN EQUITIES IN CLINICAL
DIAGNOSIS AND THE COURT SYSTEMS
WE HAVE TODAY. THESE ARE ISSUES
WE SHOULDN'T AND DON'T TAKE
LIGHTLY WE MUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THESE REALITIES. AND ADDRESS
THEM IN THE FORMATIVE DESIGN OF
THE PROGRAM. WE WILL NOT CHANGE
THE SYSTEMS OVERNIGHT BUT WE CAN
MAKE BIG IMPROVEMENTS WE CAN
ENSURE STANDARDIZED TOOLS FOR
ASSESSMENT AN EVALUATION A
REVIEW BY MANY WITHIN HI FOR
AMELIORATING. THESE FEATURES
THAT DRIVE IN EQUITY. WE CAN
TRAIN INDIVIDUALS. PARTICIPATING
IN THE CARE COR PROCESS TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE A KEEN
AWARENESS OF THESE DRIVERS OF
INEQUITY AND THEIR OWN ROLE IN
PERPETUATING THEM WE CAN INVEST
IN A- SINISTER. OF ROSS IS IN
THE CARE SYSTEM SO THAT WE CAN
APPROVE THEM ALONG THE WAY WE
CAN IN A ENGAGE COMMUNITIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS FOR NOT JUST. IN
THIS FORMATIVE DAYS OF THE CARE
COURT PROPOSAL BUT REGULARLY AS
THE PROGRAM IS DEVELOPED FOR THE
YEARS TO COME. THIRD WHY THE SET
OF DIAGNOSES AND ARE WE AWARE OF
THE RACIAL INEQUITIES IN
DIAGNOSING AND TREATING TREATING
SCHIZOPHRENIA. IN BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES FIRST THE NEAR
YOUR NEAR OR SET OF CLINICAL
CRITERIA IS MEANT TO FOLLOW THE
EVIDENCE. WE KNOW THAT THE
INTERVENTIONS PROPOSED IN CARE
IN THE CURRENT CORE MODEL CAN
WORK FOR PERSONS SUFFERING FROM
THESE ILLNESSES. FIFTEEN
TREATMENT APPROACH THE
MEDICATIONS THE COMMUNITY BASED
HOUSING WE ALSO KNOW THIS
APPROACH DOESN'T WORK FOR
EVERYONE SO IT ISN'T MEANT TO BE
TRIED FOR EVERYONE. REGARDING
THE ISSUE OF RACIAL INEQUITIES
IN THE DIAGNOSIS OF THESE
CONDITIONS THIS IS REAL AND MUST
BE FRONT OF MIND WE SHOULD
CHALLENGE OURSELVES TO IMPROVE
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THESE
DEBILITATING ILLNESSES. IMPACT
DIFFERENT GROUPS DIFFERENTLY AND
HOW WE CAN BE SURE OUR CLINICAL
PROCESSES NOT JUST PARKOUR
PROPHECIES ACCOUNT FOR THESE
UNDERSTANDINGS AND FURTHER THEM
UP FOR THE NOT FOR LEARNED OR
STANDING. FOURTH WHY ISN'T THE
HOUSING REQUIRED. LOOK THE
REQUIREMENT FOR A HOUSING PLAN
ALLOWS. THE HOUSING PLAN ALLOWS
THE NEED FOR THE INDIVIDUAL TO
BE MORE FLEXIBLE YOU INCLUDED
INTO THE OVERALL CARE PLAN. THAT
SAID LET ME BE CLEAR AS THE CO
CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA'S
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS I KNOW WE KNOW THE
LEVEL OF RECENT INVESTMENT. IN
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS AND
ADDITIONAL PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
THIS YEAR- TOTAL WITH FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS WITH ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION OF THIS YEAR'S
PROPOSED GOVERNOR BUDGET
DEDICATED TO BEHAVIORAL. BRIDGE
HOUSING- THAT IS MEANT TO TARGET
EXACTLY THE POPULATION CAR THAT
COULD BE CARE CORPORATIST
OFFENSE. BEFORE CLOSING I WANT
TO HAVE ASK A QUESTION OF MINE.
AS A CLINICIAN WHO IS LED HEALTH
CARE PROGRAMS FOR THE HOMELESS
IN SKID ROW IN LOS ANGELES AND
THROUGHOUT THAT. PROBATIVE
OVERSEEN JAIL HEALTH SERVICES
BOTH IN THE ADULT SYSTEM AND THE
CHILDREN SYSTEM. WHO HAS STARTED
AND SUPPORTED DIVERSION PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES WHO ARE CAUGHT UP
IN THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. I ASK WHY
DO WE HAVE TO WAIT SO LONG. WHY
MUST WE WAIT UNTIL THE BOTTOM
HAS FALLEN OUT. THE CHARGES
FILED IN THE ARREST IS MADE WHAT
IS HE MADE ABOUT THAT. WHERE IS
THE CIVIL IN THE APPROACH TO
CIVIL LIBERTIES I KNOW THIS IS A
HARD ISSUE BUT MAYBE IT'S MY
CLINICAL BENT MY UPSTREAM IS TO
HOPE. THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
UNTIL THE ONLY SYSTEM THAT IS
CAPABLE AND WILLING TO SERVE OUR
SICKEST HAS BARS IN FRONT. THAN
COLD WALLS ON THE SIDE. WHERE
THE INVESTMENTS ARE STEEP AND
THE RETURN ON THOSE INVESTMENTS
ARE QUICKLY SWALLOWED TO THE
LACK OF ANY INCURRING COMMUNITY
. I'LL CLOSE BY JUST SAYING-I
KNOW THIS IS A HARD ISSUE FOR
MANY OF US AND- THESE ARE
CHALLENGING THINGS TO CONSIDER I
THINK TODAY JUST LIKE YESTERDAY
AND TOMORROW AS WE WORK SIDE BY
SIDE AND A COMMITMENT FOR ME TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU ARE THE
ENTIRE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK
WITH ALL OF YOU. AND IMPORTANTLY
WITH OUR PARTNERS ARE THOSE WHO
TODAY OPPOSE- THIS CONCEPT THIS
FRAMEWORK BUT THAT WE CAN FIND
COMMON GROUND THAT THOSE
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION WILL
REMAIN OPEN AND THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO LOOK AT EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE
WE PUT THE CALIFORNIA WAY
FORWARD. A STRONG AND COMMITTED
WAY TO THE SICKEST OF THE SICK
ON OUR STREETS- SO WITH THAT-
THE PLAN I THINK IT DR ALEX
CAPELLO WHAT'S TO FOLLOW. THANK
YOU- TOM MODERATOR FREE IS FREE
ON TO THE LINE WE FOR START
WITH- DR ALEX COUPLE IT'S THAN
US AND THEN ALSO FOLLOWED BY
CRISTINA ROOP I SHOULD JUST
MENTION FOR THE TWO OF YOU- YOU
HAVE ESSENTIALLY TWO MINUTES AND
EIGHT SECONDS REMAINING FOR BOTH
OF YOU SO JUST KEEP THAT IN
MIND- THE START WITH DOCTOR.
HELLO IT'S- GOOD AFTERNOON. THIS
IS ALWAYS THE BALLOT. PLEASE
NEARLY YES PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY I
WAS THE COACH IS WORKING WITH
THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL OF
LOS ANGELES FOR THE PAST THIRTY
FOUR YEARS FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS I'VE BEEN THE CHIEF OF
PSYCHIATRY AT ALL IF YOU USE
DELAYED MEDICAL CENTER WHICH IS
ONE OF THE THREE PUBLIC
HOSPITALS L. A. COUNTY WITH A
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY ROOM. WE
RECEIVE ABOUT FIFTEEN PATIENTS A
DAY ON- OVER THE YEARS I'VE
WITNESSED THE RAVAGES. BECAUSE
OF. AND RELATED. MULTIPLE
THOUSAND PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. CHARLIE I THINK MANY
OF THESE SAME PATIENTS VITAL TO
THE ER. BROKEN OFTEN WITH THEIR
EXASPERATED PARENTS. RELATED
STORIES OF THEIR ILL RELATIVES
EXPERIENCING OVERWHELMING FOR
CHRONIC SYMPTOMS. INSPECTIONS
ARE BROUGHT TO THE HOSPITAL
USUALLY UP SOMETHING GATORS THE
CURTAINS THOSE BROTHERS. BUT
THEN GET BETTER WITH APPROPRIATE
CARE INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED
TO THE USE. OF MEDICATION.
AUTOCRINE MANY PATIENTS GET MUCH
BETTER WITH TREATMENT BUT I THEY
READ TO IT'S NOT THEIR MED.
BECAUSE THEY THINK CARE AND OF
THE PART OVER. WATCHES HAVE IS
HARD. I DON'T HEAR TO EXPO ABOUT
HER SOME WILL. A EPISODE BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT I WANTED TO YOUR
TO. MY FOCUS IS ON THAT WE- THAT
IS MEANT HEALTH IS. FOR DOING
THE STATE AND THEIR- BY NOT
PROVIDING THEM WITH ADEQUATE
TREATMENT WHEN THEY NEED IT AND
FOR AS LONG AS THEY NEED IT.
ILLNESSES SUCH AS SCHIZOPHRENIA
OR DISEASES THAT IMPACT DIRECTLY
ON THE BRAIN. THE RESEARCH IS
CLEAR THAT THE LONGER A PERSON
GOES UNTREATED THE WORST LONG
TERM OUTCOME OF THE CONDITION.
THAT MEANS GETTING PEOPLE THE
CHEAPER THAN KEEPING THEM IN
TREATMENT IS OF THE UTMOST
PRIORITY ISSUE WITH NOT ONE IS
DOUBLE RIGHT BECAUSE THEY HELP
PROFESSIONAL I BELIEVE A
PATIENT- MOUNTABLE RIGHT SHOULD
BE ACCESS TO ATTIC TREATMENT.
WISHFUL THINKING AT BEST IN
GROSS NEGLIGENT AT WORST TO
EXPECT THAT A PERSON WITH SEVERE
PSYCHOSIS WILL BE ENCOURAGED OF
WHAT IS BEST FOR HIM OR HER. THE
REASON IS THAT ALL TOO OFTEN
THESE PATIENTS LACK MEDICAL
DECISION MAKING TO PASS. THE
WORD TO THE ALMOST IMPAIR.
UNDERSTAND BENEFITS AND RISKS OF
APPROACH TREATMENT. MEDICAL
DECISION MAKING CAPACITY IS NOT
AN ABSTRACT NOTION IT COULD BE
RELIABLY IS BEST. WAY TRAIN
COULDN'T. ME FISHING MISTER
UNDERSTOOD OF THIS THE- OCT
THIRTY TIMES TO COME. OF THEIR
TO AS A- AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
THIS UP TO. THE OTHER HAVE TO
CLEAN MY JOB UNCLE DR YOUR TIMES
UP THANK YOU THANK VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATED THANK THANK YOU FOR
NEWS PERSON THANK YOU. SORRY BUT
YOUR TIME IS- MY- YEAH I'VE- BUT
- FOR YOUR TIME IS A AND I DID
SET THINK I SAID UP THE RULES
FOR CLEARLY BEGINNING. I WILL
ARGUE THAT INTRODUCERS. AND YOUR
OWN. AND HI SUE YOU'RE OBVIOUS
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT THE BILL TO
AND FORTY WE OUT TO FRAME FOR
THE CUSTOMER SO. CAN WE BRING
ACTORS ROOP TO STUFF. BALCER THE
BILL DORGAN'S SHE'S REPRESENTING
. YES MISTER KERR THIS IS
CHRISTINA RICHTER RECTOR
PROGRAMS THAT UNITE
INTERNATIONAL YEAH I AM A FAMILY
MEMBER AND IF YOU'RE AND I USED
TO WORK AIRPORT. OKAY DEAL THANK
YOU AND AGAIN I APOLOGIZE BUT-
THE- THE TIME IS. TIME IS OUT SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT TOUR
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED YEN
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WELCOME LEAVE BARROWS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS MILLION SUPERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MORE TOP HERE ON BEHALF
OF. SAN DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA
AND THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. DOCTOR SUSAN
PART TOBY THIS TIME I AM
REPRESENTING LA COUNTY'S GREAT
DISABILITY WORKGROUP. THANK YOU
. IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M THERMIC
DATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE ARE A TWEENER UP TO
EXPRESS CONCERNS RELATED TO
FUNDING HOUSING SANCTIONS AND
OTHER ISSUES BUT READY TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE IT WORK. I
THINK THANK YOU. SERIKAT ON
BEHALF OF THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND LIKE SEE SECRETARY IN
BETWEEN- AND WE HAVE A CONCERNS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
AUTHORS IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ELHAM'S CHAIR
THIS IS RYAN ELAINE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SAY NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE WILL NOW GO TO
TELECONFERENCE LINE- JUST A
REMINDER- AS A NOW IT'S AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING OTHER
MADE YOU MAY NOT SIGNED ON YET.
WE WILL TAKE UP TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY- IN TERMS
OF- ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR EACH
SIDE. IF WE HAD FIFTEEN MINUTES-
ANYONE WHO ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
TO YOU CAN ALWAYS SEND IT YOUR
TESTIMONY ALSO DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMITTEE ALSO FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO EXPRESS YOU KNOW. MORE
THAN SIMPLY EXPRESSING SUPPORT
FEEL FREE TO ALSO SEND THE
LETTER WITH THAT WHERE YOU CAN
EXPRESS MORE THOROUGHLY YOUR
THOUGHTS OR IDEAS OF THINGS YOU
WANT EXPRESS AGAIN IN WRITING TO
THE COMMITTEE. SO WITH THAT
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO IS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. HE LATER EXPRESSED
YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL YOU HAVE
NOT ALREADY DONE SO. ME PRESS
ONE NUMBER ZERO. WELL THE FIRST
THE LINE FORTY ONE. FOUR ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN ARE YOU ON
MUTE. HELLO MY NAME IS. ABOUT
THE VISION OF THE PARTICULAR
BILL I MIGHT BE A LITTLE TAKE
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW AND AGAIN IT'S
NAME WORKSTATION SO- SO WE WILL
TAKE OPPOSITION AFTERWARDS
YOU'LL HAVEYOUR OPPORTUNITY SO
AGAIN IT'S SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. BLIND.
TWO HUNDRED. SHE DIDN'T GIVE ME
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY REPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. TWO OR
THREE. HELLO TARGET BY EAT THEM
AT THE TIME BEGIN IF YOU ARE AN
UNTAPPED THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. ONE TWENTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
IS DIANE MAY BE FAMILY ADVOCATE
CALIFORNIA AND I AM. SENATE BILL. THE THREE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE SEVENTY. I CRISTINA
VERA NAMI GREATER LOS ANGELES
COUNTY MINUS POLY AFFILIATE AND
I AM TOTALLY DISAPPOINTED YEAH
THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT THIS.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT. ONE ONE THREE
ARE YOU ON ME. YEAH YOU GOT ME
THERE AND CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
NOT ME MONTEREY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY ONE EIGHTY
ONE. LET THEY OFFER REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL LINE. THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT THIS. ONE SIXTY TWO.
WHEN YOU WERE YOUNG YOU. PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. WILL MOVE
THE LINE SEVENTY NINE. AFTERNOON
KELLY BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
IRVINE COUNTY AT THE CALIFORNIA
SEE ALSO HAVE A CLEANER POSITION
ON WHAT THANK YOUNG TECH THANK
YOU X. WITNESSED. EIGHTY SEVEN.
ONE EIGHTY SEVENTY OTHER. MOVE
THE ONE SEVENTY FIVE.
OVER ONE EIGHTY SIX THANK.
ESTATE. TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. YES PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. LORD ABBETT
ON BEHALF OF MY LATE BROTHER AT
THE DOOR WHO DIED IT'S A PRETTY
TOO EARLY AND THAT FAMILIES ARE
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL FROM
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
PINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE. YES HELLO
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF OKAY ANTHONY TO FISHER
IF YOU'RE MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTANT AND A MOTHER OF AN
ADULT I'M LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU X. WITNESS. NINE ONE
TWO THREE- MARLENE EARLIER ADULT
A MOTHER OF AN ADULT BODY WITH A
LONG HISTORY OF MENTAL ILLNESS
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT MAKING AN
ARREST IN STRONG WHAT ABOUT THE. ONE EIGHT THREE EIGHT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY. ONE FORTY
THREE. FIVE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES SIR PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. CASEY ON THE BOARD
RESIDENTS OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCACY SERVICES TO LEGAL AID
NON. PROFIT FOUNDATION LOS
ANGELES FATHER OF IT BOSTON
WHICH GETS OFFENDED A STRONG
SUPPORT SB THIRTY DEBATE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE FORTY
FIVE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
BURGER STERN NUMBING CONTRA
COSTA FAMILY BELOVED ALMOST THE
SERVER MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. BY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN.
ONE SIX SEVEN OR YOU ON MUTE.
WILL MOVE THE LINE ONE SIXTY
FIVE. YES YES WE ARE GOING TO
SELF. MY NAME IS BOB BURTON. I'M
A FAMILY MEMBER THE BARELY. BUT
PRODUCT INDIVIDUAL AND I FOUND
IT OR CALL OF YOUR QUARTER
FILLED. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BLIND ONE THIRTY ONE THREE ZERO
. HELLO THIS IS LINDA HADAL AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL HAVE AN ADULT SON WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA I HAVE WORKED FOR
PERSONS SERVING UNDER SERVICES
ALL MY LIFE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. NINE TWO
OH SIX. HI MY NAME IS KATIE
WILSON NUMBER SIX EIGHT THREE
THOUSAND FARMS THE CALIFORNIA
WORKING JAIL AGEN CAN'T COUNTY
HEALTH THANKS. THREE FIVE PETER
EIGHT MILLION- OF THE S. B.
THREE EIGHT I THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE
THIRD. ONE ALL MY NAME IS
CHRISTY RAINY ARMS HAVING
SUFFERED FROM A MENTAL ILLNESS
AND- AND STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE
SPELL AND THEY JUST WANT TO ADD
TO IT BECAUSE I HOPE THEY THIS
THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
DURING THANK YOU WE'RE JUST
TAKING NAY MARKS A SOME POSITION
BUT- THANK YOU. THANKS WITNESS
NINE ONE. THEY GIVE PLAN. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. BORDERLINE. ONE FORTY TWO.
FOUR ONE FORTY TWO WERE YOU ONE
YOU. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX. ONE FIVE SIX ARE YOU THERE. BORDERLINE TWO OH EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS FIRST
LOOKED UP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS ONE ONE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHT ZERO. THE FIRST
ONE WELL I'M SPEAKING FOR MYSELF
AND MY FAMILY AND ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT I'VE DEALT WITH IN MY JOB.
WE'RE REALLY MENTALLY ILL THE
CORRECTIVE. THANK YOU THANKS
WITH THIS. BY. TWO ZERO SEVEN
TWO OH SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ALL SCREEN BUT BUT NOT
ME. CHARLIE RESPONSE. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. PINE TO TWELVE.
HELLO THISIS ELIZABETH PRIETO-
I'M CALLING TO REPRESENT FUNDING
SUPPORT FOR FAMILY AND FRIENDS
TO SOMEONE LVING WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS TO REGISTER
SUPPORTED STILL ALSO REPRESENT
MYSELF AS A PARENT. OF A
DAUGHTER WITH SEVERE. READ
SECOND DISORDER UNTREATED LIVING
ON THE STREETS OR IN CUSTODY FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SWEETNESS. BLIND TO
FOURTEEN. I AM BRIAN BLOOM BUT
THE THOUGHT HELP AS REPORT YEAH
COUNTY- COACH HERE THE CRIMINALS
THE COMMITTEE OF THAT BOOK AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE FARE FOR
SALE LAUGH AT WORK IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY MANDATED BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TROPHY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. WHAT. TO FIFTY TO ONE
FIVE. AFTERNOON THAT THE JUSTICE
CRUZ YELLOW OF NAMI CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LINE. TWO EIGHTEEN. HI
THIS IS THERESA HAVE WE NEED A
PROUD MOM OF ADULT SON WHO IS
ROUGHLY WITH IT SO ACTED
DISORDER AND I AM CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. FIND ONE NINETY TWO.
ONE NINETEEN WERE YOU ON MUTE.
MOVING ON THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANKS VERY MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I-
I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE FIVE
WITNESSES. A REGISTERED TEST.
OPPOSITION I STRUGGLE HERE ANDY
IMPARATO WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
FOLLOWED BY YOU KNOW WARREN FROM
NEIGHBORHOOD WELLNESS FOUNDATION
FOLLOWED BY NICOLE MENDOZA
FOLLOWED BY MICHELLE CABRERA
FROM THE COUNTY COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND FINALLY ROB LANE
FROM THE CALIPHATE COUNCIL ON
COMMITTEE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES THAT I GET THAT RIGHT
NOW AGAIN. MY REINFORCE TEN
MINUTES. I'LL CALL OUT EVERY TWO
MINUTES TWO FOUR SIX EIGHT TEN
AND A TEN WERE DONE SO. TO KEEP
IN MIND EVERYONE TERMS OF WHEN
YOU'RE TESTIFYING IF YOU GO OVER
THAT'S BILL WOULD JUST
UNATTENDED SELF ALL RIGHT SO
JUST A THE ONLY ONE TO FEEL
SURPRISED HER. AND WITH REASON
YOU HEARD WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PROTEST SOMEBODY THE LAST PERSON
WAS NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY SO WITH
THAT- WILL GO AHEAD TO BEGIN
WITH THE ANTI APARTHEID AS A
LEADOFF WITH THIS PLEA RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WELCOME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MY NAME'S ANDY. ACTOR OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO A LAWYER WHO'S BEEN LIVING
WITH BIPOLAR DISORDER FOR THIRTY
TWO YEARS. AND YOU KNOW THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING I CAN SAY AND I
WAS HERE YESTERDAY AS WELL AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED- SENATOR
ON BRUCE COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE AS
BILL AS TO OF ALL AND I
APPRECIATE. SECRETARY DOLLARS
COMMITMENT ON THAT AS WELL.
FUNDAMENTALLY IF THIS IS A
RECOVERY AND EMPOWERMENT ARE AND
THE E. AND CANACCORD. THE BEST
WAY TO DESIGN A NEW FRAMEWORK
THAT'S GOING TO GET TO RECOVERY
AND EMPOWERMENT. IS TO TALK TO
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RECOVERED. AND
ARE LIVING GOOD LIVES WITH LONG
TERM MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
INCLUDING SKITS OF. AND CONCERN
UP UNTIL THIS POINT IS THAT THAT
VOICE HAS NOT BEEN PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PROPOSAL
THERE ARE FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS
OPPOSING THE PROPOSAL. ALL OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL AS IT
WAS WRITTEN WHAT. FROM SEPTEMBER
. JUDITH BAKER IN THIS COMMITTEE
IS THAT IT'S INTENDED TO BE
COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY THAT NOBODY
WOULD BE FORCED TO PARTICIPATE
IN CARE COURT. BUT WE ALSO HEARD
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISMS AND
THAT FOR PEOPLE TO BE ELIGIBLE
TO BE REFERRED KARAKUL. NOT HAVE
INSIDE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
MEDICAL DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
SO IT'S JUST NOT CLEAR TO ME HOW
CARE RECORD IS GOING TO BE
VOLUNTARY. AND HOW THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE ANY FORS IF IT'S A
COURT ORDERED CARE PLANS AND THE
PEOPLE ARE GOING INTO IT OR
BEING REFERRED BY OTHER PEOPLE
PRESUMABLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT TO BE. IN THE COURT ORDERED
CARE. WE TAKE SENATOR UMBERG GOT
HIS- THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
FORCE TREATMENT IT'S NOT ABOUT
FORCED MEDICATION. WE THINK THAT
IF THAT'S TRUE. THE OPPOSITION
TO THIS IS GOING TO BE A LOT
LESS. BUT RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE
BILL IS WRITTEN IT'S JUST NOT
CLEAR. THE POINT ABOUT HOUSING
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. IT'S THE
PEOPLE ON THIS COMMITTEE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A- MOVEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AROUND THE COUNTRY.
LOTS OF GOOD EVIDENCE THAT SHOWS
IF YOU DON'T HAVE STABLE HOUSING
WHATEVER ELSE TO DO THIS. BEFORE
ON HOUSES NOT LET IT BE LONG
TERM EFFECTIVE SO I WILL. TURN
IT OVER TO DR GENERAL WARREN WHO
WAS ON THE PHONE THANK YOU.
EIGHT WATER PLEASE BRING GINA
WARREN FROM NEIGHBORHOOD
WELLNESS FOUNDATION ON. THE LINE
. HI THIS IS A IN A WARM LARA
COUNTY. AND I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER YOUR
EDUCATION WE ARE. OUT OF HIGH-
WHERE YOU'RE A FIFTY AMOUNT OF-
INDIVIDUALS WELL AS
NEIGHBORHOODS- COMMA I CAN'T
WRITE ANYTHING RELATIONAL
TRAUMA- MANY BANDS WHO HAVE
SHARED THEIR EXPERIENCES AND I
DON'T THE STORY BECAUSE
EXPERIENCE IS IMPACT OVER MY
FROM PHYSICAL HEALTH- AND
CORRELATE.
SO WHAT WE WANT YOU TO
UNDERSTAND IN OUR OPPOSITION
THAT. HAS FIFTY ACRES BURNED
STATED THAT THEY NEED FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES. TO CUT BUT
IT'S A LOT OF HELP. IT'S
DIFFERENT WHEN IT BECOMES. AND
SEVENTY ARE OUTSIDE OF THEIR
PERFECT EIGHT OFTEN OFTEN- YOU
TO A LOOKING IDENTIFY PEOPLE WHO
YOU CAN AUTOMATICALLY PLANS WHEN
ASKED AND THE DIAGNOSIS. IS NOT
INTIMATE. AND THAT'S FINE YOU
CAN'T CONFIDENCE IT'S THREE AND
UNDERSTANDING. EFFECTIVE PRINT.
BE ABLE THE COURT COURT. TELL
AND I AM FINALLY IF AS-
EFFECTIVE DIRECTOR AT. YES AND
AT THE CLINICAL PHARMACIST MADE
UP IN AND BEFORE IF I THANK YOU
FOR MUCH I WILL NOW MOVE TO. I
THINK IN PERSON THE CALL MENDOZA
ATTORNEYS TWO YEARS WORK OUT OF
STOCK I WAS BORN AND RAISED A
SINGLE PARENT A PERSON WITH
BORDER PERSONALITY DISORDER AND
SURVIVOR POLITICS SEXUAL ABUSE
IN RECENT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I
SEN- FOOD OUT OF TURN- STATIONS
AND SUICIDAL ID. I SHARE THIS
WITH YOU ALL BECAUSE THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT WILL SET US BACK
DECADES IN ADVANCEMENTS MADE IN
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. INSIDE
IN JUDGMENT OR NOT MAGICALLY
CAME THROUGH SHOULD CATION AND
CERTAINLY NOT IN IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE TREATMENT.
FIRST BECAUSE THE COMPLETE TRUST
THEIR ONLY FOR. THESE ARE THE
ACT OPPOSITE CONDITIONS WHICH
LEAD TO HOPE AND EMPOWERMENT
FURTHER IT IS AEROMEDICAL
ANSIBLE TO IMPULSIVELY DIMINISH
CIVIL RIGHTS OF VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS DURING TIMES OF WAR.
AS ANALOGOUS TO THE EUGENICS
MOVEMENT PROMINENT UNITED STATES
AT THE SAME TIME **** GERMANY
WAS LEGALLY MURDERED PEOPLE WITH
BILITY. HUNDREDS THOUSANDS FROM. NINETEEN FORTY NINE FORTY. THE
TREATMENT. OPTIMIZED WHEN I AND
THE ADVERSE IMPACT PEOPLE OF
COLOR COLOR WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISABILITIES. FURTHER IT OPENS
THE DOOR TO DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
AS IT WILL ALLOW FOR AN ABUSER
OF A PERSON WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION TO WEAPONIZE THAT
PERSON'S DISABILITY AGAINST THEM
INSTEAD LEGISLATORS SHOULD BASE
PAY ALMOST OUT REACH WORKERS
PEERS AND MY PROFESSIONALS. FUND
MORE OF THEM THE WHOLE WORK OF
ESTABLISHING TRUSTING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH CALIFORNIANS
LOSE ON THE STREETS. OF THE
SERVICES TO THEM. EIGHT AND
PRESERVE ACCESSIBLE DEEPLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LACK OF
HOUSING IN ADDITION TO SYSTEMIC
RACISM AND ABLEISM ARE THE TRUE
ROOTS OF OUR HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS. AND UNLIKE WHAT HAPPENED
HERE PLEASE INVOLVED HOMELESS
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE IN YOUR PROCESS IN
CLOSING AS A SISTER TO A PERSON
WITH INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY AND
AUTISM WHO GREW WITH STEP IN
STOCK WITHOUT ANY SERVICES I
UNDERSTAND. ISOLATION IN DEATH.
FAMILY FEEL THINKING THIRTY ONE
DISABILITIES BUT WITH A HEAVY
HEART I IS FIT IS THE NOT A- AND
I CAN YOU FROM SERVING ON HOUSE
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS FOR MANY YEARS THAT
WE ARE SAYING. OLD AS- WE'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS THE PERSON
WHO MLESTED ME AS A CHILD IS MY
UNCLE DIAGNOSED WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA HE LEFT OUR FAMILY
FOR MANY YEARS AND WE THOUGHT
THAT HE WAS DEAD. WE RECENTLY
LEARNED THAT HE IS ALIVE DUE TO
AN OUTREACH WORKER IN NEW MEXICO
AND- FOUND OF AN ENCAMPMENT
ESTABLISH TRUST AND HE IS NOW IN
HOUSING WITH SSI BECAUSE OF MY-
EXPERIENCE AND EDUCATION. I
WOULDN'T WISH- COURT EVEN ON HIM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO MICHELLE CABRERA FROM
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SISTER
ACTORS ASSOCIATION YOUR
PRESIDENT PERSON OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MITCHELL
COVETED OUT AND I'M SPEAKING
ABOUT TURNS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF A WHOLE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THAT. YEAH A LOT
CYCLE. IT WOULD CREATE FAST
REFERRAL. FOR FAMILY MY AND-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO EXPAND OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY NETS REACH THIS
INCLUDES MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
NOT YET ENGAGED IN SERVICES. AND
THE TENANT SEVEN OUT OF TEN
CALIFORNIANS WITH PRIVATE
COVERAGE. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST CONSIDERATION OF OUR
CONCERNS AND RECOMMENDATIONS ONE
WE NEED MORE DIVERSE AND MORE
ACCESSIBLE HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
OUR CLIENTS VIA CARE COURT. OUR
CLIENTS ARE OFTEN SCREENED OUT
OF HOUSING WERE TOLD TO GET TO
THE BACK OF THE LINE IF THERE
ARE HELPING AVAILABLE TO
BEGIN WITH. FOR FULL IN BILLION
ALL INVESTED INTO HOUSING TO BE
BROUGHT INTO CARE COURT WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
INVOLUNTARY SERVICES TODAY WHO
ARE ANNOUNCED WITH HOUSING PLANS
WAITING FOR HOUSING. TWO WE'RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE SINGLE
WORST WORKFORCE CRISIS OUR
SECTOR HAS EVER EXPERIENCED IF
WE TRY TO ABSORB A SIGNIFICANT
NEW EXPANSION OF SERVICES WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES WE WILL NEED
TO DIVERT CLINICIANS TO ON
REIMBURSABLE TIME SPENT WAITING
IN COURT. OUT IN THE FIELD
LOOKING FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
ENGAGE THEM INTO TREATMENT
PLANNING AND OTHER COURT
MANDATED ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
TRANSPORTING THEM BACK AND FORTH
TO COURT. DO THEY WILL NEED MORE
STATE AND SOME BONUSES WE WILL
NEED TO INCREASE SALARIES TO
ATTRACT NEW STAFF AND KEEP THE
ONES WE HAVE. WITHOUT NEW
FUNDING. WILL HAVE THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE OF
SHIFTING RESOURCES FUNDING AND
ATTENTION AWAY FROM KIDS AND
PREVENTION. AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAVE A FULL BLOWN YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS ON OUR HANDS WE
CANNOT AFFORD EITHER OPTION.
WITHOUT ANY NEW FUNDING WE ALSO
WORRY THAT THE CONCEPT OF FINES
AND RECEIVERSHIP WOULD ONLY HURT
OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SAFETY
NET. IN THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
WE COULD BE PLACED UNDER
RECEIVERSHIP AND DIVERT
RESOURCES AWAY FROM CORE MEDICAL
SERVICES INCLUDING CHILDREN.
CLEAN UP IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
THAT CONCEPTS LIKE QUALIFIED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS ARE
DEFINED AND ALIGNS ITS SCOPE OF
PRACTICE. TO REMOVE LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW ELIGIBILITY
BASED ON A NON CLINICAL REVIEW
OF RECORDS WITHOUT MEDICAL
SCREENING. TO ADDRESS HEALTHCARE
COURT WORK FOR DRUG INDUCED
PSYCHOSIS WHERE MENTAL ILLNESS
IS NOT THE PRIMARY CONDITION OR
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE FOR WHOM CAL IN
IS MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION TO REMOVE STIGMATIZING
DIAGNOSES. FINALLY THE BILL AS
DRAFTED WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERMINE OUR GROUND IN PARITY
LAW WHICH SENATOR WIENER
AUTHORED AND WE WOULD MEAN
TIGHTENED SIGNIFICANTLY TIGHTEN
CLOSE OF THOSE LOOPHOLES.
COLLECTIVELY OUR MEMBERS ARE
SEEKING CHANGE BEEN SURE THAT
CARE COURT CONTROL WELL IT'S-
INTERESTING. START THANK YOU.
FOR THE FINAL WITNESSES
OPPOSITION WE HAVE ROBERT LANE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
THREE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ON THE
LINE SO MODERATE PLEASE BRING-
ROB LANE ON TO THE LINE- YOU
HAVE- IT IT AND- NINE. THANK IN
A TERRIBLE IN THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL COMMUNITY BECAUSE THE
HALL THEY DIDN'T THE PUBLIC
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF A MODEL TO
ADDRESS- WHAT WE FEEL IS AN
INEFFECTIVE SYSTEM HAVE GOTTEN
TURNED ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF MORE
HEARTENED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE IN
THIS AND WORKING WITH OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES THAT AND FINDING
SOLUTIONS- ON OUR MEMBERS ARE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THE ABILITY OF
THIS GREAT. PLACE STARTING FOR
MANY BY MENTAL ILLNESS YEAH WE
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL THE WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
WORK ON HELPING STRENGTHENING
AND LANGUISHING IN THE STATE
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT STAND BY AND
DO NOTHING ABOUT THAT WE WANT TO
REMIND YOU THAT ARE HIGHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. IN WORKFORCE
RIGHT TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
SUPPORT INCLUDING PROPER FUNDING
AND RELIEF MINISTRY DEPARTMENT
ARSENAL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE TO
KEEP UP WITH DEMAND SO THAT
THEY'LL INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
EARMARKED FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THIS NEW MODEL THAT IS BEING
BUILT JUST GOT TO PUT THE STATE. ON ONE TRAINING OF ANY AND ALL
. TO ATTEND WITH INTO THE COURT
AND- AFTER THE STANDARD HOW AND
POSSIBLE THREE FOR. AT NIGHT THE
THERE IS A NEED PROVIDE. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE. FOR CHARACTER
THERE'S A NEW DIFFERENT THEM
FROM NIMBYISM ALEXIS AND
HEIRONEOUS FALLS. I THINK IT IS
AN EXTRACTION LATEST. ABOUT
TAKING OUR MEMBERS. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING THE
ADOPTION BECAUSE THANK YOU. FOR
YOU. ALL RIGHT- SO NOW A PLEA
THE- TO. THAT NOW- WILL BE
HEARING FROM- PEOPLE WHO WISH.
ATTEND AGAIN IN OPPOSITE. TO S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT NAME OR
EXIST POSITION ONLY AT THE
BEGINNING HERE ROOM- TWELVE
HUNDRED. WELCOME GOOD AFTERNOON
GOING BACK IS FOR THE OLD ARE
FOR. HEY SO YOU CAN ACTION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON SYNDICATE THE
ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LISA LEWIS
ON THE OF THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
FOR. EVERY WHO LOG THIS AND TAKE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND ORGANIZATIONS
ALSO KNOWN AS CAMPRO STRONG
OPPOSITION TO. THUS THE HOLY
FATHER AND CO FOUNDER OF CARE
COURT IS- OXYMORON. AND THEN
THERE'S NO CARRYING COURT IN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT WOULD BE WRONG
TO PUT PEOPLE'S RECORDS THANKS
OTHER MISTAKES THAT THANK YOU
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS SELLING BAN ON THE
RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO BUT A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY THAT I
STAND WITH THE FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS SOCIAL AND CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION TO OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN VICKERY WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ADRIN
SULTAN CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
HAVE A CONCERNS POSITION OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. TYLER IN THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION ABOUT
CONTRACT PROGRAM EXECUTIVES AND
WE HAVE A CONCERNS POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GALLAGHER
COWBOYS THIS OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. MARCUS ALL THE ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU. SENATOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF. IT IS AN
HONOR TO SERVE ABOUT TODAY
PLEASE PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF
SIR. MY NAME IS FOR COLON
NEUTRAL HYPHEN CLAIMANT. I'VE
BEEN STATE HYPHEN WITNESS HYPHEN
FEDERAL HIGHER AND WITNESS
SEARCH ARE YOU AN OPPOSITION YOU
CANNOT TELL ME MY NAME SIR
PLEASE DO NOT INTERRUPT ME I AM
A LIBERAL JUDGE YOU HAVE NO
AUTHORITY TO INTERRUPT ME. HI MY
NAME IS FULL COLOR NEUTRAL. HI
FRIENDS WITH. I'VE BEEN FEDERAL
HYPHEN WITNESS. HYPHEN FEDERAL
HAIDAR POSTMASTER THANK YOU
THINK LIFE IN FEDERAL HYPHEN
JUDGE THANK YOU I HAVE PHYSICAL
PHYSICAL FORENSIC EVIDENCE THANK
YOU SENATOR THANK YOU. THE
FLINTSTONES. THE SYSTEM IS
DESIGNED BY BIG PHARMA NEW
EDUCATION FOR DOCTORS ON THE
NERVOUS SYSTEM THAT MADAM
INTRODUCE YOURSELF. THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU
CAN NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
CAN ONLY. YOUR FORTY YEARS
AUTHENTIC LIVED EXPERIENCE FROM
- MINUTE DIAGNOSTIC LABELING
FIRST QUARTER OF COLLEGE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUING TO LET
OUR SYSTEM BE JUST. THANK YOU
NEXT THIS IS YOUR THANK YOU FOR
. THANK YOU NEXT. THANK YOU.
VEEDU AGEE LARS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER HOLISTIC CARE PRACTITIONER
QUANTUM NUTRITIONAL PRACTITIONER
CERTIFICATE CERTIFIED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION HERE THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. BILL NOW- GO TO
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU. EXPRESSED OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. AND IF YOU ARE IN QUEUE
FOR A DIFFERENT BILL YOU MEMBERS
MOVE YOURSELF TO REPEAT IN THE
COMMAND ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO FIRST BEHIND TWO OH NINE.
HERO MOTOCORP REMCO THE RACIAL
AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION. CLOSE
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THIS. TIME
TO TWENTY ONE. FOR THE CHANNEL
NUMBERS AND LAYING ON THE OFFICE
MAYOR LONDON BREED IN
FORTENBERRY. I AM. ALL RIGHT
THANK FONG. ALL THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE FORTY SEVEN. ONE
FORTY SEVEN ARE YOU ON MUTE- YES
IS THAT I'M TAKING THE PAPER
AFFECT NINETEEN EIGHTY OKAY AND
RENEWAL AND THE PROVIDER IS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH COUNTY AND
DRIVING ON THE BORDER DIRECTORS
FAMILY AND ASK ME OKAY THANK
THANK YOU ONGOING SUPPORT. HI
THANK WE ARE TAKING A POSITION
WHERE. RIGHT NOW SO- IF YOU-
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT A LETTER TO OUR
COMMITTEE- WE ARE TAKING
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AT THIS
TIME. BOB. THANK YOU OF THE LINE
TWO THIRTEEN. NEAR ME WERE MERIT
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
FUNDING SOME SCHOOL IN THE
RESPECT WE HAVE THOSE KIND THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. MIME FORTY
ONE. A NUMBER OF NEEDED SO
IMPOSSIBLE THAT THE
FUNDAMENTALIST MOVEMENT AND WHEN
THE LITTLE CYCLISTS WON'T GO AYE
IT HE WILL SAY IS THAT SPECIAL
RECOUP ENOUGH FOR ME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ACTS OF THE LATE. MONEY
THAT. I MEAN I. MONEY THAT IS
PART OF WE'RE NOT AT YEAH PRICES
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT. THANKS WE
ARE BUYING TO- TO. WALKING IN
THE MIDDLE OF GERMANY THE PHONE
COME UP WITH WITH THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE CALLING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS FALLS WORSE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CONCERNS
POSITION. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. ALL SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
BORROWED OF YOUNG GIRLS SANTA
CLAUS IS GOING TO RESIDENTS OF
CONSUMER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOTE THANKS THANK YOU THANKS
WITNESS. BY ONE THIRTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. MEMBERS ENJOY ACCESS
COMPLETELY ON BEHALF OF TOM YOU
KNOW FREEDOM ALL AND PROJECT
MEDIA AND STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THAT AFTERNOON ON TWO THOUSAND
HAPPENED THAT THAT YOU
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN IN BETWEEN
POSITION AND LOOK FOR GENUINE
DEPARTMENT DOCTORS MINISTRATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. FIVE ONE FOURTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. BY ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KAMALA SHANKS BURKE COULD
SPEND PART OF PRESSURES GOING
TOMORROW NIGHT NEXT WITNESSES OF
THE- NEXT WITNESS. MODERATOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TO TEN
YOUR OPEN. LEGALTECH CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. IF ANY CARTER WITH
HELLBOY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. I TO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS. A POLITICAL GRANT
IT'S A PRETTY- IN L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENTS. IN OPPOSITION LOOK
FOR WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. BY TWO TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
PAUL BODEN WITH THE WESTERN
REGIONAL ADVOCACY PROJECT AND WE
ARE IN WRONG OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JOHN RATE PLAN
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH WE'RE IN
THE WRONG POSITION THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. I NEED TO MAKE IN
YOUR UP. DID YOU HEAR MANY
MISSOURI ALL OF THE INDIGO BASED
. I RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHAT SEVENTY THREE YEAR OPEN.
BUT I SHOT ONE SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT ALONG
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE OKAY. ONE
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE CAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY. BY
TWO TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO ALLANSON ROAD FAMILIES
THAT WOULD EVEN CONSIDER COULD
MENTALLY ILL I ONLY PUT THE
STILL AFFECTED. MY NUMBER WITH
PHONE THANK THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WHY DO TWENTY NINE YOUR
- AT THE PROJECTION FROM SAMPLES
. MUST HAVE AN ADULT WITH THE
FACT THAT THE FLOOR HERE OLD
SUPPORT THE BILL I WAS THE MIND
BUT NEVER CALLED ON. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AT THE
FINAL REMINDER AT BEST OF IN UP
TO SB ONE THREE THREE EIGHT
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO TWENTY EIGHT
HE SAW THAT. I PAYMENT ANDREA
CORRECT AND THE DIRECTOR OF
OPPORTUNITY WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
AND HAWAII. AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. BY ONE TWENTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. ONE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. VOLUNTEERING WITH THE
PROGRAMS. THAT THE ORGANIZATION. I DON'T WANT. OTHER MOTIVATION
FOR ALL OF THEM ONE I DON'T I-
VERY. ORDER YOU CAN GET FIVE
OKAY SIR THE ACQUISITION ALIGNED
ONE AGAIN. BY LAW CAN YOU ARE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ALONG THE
LINE ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY THIS IS THE ANDREA
WAGNER FROM THAT. CAMP FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE RUN ORGANIZATIONS
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. OBVIOUSLY CARE
WE ADJUSTED THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH NOW WILL BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- JEFF SESSIONS
EFFORTS THERE OKAY LOW SERA OKAY
CLOSER SEVERAL AMOUNT AND
INTEREST OKAY THANK YOU. HE I
THINK SO TO ALL FOR THE
INFORMATION ON BOTH SIDES I
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC IN A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND CERTAINLY ONE THAT WE'VE NOT
FIGURED OUT HOW TO NAVIGATE
WHICH IS WHY WE CONTINUE TO
BRING IDEAS FORWARD. YOU'RE
QUITE I HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE AT
KIND OF CHIME IN- SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I THINK MANY OF US UNDERSTAND IS
THAT THERE IS A HIGH NEEDED TO
ADDRESS- IN SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS BUT WE ALSO DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROGRAMS WE DON'T HAVE IT
BEING NOT HAVE ENOUGH- STAFF
MEMBERS WHETHER WE LOOK AT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR OR THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. LIST ONE OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT AS I HEAR THIS IS
THIS BILL COME FORWARD I'D LIKE
TO KNOW HOW WE WANT HOW WE PLAN
TO NAVIGATE THAT PARTICULAR
CHALLENGE THAT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH STAFF THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
YOU KNOW MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
NOT ENOUGH PROGRAMS NOT THAT YOU
KNOW ENOUGH OF THE VERY MUCH AND
WE'RE ADDING A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM TO THE LAST. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAVE ESPECIALLY FOR
THE COUNTIES IS THAT THEY WILL
AB THE BILL DO I BELIEVE THEY
WILL DO THIS AND I'M WORKING
AWAY BUT I'M THINKING WHAT ARE
THE TO PULL STEP OFF OF IN ORDER
. BOARD MEMBER MEAN JUST.
EIGHTEEN PRIESTS AND THE NUMBER
OF HEALTH ISSUES AMONGST OUR-
YOU KNOW UNDER EIGHTEEN THE
SUICIDE RATES OUR SCHOOLS ARE
ASKING FOR MORE I'M TRYING TO
GRAPPLE WITH ALL OF THIS AND
JUST WANTING TO KNOW HOW THIS IS
GOING TO PLAY IT. I DON'T THINK
IT'S GONNA PLAY OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RIGHT AND- SO I WILL
SAY THIS IS THIS IS NOT IN
ISOLATION THIS IS IN CONTEXT OF
ALL THE WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS AND THEN
YOU KNOW WE LAST YEAR WE- FUNDED
. TO BE ALL THE WASTE BUT A
PLATFORM TO BE ABLE TO DO IT-
MIDDLE HEALTH EVALUATION OF A
CHILD. ZERO THREE TWENTY SIX.
THE BEER. WHO THIS NOW WE'RE
FUNDING AT. POINTS BILL DOLLARS
A YEAR WHICH IS UP SEVENTY
PERCENT. FROM WHAT IT WAS JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO- WE INVESTED
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARSLAST
YEAR. ON HOMELESSNESS AND
HOUSING AND ANOTHER. TWO BILLION
THIS YEAR FOR BRIDGE HOUSING-
AND- IN THE ADMINISTRATION KNOWS
AND PLANS ARE. INCLUDING MORE
CAUGHT. AS IT'S GOING TO BE TO
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND HOUSING- IT
COMING UP IN THE MAY REVISE. I
SAW. ARE NOT. THESE ARE CLIENTS
ALREADY THEORETICALLY BEING
SERVED BY OUR COUNTIES ALREADY
BEING THEORETICALLY BEING SERVED
AND IS TECHNICALLY LIKE SAY.
MOSTLY WE'RE PUTTING THEM TO THE
FRONT OF THE LINE THESE ARE
FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T EVEN BEEN IN
LINE BECAUSE THERE'S STILL A
BUNCH MORE DIFFICULT TO SERVE
AND IT'S EASIER JUST TO LEAVE
THEM- I WOULD THERE'S A DOCTOR
HERE WITH HE'S GONNA TESTIFY
LATER BILL NYGREN ARTICLE BY
HER. EARLIER THIS WEEK SHIA
STREET MEDICINE DOCTOR ABOUT
GOING OUT AND SEEING PEOPLE OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN ALMOST
BEING ABLE TO PREDICT WHO'S
GOING TO DIE NEXT. AND CALLS A
DYING WITH YOUR RIGHTS ON YOU
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
TREAT YOU BUT WE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO WATCH YOU HAD TAKEN SOMETHING
TO COMPENSATE AND DIE ON THE
STREETS SO WE UNDERSTAND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THERE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BEING SERVED AND
BECAUSE IT'S LOCATED IN BECAUSE
IT TAKES MORE TIME THEY ARE NOT.
WE ARE WE THINK KNOWLEDGE AND IT
WILL BE A MORE HISTORIC AMOUNTS
OF MONEY COMING IN FOR OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE IT
LOOKS FULLY ACKNOWLEDGE IS A
HUGE ISSUE BUT I WILL ALSO SAY
JUST ON THE BURNOUT OUR STAFF
LEVEL IT'S SO HARD TO SEE.
ACTIVE SYSTEM. SO HARD TO SEE
PEOPLE YOU. HELP AND DESPERATELY
WANT TO. THAT CREATES BURNOUT AT
A HIGHER LEVEL THAN ANYTHING
ELSE IN BEING ABLE TO KEEP OUR
FOLKS. IN THE FIELD ENGAGED IN
DOING THIS KIND OF VERY
IMPORTANT WORK. WE HEARD TODAY
FROM OUR PUBLIC GUARDIANS. ABOUT
THEY ARE NOW THEIR CASELOADS ARE
HUGE AND WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE COMING TO
THEM MUCH LATER. MUCH MORE
ISSUES WITH WITH DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY FROM LIVING ON THE
STREETS. MUCH MORE ISSUES AND
MUCH MORE. IT FEEL PEOPLE WHICH
AGAIN CAUSES. BURNOUT TO OCCUR
AT HIGHER RATES- SO WE FULLY
INTEND TO CONTINUE TO FUND WE
HAVE SENT HISTORIC AMOUNTS DOWN
I UNDERSTAND. THE COUNTIES-
NERVOUSNESS IN RESERVATIONS
BECAUSE AGAIN THIS IS COMING
WITH A LOT OF- OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
THOSE TO THESE FOLKS WILL HAVE
TO BE. AND AGAIN I'LL SAY IT TOO
IN A COLLABORATIVE NON FORCED.
CONTINUOUS ENGAGEMENT KIND OF
WAY TO GET EVERYBODY TO CREATE
THIS PLAN TO GO FORWARD- SO I
CANNOT ANSWER EVERY SINGLE
QUESTION LIKE EXACTLY. BUT
THAT'S IN THE CONTEXT THAT THIS
PLAN COMES FORWARD IN AND AGAIN
WITH THE ECOLOGY MEANT. THAT
THERE WILL BE A PUBLIC DEFENDER
THERE WILL BE. A CASE MANAGER
THERE WILL BE THE SUPPORTER. BE
THE JUDGE AND THEN THE COURSES
THAT ARE ABLE TO BE PULLED. AND
AGAIN ALSO IN THE CONTEXT OF
CALAMP CAL AIM IS OCCURRING AT
THE SAME TIME ALSO WERE THE
PLANS WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
FUNNY. FUNDING TO PAY FOR
HOUSING AS WELL. THIRTY GO DID
YOU WANT TO ADD ANYTHING OR-
OKAY. WHAT WORKFORCE IN HOUSING
IN THE TO BE AT OFFICE. YES AND
THANK YOU FOR SAYING THAT
BECAUSE THE NEXT ONE WAS ON
HOUSING- IN ANYTHING. AS WELL
AS- YOU KNOW DOCTOR GALLEYS
EXPLAINED THAT. HE HEARD IT LOUD
AND CLEAR YESTERDAY- AND THAT IS
DEFINITELY A PIECE- THAT
ACTUALLY A THINKER COMMITTEE.
BROUGHT UP TO AS A AS A PIECE
THAT'S MISSING IN THIS AND
CERTAINLY ONE FOR ME RIGHT THERE
THE- THEY GO HAND IN HAND AND I
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
COUNTIES PROVIDE IT YOU KNOW.
THE DEAL A NUMBER OF SERVICES
AND WE'VE ESTABLISHED I THINK
SOME- HE YOU KNOW PROGRAMS- AT
THE CITY LEVELS THAT INCLUDE
HOUSING WITH SOME STATE FUNDING
AND THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS- IT
BUT I THINK ABOUT THE
COORDINATION AND WHAT'S IT'S
GOING TO MEAN WHEN- YOU YOU HAVE
TO HAVE BOTH I MEAN AND WE KNOW
THAT THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT-
AND WE WILL. ACTIVE PROGRAM SO
YOU KNOW THAT YOU WILL THINK
ABOUT HOUSING BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING IF YOU CAN COMMENT A
LITTLE BIT MORE MEAT ON THE
DIRECTION THAT YOU THINK. SO OR
THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT YOU
WILL BE ASKING AS THIS BILL GOES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IN RELATION TO COORDINATING
HOUSING AS- A COMBINATION- TO
THIS STRATEGY. OKAY I WOULD I
WOULD POINT TO. A THE WHAT I
WHAT I ALREADY WENT OVER WHAT WE
HAVE SENT DOWN AND I KNOW THERE
ARE- WE PERFORM THE THIRTEEN BIG
MAYORS. IF THEY WANT TO HAVE
DOUBLED I THINK YOU KNOW I THINK
OUR OUR BODIES CERTAINLY AGREES
WITH THAT- I THINK WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT KIND OF A- AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE WERE TALKING TO SEVEN TO
TWELVE THOUSAND. NOT ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE IS NOT TO BE ONE
SIZE SAW RIGHT THEY'RE NOT ALL
GOING TO GO TO A BED ED- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE SAID THE GOING TO
BE A LOCKED FACILITY KIND OF BY
DEFINITION IT WILL NOT. BE IN A
LOCKED FACILITY BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ON LPS AND NOT
GONNA BE IN THERE AND IT'S NOT
AN ACUTE SYSTEM WITH THE-
DEVELOPING IS A SEPARATE ON
RAMP. TO OUR SYSTEM THAT IS NOT
A CUTE BUT IS MORE COLLABORATIVE
. ALSO JUSTIN THAT. WE CAN'T
DECIDE WHAT KIND OF HOUSING
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE BECAUSE IT
COULD VERY. BUT ALSO IF JUST
LIKE. WITH CHILD WELFARE. IF
SOMEBODY IS IN A- SETTING WHERE
THERE'S MORE SUPPORT A FAMILY
MEMBER. IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
ALLOW THAT PERSON TO LIVE AT
HOME. OFTENTIMES FOLKS HAVE.
FAMILY STILL THAT THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY LIVE WITH. FAMILIES
HAVE HAD TO DRAW LINES WHEN
BEHAVIOR IS OUT OF CONTROL. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY SUPPORTER
RESOURCES. I THINK YOU HEARD
FROM A- LOT OF FAMILY MEMBERS
TODAY TO. WHO WOULD WELCOME
SOMETHING LIKE THIS. SO THEY
COULD THEN BRING THEIR ADULT
CHILD BACK HOME POTENTIALLY. OR
HAVE OTHER. SITUATIONS SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT THAT ONE SIZE DOES
NOT FIT ALL. BUT AGAIN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A- PRETTY SMALL. A
POPULATION OF PEOPLE. IN THE-
FORTY MILLION STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LET ME JUST. OF
RESPOND TO THE- HOUSING
QUESTION- ALL THOSE WHO WERE
ENGAGED WHETHER IT'S THOSE
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE OR THE ADMINISTRATION
OR THE AUTHORS AND MY GUESS IS
THE COMMITTEE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT HOUSING IS A KEY COMPONENT
IN STABILIZATION. AND THE CHAIR
AND I HAD A CONVERSATION EARLIER
TODAY ABOUT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
IN CONNECTION WITH CARE COURTS-
WE'RE WE'REINVESTING A LOT OF
MONEY IN HOUSING WHETHER THOSE
ARE IN CARE COURTS HAVE FIRST
PRIORITY OR HOW WE- NOPE IS
FOLKS WE PROVIDE ADEQUATE
SHELTER AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
IN TERMS OF THE CONTENT THAT
WILL DIE TEARS GONNA RAISE THIS
POINT JUST A MINUTE. WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN IF YOU'RE NOT
COOPERATING IN CARE COURT WHAT
IF YOU HAVE A LAPSE WHICH IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. BOB DOESN'T
MEAN YOU LOSE YOUR HOUSING THE
ANSWER TO THAT IS IF THERE'S A
LAPSE NOW- THERE HAS TO BE
SOMEONE THOUGH WHO MAKES
DECISIONS AND WE NEED TO SORT OF
DEFINE WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR
INTER MINUTE LAPSE. OR ATLEAST
GET SOME CLINIC. OR COME
GUIDELINES TO SOMEONE TO MAKE
THAT. THE PERSON MAY THE
DECISION IS THE JUDGE- BUT- WE
THIS THIS IS NOT A MEMBER BUT
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TODAY. BUT
IT IS AN AMENDMENT THAT WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH AND RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND I THINK
THIS IS IT YOU KNOW I TAKE THIS
AS BEING ONE OF THE FIRST A-
POLICY COMMITTEES THAT IT'S
GOING THROUGH AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF TALK I THINK IN BOTH
HOUSES AND MEMBERS FORMALLY AND
INFORMALLY I MEAN THIS IS BEEN.
THERE'S BEEN CHATTER ABOUT THIS
IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY UP BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND THE IN TREMENDOUS
NEED. TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
CALIFORNIANS TO FOLKS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO NEED THE MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT BUT IT'S NOT LOST
ON ME THAT THIS CAN BE
COMPLICATED IS NOT LOST ON ME.
THAT AT. THIS MODEL MAY NOT WORK
FOR ALL AND THAT SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT ARE COMING BUT OUR
MAIN CONCERNS OF HOW WE'RE GOING
MAKE THIS WORK UP.
YES I KNOW YOU KNOW OTHER
COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING US TO HAVE A
LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THIS. I THINK VERY IMPORTANT AND
NEEDED ISSUE. THANK YOU SIR
ALONE CERROS. THING WAS FOR SURE
YOU KNOW- GIVEN THE CRITICALITY
OF THE ISSUE INVOLVED HERE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO. TRIAL
THE TOOLS IN THE TOOL CHEST AND
IT CERTAINLY APPEARS TO ME THAT
THAT'S WHAT THE- CUT THE
GOVERNOR IN THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE DOING HERE AND I THINK OF.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE MINISTER.
BENDED FOR DOING SO OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S SOME ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE WORKED OUT ACROSS A WIDE
RANGE OF- OF AREAS- BUT- WE'VE
ALL HEARD FROM OUR COUNTIES BOTH
AS TO FUNDING AND OTHER ISSUES
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO. DEPEND
ON THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
INDICATED THAT IT INTENDS TO.
PURSUE APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR
THIS PROGRAM AND IT IS VERY IS
OF VERY SERIOUS- BUT OF COURSE
WE HAVE A PART IN THAT TOO HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE SO. WE'RE NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING THIS PROPOSED WE NEED TO
ENGAGE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE GOVERNOR. TO PURSUE THAT
AND I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT. AFTER
BUDGET CHAIR IN THOSE OF. YOU
WHO ARE BUDGET SUB CHEERS WILL
WILL PURSUE THAT- YOU KNOW AS
NECESSARY THE ONE OTHER AREA
THAT COUNTIES AT LEAST THE
COUNTY THAT. THAT I WORK IN- IS
RAISED IS IN THE AREA OF
SANCTIONS- OF COURSE. THIS
PROGRAM AS HA BEEN INDICATED
DEPENDS ON THE ON ADEQUATE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE AND OTHER
AREAS AND ALSO STAFFING. SO WHEN
I LOOK AT THE SANCTION PROVISION
OF THE BILL AND IT SAYS. YOU
KNOW IF AT ANY TIME DURING THE
PROCEEDINGS THE COURT FINDS A
COUNTY IS NOT COMPLYING WITH
COURT ORDERS THE CULPRIT MAY.
FIND COUNTY UP TO ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY FROM NINE. THE
QUESTION THIS. THAT GIVES SOME
OF THE ISSUE FUNDING AND
STAFFING OR MAYBE OUTSIDE THE
CONTROL OF THE COUNTY SHOULD WE
NOT CONDITIONED THE AVAILABILITY
OF SANCTIONS ON THE ADEQUACY OF
STATE FUNDING AND STAFFING
SUPPORT OR IN THE ALTERNATIVE
SHOULDN'T WE CONDITION THE
AVAILABILITY OF SANCTIONS. A
SHIP OF INTENT INTENTIONAL NOT
PLANTS. WITH THE PROGRAM. JUST
COULD. ARREST ARTICULATED TAKEN
. BUT LET ME IF IT WORK TOGETHER
COME ON UP IT IS REALLY THE
QUESTIONS ARE ANSWERED- OKAY BUT
BUT ONE OF THE RULES OF THE
JUDGE IS ALSO TO USE DISCRETION
HERE AND YOUR POINT CENTER ROTH
ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE OF THE
UNAVAILABILITY OF SOME RESOURCE
THAT YOU CAN'T BASICALLY. GET
BLOOD OUT OF A STONE THAT THE
POINT IS WELL TAKEN UP IN WE
HAVE TO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES SO
THAT IT SAY- FULLISH ANNALYNNE
DISCRETIONARY ACT ON THE PART OF
THE COUNTY NOT TO PROVIDE IN
ORDER TO BE ORDERED TO DO SELF
AND I'LL LET DOCTOR GET RESPOND
PRESS SECRETARY ALEX YEAH. TO
ROB. THE QUESTION DEEPLY BECAUSE
THE LIGHT IT'S BE SPOKEN BIT
ABOUT YESTERDAY BUT NOT MUCH TO
. WHICH IS THE CARE COURT MODEL
IS A ABOUT A- ON TO SIDES. WE
FOCUS ON THE ACCOUNTABILITY ON
THE CLIENT BUT AN IMPORTANT PART
OF CARE CORD IS THE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON GOVERNMENT. TO
DELIVER FOR SOME OF THE SICKEST
CALIFORNIANS. SENATOR I MEAN YOU
MENTIONED SO. END OF IT. THE
PARTICIPANTS GIVEN THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT. GIVEN THE RESOURCES
WE BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES CALIFORNIA CITIES.
CALIFORNIANS ARE THE ENTITIES
WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
SERVE. SOME OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS CAN COME
TOGETHER TO DELIVER ON ALL
COMPONENTS OF A CARE CORE PLAN.
YES I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
MIGHT BE SHIFTING AND MOVEMENT
OF STAFF TO MAKE SURE WE DELIVER
THOSE SERVICES. BUT AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE MAKING SURE
THIS POPULATION MOVES TOWARDS
THE FRONT OF MIND TO GET THEIR
SERVICES IS AN IMPORTANT VALUE.
SUPPORTIVE CARE COURT I WONDERED
IF WE COME TOGETHER CAN BE DONE
SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SANCTIONS
AGREE WITH SENATOR UMBERG THE
DISCRETION BUT THIS CONCEPT SAID
IF WE REALLY PUSH OURSELVES TO
SERVE THIS POPULATION WELL. WITH
THE COMPLETE PLAN THAT INCLUDES
THE TREATMENT SIDE IN THE HOUSE
INSIDE THAT INVOLVES NOT JUST
COUNTIES BUT CITIES AND OTHERS.
SO THE HOPE IT OF COURSE BUT
COMING TOGETHER PRIORITIZE AND
FOCUSING ON THIS POPULATION AS
CLEARLY AS INTENTIONALLY AS
POSSIBLE THE BILL SANCTIONS
WON'T EVER COME INTO PLAY AND
THAT PATTERNS OF CHALLENGES CAN
BE ADDRESSED OVER TIME TO MAKE
SURE THE RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE
WE KNOW THIS IS AN EASY. BUT
THIS IS NECESSARY AND THAT'S WHY
THIS IS YOU KNOW A DIFFICULT
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION BUT AN
IMPORTANT WELL YOU KNOW FOR
LAWYERS AND I KNOW THE ALTARS
WON'T. ACTUALLY OCCUR A LAWYER
WHICH I DON'T CLAIM TO BE. BUT
FOR LAWYERS THE TERM NON
COMPLIANCES ABSOLUTE. AND WHILE
THE COURT MAY HAVE DISCRETION I
THINK AS WE MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AND I PLAN TO SUPPORT
IT- WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE OF COUNTIES ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT THEN THERE'S
PROBABLY SOME REASON TO BE
CONCERNED. AND THERE PROBABLY
ARE WAYS TO BUILD OFF RAMPS AND
THE LANGUAGE OF TO BE TO FURTHER
DEFINE- CONDITION NON COMPLIANCE
SO THAT IT'S OBVIOUS IF THE
COURT IS FACED WITH A SITUATION
WHERE THE COURT IS EXERCISING
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE THE- THE
FOR THE AMOUNT OF THE FINE. THAT
THE COURT ALSO MUST TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION VARIOUS FACTORS
INCLUDING. AVAILABILITY OF
FUNDING SUPPORT FROM THE STATE-
AND STAFFING SUPPORT TO MAKE
THIS PROGRAM WORK THAT'S MY ONLY
COMMENT- SENATE ROTH IT'S COME
IT WILL TAKEN OF. THERE IS-
NEARLY. THE DISCRETION HAS TO BE
WHERE A ENTITY OF ITS OWN
VOLITION DECIDES NOT TO USE
RESOURCES THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
AVAILABLE- THERE ARE SOME
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES WE'LL VERY
FEW IN CALIFORNIA WHO WHO MAY
NOT BE COOPERATIVE IN MAINE MAKE
A DECISION NOT TO BE COOPERATIVE
THOSE OF THE ENTITIES THAT
UNFORTUNATELY MAY END UP FACING
SANCTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS MISTER. THANK YOU SERRA
CERTAINLY VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
PAM- I APOLOGIZE I HAD TO STEP
OUT TO GO TO THE STATE
ALLOCATION BOARD MEETING- CITED
MISSILES LITTLE BIT OF MONEY BUT
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS- ALREADY
THAT I FULLY SUPPORT THIS AND I
WILL BE VOTING I TODAY AND I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHORS AND TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. WERE GOING FORWARD WITH
THIS PLAN BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW ISN'T WORKING AND SO
WE DO HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ARE
THE QUESTIONS I HAD ON PAGE
TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS THERE
ARE- SIX POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS
THAT- IT ASKED HE AUTHORS TO
CONSIDER I'M NOT GONNA GO
THROUGH ALL SIX FROM TODAY BUT I
DO THINK THAT THEY ARE GOOD
SUGGESTIONS AND WE JUST ASK THAT
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THEM AS THE
BILL MOVES. HOW LONG DOES IT. TO
THE A COURT ORDERED PLAN I KNOW
IT TALKS ABOUT THE FOURTEEN DAYS
BUT WILL IT HAPPEN IN FOURTEEN
DAYS. AND THEN MY OTHER QUESTION
IS. WILL THE COURTS BE PREPARED
FOR THIS THAT'S THAT MIGHT BE AN
ONSLAUGHT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HOWEVER WELL I CAN START THE
LAST ONE FIRST LOCUSTS DOCTOR
DELHI TO- RESPOND- WILL THE
COURTS BE PREPARED WEL THAT'S
THIS IS A UNIQUE MODEL THAT
INVOLVES ALL THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT AND CERTAINLY
JUDICIAL COUNCIL I AM INFORMED
THE CHIEF JUSTICE IS FULLY AWARE
THAT THIS IS GOING TO CREATE-
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES FOR THE
COURTS CREATES A DIFFERENT
CHALLENGE AS WELL ONE OF THOSE
CHALLENGES IS TRAINING FOR THE
JUDGES BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
TYPICALLY WITHIN THE SKILL SET
UP A JUDGE TO BE ABLE TO. THE
SUIT IS THAT OUR HELP SIDE ALL
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE CIVIL
PROCEDURE AND SO THAT'S- IT HERE
IS THE RAINING IN IN THEIR A
COLLECTION OF BEST PRACTICES
AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO GATHER. ON THE DOCTOR
PRODUCTOR GALLAGHER OF THE LEAF
TECHREPUBLIC ALL STATER IS THE
QUESTIONS GET HARDER THAN HIS
FATHER REALLY EXPERTS. IT WAS SO
. BOB HAD THE INTENTION IS TO
REALLY TRY TO PUT TOGETHER THE
CARE PLAN IN FOURTEEN DAYS WE
KNOW THAT TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
YOU HEARD. A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TESTIMONY AROUND MAKING SURE
THAT IF. THE TREATMENT CAN BEGIN
EARLIER WE KNOW EVEN RECENT
EVIDENCE AS OF THIS MONTH AND-
THE LAST TWO MONTHS
DEMONSTRATING THAT THE SOONER
INDIVIDUALS CAN GET ON EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT THE MORE LIKELY THAT-
THE COURSE OF THE DISEASE IS
BETTER OVER TIME. AND UP- YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PARTS OF BEING CLIMB WITH
MEDICATIONS IS STARTING YOUR
MEDS AND TAKING THEM SO THOSE
THE THAT THAT'S AN ASPECT THAT.
THE HOPE IS OF COURSE. JEAN DE.
IT'S LIKE. AND IT'S MEANT TO BE
IN ORDER TO PUT SOMETHING
TOGETHER THAT MATTERS AND WORKS.
THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU DR KELLY
AND I JUST AGAIN WANT TO EXPRESS
MY GRATITUDE TO EVERYONE
INVOLVED THIS IS SUCH A BIG
ISSUE. AND WE'VE HEARD FROM SO
MANY PET PARENTS AND FAMILIES
OVER THE YEARS I'VE BEEN IN THE
SENATE- JUST ABOUT HOW HARD THIS
IS AND HOW PAINFUL IT IS. AND I
WOULD ALSO CAUTION AS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO NOT LET PERFECT GET
IN THE WAY OF GOOD. AND LET'S DO
SOMETHING GOOD FOR THE PATIENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LEYVA-
RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE- A CO
AUTHOR IS HERE- FOR THIS MEASURE
AND I. DON'T WANT TO RE ITERATE
WHAT EVERYONE SAID AND I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF OUR COUNTIES AND
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES HAVE
CONCERNED IN AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF CONCERNS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. WELL THIS
BILL TO MOVE AGAIN I KNOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED AS
WELL AS THE AUTHORS AND WORKING
ON THOSE LINGERING CONCERNS I
EAT CLEARLY THERE HAS BEEN
COMMITMENT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TO. YOU KNOW TO
TACKLE THE FUNDING ISSUE AND
WE'VE BEEN INVESTING A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE PASTURES THAT
PERTAINS TO HOMELESSNESS MENTAL
HEALTH IN FACT THE AUTHOR HAS A
PACKAGE OF A MENTAL HEALTH BILLS
IN AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE DEAL WITH THIS IS YOU
KNOW SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE
DEALS WITH YOU KNOW PERSON.
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE THAT HAVE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE OUT ON THE STREET OR
HAVE DIED ON THE STREET DUE TO
HOLD ISSUES AND THEY WERE NOT%
ABLE TO GET THEM HELP HIS BOSS
HAD A YOUNG LADY WHO BROKE DOWN
PROFESSIONAL U. S. C. WHO IS
SAYING THERE WAS JUST. TYPE GEN
I THINK THAT CREATE SOMETHING
THAT'S GONNA HOPE TO ALL THE
FAMILIES IS IN PART BUT WE
WANTED TO AND I DON'T HEAR
ANYONE SAYING THEY'RE NOT
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS IT
IS AN AGGRESSIVE APPROACH BUT AT
THIS POINT DOING NOTHING IS NOT
AN OPTION THE PROBLEM IS NOT
GETTING SOLVED OUR STREETS
CONTINUE TO GROW IN TERMS OF
KNOW AND AS THE TIME TO. AND SO
THEY ALSO VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH STATION AS WELL AS
THE AUTHORS AND I AM A CO
AUTHOR. AS WELL BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THIS IS A TIME THAT TIME IS
NOW AND MORE THAN EVER NOW THAT
WE HAVE A HEALTHY. RESERVE I
THINK THAT THE COMMITMENT IS
THERE TO GET THIS DONE TO FIND
WHAT WE NEED TO. INSIDE INSIDE
BRING ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
GATHER. HOW TO CREATE A PLAN
THAT'S EFFECTIVE AND I AM ALSO
VERY COMMITTED SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YES SIR
WITH MELENDEZ. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- SENATOR EGGMAN AND
CENTER AMBER GRAVES SO MANY
QUESTIONS- I WILL START WITH THE
SECOND PAGE OF THE BILL I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE IT THERE WITH
YOU KNOW OKAY- SO IT SAYS. HI
THE BILL WOULD. WELL I'M LOOKING
THE PART HERE IT SAYS IF THE
RESPONDENT IS ORDERED TO COMPLY
WITH THE ONE YEAR CARE PLAN BY
THE COURT IN SO. I HEARD YOUR
COMMENTS IN THE BEGINNING
TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM BUT THE BILL
TALKS ABOUT IT- ORDERED BY THE
COURT TO HOW DO YOU SQUARE THOSE
TWO THINGS TOGETHER THAT'S MY
FIRST QUESTION WOULD YOU. YOUR
DRAW STRAWS TO SEE WHO ANSWERS
IT- I'LL START ATDOCTOR DELHI-
CORRECT ME- BUT SO. WITH WITH
THEM AS AS YOU ALL PROBABLY KNOW
BETTER THAN NIGHT WHEN SOMEONE
HAS A- SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
SCHIZOPHRENIA IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT IT THAT. FROM THAT POINT
FORWARD THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS- IF SOMEONE FOR
EXAMPLE SAYS LISTEN HERE HERE'S
THE PLAN THAT I'M AGREEING TO
HERE'S- HERE'S WHAT. I WANT TO
HAVE HAPPEN WHILE IN THE CARE
COURT PROGRAM THEY CAN AGREE
AHEAD OF TIME. AND AT THAT POINT
IN TIME IT THEY HAVE A TREATMENT
PLAN AND THEY FILLIT OR THEY-
ALL PHILIP BUT BUT- YOU ARE
CONTINUALLY INCAPACITATED OF
DOCTOR GALLEY WELL IT'S JUST IT
SAYS IF THEY'RE ORDERED TO
COMPLY WITH IT SO RIGHT. NOT A
VOLUNTARY ONCE ONCE THEY'VE
AGREED THEN THAT IS THE GREED
UPON PLAN. I AM WHAT SECRETARY
ALSO THAT- YES THANK YOU BUT
HOLD ON ONE SECOND I JUST. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR IN THIS BECAUSE
YOU ARE SAYING AS LONG AS THEY
AGREED TO. ACCEPT THE PLAN. BUT
THE BILL SAYS. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO SPECIFY THE SCHEDULER
REVIEW HEARINGS REQUIRED IF THE
RESPONDENT IS ORDERED TO COMPLY
WITH THE WHEN YOUR CARE PLAN SO
THIS IS THEIR ORDER TO COMPLY
WITH THE PLAN YOU'RE AYING THEY
WOULD VOLUNTARILY COMPLY WITH
THE PLAN BUT- NO. WAY IS SO IF.
IF I AGREE THIS IS THE PLAN. YES
AND THEN I DON'T COMPLY WTH THE
PLAN AND THEN I'M ORDERED TO
COMPLY WITH THE PLAN THAT I'VE
ALREADY AGREED TO AT THE END AND
I HAVE THE CAPACITY DECIDE I'M
NOT GOING TO COMPLY THEN YOU CAN
FAULT ONE OUT OF COMPLIANCE OUT
OF THE PROGRAM OKAY- YOU'RE
SAYING THAT HE- FELT. I DON'T
SEE IT OUTLINES THE BILL WORD
SET. YOU ONLY IF YOU PREVIOUSLY
AGREED TO COMPLY WITH THE PLAN
IT DOESN'T OUTLINE THAT IN
SENTIMENT IS. A LEAD DOCTOR
GALLEY SORRY MORE COMPLETELY
EXPLAIN. SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION OF. THE THERE'S TWO
IMPORTANT PIECES HERE WHEN I'M
SORRY COULD YOU STEP JUST YOU'RE
VERY TALL BUT COULD YOU STEP
CLOSER AND MAKE IT WORK AND YOU
HEAR ME BETTER NOW. YES OKAY-
THERE IS REALLY TWO COMPONENT I
WANT EXPLAINED WHEN A REFERRAL
IS MADE. ONE OF THE FIRST AND-
THE POTENTIAL PARTICIPANT IS
DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR THE CARE
COURT PROCESS. ONE OF THE FIRST.
STAGES IS. WHAT WE ARE. PUT IN
THE IT'S MENTIONED IN THE
LEGISLATION AS THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THIS PERIOD OF SIXTY
DAYS. WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
WORKING WITH THE COUNTY CAN COME
TOGETHER AND CREATE A CENTRALLY
A CARE PLAN. THAT IT WOULD HAVE
ALL THE THREE COMPONENTS THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT THE CARE TEAM.
MEDICATIONS HOUSING AND THAT THE
COMING TOGETHER AND PUTTING THAT
PLAN IN PLACE- IN THOSE SIXTY
DAYS AND THEN HAVING IT BEGIN TO
BE IMPLEMENTED- IN A- IN A
REALLY VOLUNTARY WAY COUNTY
PROVIDES. SERVICES CLOSING
SOURCES COME TOGETHER IN THE
VARIOUS ENTITIES THAT HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES. BEYOND THE INDIVIDUAL
COMPLIES INCOMES TOGETHER AGREES
TO THE PLAN THE COURT
INVOLVEMENT OVER TIME WILL BE.
LAST AND THE SENSE OF AN ORDER.
MONITORING REALLY LOOKS VERY
DIFFERENTLY IF THERE ISN'T AN
ABILITY TO CREATE A
COMPREHENSIVE CARE PLAN IN THE
SIXTY DAYS. THE COURT WOULD COME
BACK. BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WAS THE- TO GETTING THAT CARE
PLAN TO. COMING APPROPRIATE AND
THEN- WHETHER IT'S ON THE SIDE
OF THE GOVERNMENT ENTITY THAT
NEEDS TO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
DIFFERENT SERVICE OR ON THIS
SIDE OF THE PARTICIPANT TO THEN
MONITOR THE INVOLVEMENT AND
ENGAGEMENT IN THAT PLANT SO IT
REALLY STARTS OUT THAT PER SIXTY
DAY SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT I LIKE
TO CALL IT ENDING. IS REALLY
MUCH. YES IN THE CARE COURT
PROCESS BUT IT STARTS OUT WITH
THIS PERIOD OF TIME WHERE
INDIVIDUALS CAN. REALLY FILL IN
AND BUILD THE PLAN THE OTHER
COMPONENT IN THE PLAN OR THE
WHOLE PROCESS THAT WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT TODAY IS THE ROLE
OF A SUPPORTER. BUT SUPPORTER IS
AN INDIVIDUAL ALONG WITH THE
FROM A LEGAL REPRESENTATION FOR
THE CLIENT THAT WILL WORK WITH
THE CLIENT. THE IDEA HERE IS WE
AREN'T WORKING NOT CONFINEMENT
WERE LOOKING A COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES WE'RE NOT LOOKING AT
ART SUBSTITUTE DECISION MAKING
WE'RE LOOKING AT A SUPPORT OF
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AND NOT
SUPPORTER WORKING WITH THE
CLIENT- WITH THE INDIVIDUAL. CAN
BRING THE WISHES THE INTENTIONS
THE DESIRES ENSURE THAT THE
HOUSING SOLUTION THAT IS
PROPOSED ONE THAT. NEEDED IN. AN
OVERTIME TAKES THAT INTO ACCOUNT
THAT HAS AN INDIVIDUAL
POTENTIALLY STABILIZERS ON
MEDICATIONS IN THE COMMUNITY THE
COMPONENTS OF THE CARE PLAN
WOULD CHANGE OVER THE COURSE OF
THE YEAR. BUT THE IDEA IS THAT
IN THAT FIRST YEAR. THE
PARTICIPANTS WOULD THREE. CORE
MONITORING WOULD ENSURE FULL
DENTAL CARE PLAN IS DELIVERED TO
THE INDIVIDUAL. I HOPE THAT
HELPS. TO THE QUESTION. WELL I
SEE SIXTY DAY REF IN HERE THE
SIXTY DAY STATUS CONFERENCE
SHALL BE FOLLOWED BY REGULAR
STATUS COMES IS SET BY THE COURT
AT LEAST A HUNDRED. EVERYONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS- THAT IS.
FOR A COURT APPROVAL AND THE
CARE PLAN BUT IT DOESN'T QUITE
ANSWER MY QUESTION ABOUT THE
VOLUNTARY OR INVOLUNTARY NATURE
OF THIS PLAN AND- I DON'T KNOW
WHO CAN ANSWER THAT BUT IT JUST
I'M NOT SEEING ANYWHERE IN THIS
BILL WHERE IT'S- NECESSARILY
VOLUNTARY- WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
WHAT YOU OUTLINED OF SOMEONE
SAYING OKAY YOU'RE RIGHT I NEED
SOME HELP AND I'M GONNA AGREE TO
THIS PLAN THEN I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING ABOUT IF THEY
RENEGE ON THAT BUT I'M TALKING
ABOUT. FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
AGREED TO A PLAN JUST WHAT ARE
THE PARAMETERS HERE AND RIGHT
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IT. SO- I THINK THE RIGHT WAY TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION IS THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT-
INTERESTED OR NOT COMING FORWARD
IN FONG WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
THE COURT ON THE PLAN- THEY
WOULD FALL OUT OF THE PROGRAM IN
THAT INDIVIDUAL HOPEFULLY WE
CONTINUE AT THE COUNTY LEVEL TO
WORK WITH THE INDIVIDUAL FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THERE'S SOME OTHER
OPTIONS BUT- YOU. WE ON THE SORT
OF NORMAL COURSE THAT WE SEE
TODAY SOME INDIVIDUALS MAY HAVE
BEEN RECENTLY UNDER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY HOLDS IN A HOSPITAL THERE
VULNERABLE TO GO BACK INTO THAT
PROCESS AND DONNA
CONSERVATORSHIP PATH WE KNOW
THAT MANY INDIVIDUALS END UP
ENCOUNTERING LAW ENFORCEMENT
MAYBE ARE CHARGED AND ARRESTED
PLACED IN COUNTY JAIL IF IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR OR A FELONY. MAYBE
IN TRIAL A DEFENDANT AND THAT
HAS ITS OWN PATH SO THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OTHER PATHS THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS VULNERABLE FOR THAT
CARE COURT THE PROCESS OF CARE
COURT- REALLY REMOVES THEM OUT
OF THOSE SITUATIONS. AND SO WILL
THE CONSEQUENCE OF NOT.
COMPLYING OR PARTICIPATING IN
THE CARE CORP PLANT IS THAT
THOSE EXISTING PATHWAYS THE
TOOLS THAT EXIST TODAY COULD
COME INTO PLAY DOWN THE ROAD FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL THE WHOLE IDEA OF
CARE CORD IS TRY TO. PROVIDE THE
PROGRAM A SYSTEM THAT OF US
GOING DOWN THOSE OTHER PATHWAYS
AND SO. IN THAT SENSE THE
INDIVIDUAL HAS THE FULL RIGHT TO
SAY NOT GOING TO COMPLY AND THEN
THE CONSEQUENCES COULD BE DOWN
THAT PATH SO OUR HOPE IS THAT.
ALLOWS IT SAID- MAYBE
STABILIZATION ON MEDICATIONS
WILL ALLOW IT THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL WILL GET THE FULL
PACKAGE OF SERVICES CAN BE ABLE
TO BE STABLY HOUSED AND
SUPPORTED IN THE COMMUNITY. OKAY
SO LET ME SEE IF I UNDERSTAND
THIS YOU HAVE. YOU'RE PROBABLY
GONNA HAVE SOMEBODY IN CUSTODY
RIGHT. SO NOT NECESSARILY THAT
THEY SHOULD BREAK BECAUSE I
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT GOES WITH
WHAT I HEAR YOU ASKING IS THAT
IT'S IT SAYS IT'S WILL BE A
COURT ORDER RIGHT AND SO THEN
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THAT MEANS
IT'SNOT VOLUNTARY. BUT DO YOU
SEE WHEN YOU'RE ALSO IN YOUR
READ THE BILL DO YOU SEE
ANYTHING IN THERE THAT SAYS THEN
THIS WILL HAPPEN TO YOU YEAH IF
THEY'RE IN ELIGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION I SEE THAT IN HERE
OKAY THAT MEANS AND THEN WAS DR
KELLY SAID THEN THEY WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE IT WAS TO. RIGHT
ANY THESE PEOPLE HAVE SUPPORTERS
WITH THEM. MANAGERS TRYING TO
HELP THEM. SEE IF THEY CAN MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. IF THEY CAN'T.
THEN THEY WOULD BE RIGHT THERE
THERE THERE THERE WILL BE NO
TIME WHERE SOMEBODY WILL SAY.
THE COURT IS NOW TAKING YOU
SOMEWHERE ELSE. RIGHT THE COURT
IS NOW SAYING THIS. BUT IF YOU
IF YOU REFUSE TO ENGAGE IN THE
TREATMENT THAT YOU'VE AGREED TO.
THE POTENTIALLY. YOU WOULD END
UP IN THE SYSTEM. THAT WE TALK
ABOUT. WHAT TIME OKAY. THIS BACK
TO THE PROBLEM THOUGH RIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO CAN'T. POSSIBLY KNOW WHAT'S
BEST FOR THEM THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
IN THE PREDICAMENT WE HAVE FIFTY
ONE FIFTY FIFTY TWO FIFTY AND
THE CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS.
OKAY BUT THAT'S THAT HASN'T
SOLVED THE PROBLEM UP TO THIS
POINT THAT'S WHY YOU'RE
INTRODUCING THIS BILL- SO YOU
HAVE PEOPLE WHO JUST CAN'T MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
OR WON'T- AND THEN THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT IF YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THEY CAN DENY THEY
CAN SAY NO I'M NOT INTERESTED.
CARE CORD THE CONSEQUENCE OF
THAT WOULD BE THAT THEY JUST END
UP RIGHT BACK IN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM AND THEN RIGHT BACK ON
THE STREET WHILE WHICH PUTS HIS
BACK TO BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE.
YOU'RE REALLY TRYING TO- ZONE IN
ON THE PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY.
VERY VULNERABLE AND JUST CANNOT.
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS RIGHT.
SO THAT THE STATE- SOMEONE WHO
IS IN A CUTE SORT OF. PSYCHOSES
WHO IS SOLUTION ON FOUND IN THE
MIDDLE STREET AND CAN'T MAKE A
DECISION THAT PERSON CAN'T MAKE
A DECISION TO ENGAGING CARE
COURT BUT THEY COULD BE ON A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD DURING
THAT PERIOD OF TIME IT COULD
STABILIZE SEVENTY TWO IS TOO
SHORT I THINK BUT FOR A LONGER
GOOD WHERE THEY'RE- STABILIZED
ONCE THEY'RE STABILIZED THEY CAN
START TO MAKE DECISIONS. BUT TO
YOUR POINT- WELL WAIT DOES THAT
I MEAN I'M SORRY DID YOU WHEN
PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO BE FOR
EXAMPLE PICKED OFF FROM
UNDERNEATH THE BRIDGE IN BASIL
PLACED IN THE CARE COURT WITHOUT
ANY KNOWLEDGE CONSENT OR
AWARENESS THERE OFF. I SUPPOSE I
SHOULD LET DR KELLY FURTHER
EXPLAINED BUT- I'M JUST THINKING
OF YOU KNOW THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
SEVERE MENTAL ISSUES ARE I MEAN.
THEY JUST MAGICALLY RECOVER
AFTER SEVENTY TWO HOURS PROBABLY
NINE THEY'VE BEEN ON THE STREETS
SO THEY DON'T THEY WERE GOING TO
GET HER PLANNED SO- SO FAR. NO
WE ARE. AND CAL. FIVE DEPENDING
ON HOW YOU. START YOUR YOU MIGHT
GO FROM. SEVEN TWO HOUR HOLD TO
A FOURTEEN DAY HOLD EVEN A
THIRTY DAY HOLD DOWN A TEMPORARY
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS TO
CONSERVATORSHIP THAT THE PATHWAY
THAT. LOT OF CLINICIANS AN ACUTE
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES MY MOVE A
PATIENT DOWN INVOLVING THE COURT
SYSTEM- NEARLY EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY IF NOT ENTIRELY EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY. THE IDEA HERE IS
SOME PEOPLE TO STABILIZE. IF
IT'S NOT SEVENTY TOWARDS
FOURTEEN DAYS MAYBE THEN THE
RELEASED AND RETURNED RIGHT TO
THE SITUATION THAT THEY WERE IN
BEFORE. ONE CONCEPT FOR CARE
COURT AND WE BELIEVE IT WILL BE
A COMMON REFERRAL PATTERN IS OUT
OF. THE SITUATION INTO VICTOR
COURT PROGRAM WHERE IN A MORE
STABILIZE PATIENT PERSON FIVE
CAN PARTICIPATE. MEET THE
SUPPORTER WORK WITH COUNCIL COME
TOGETHER BUILD THE PLAN THE CARE
PLAN ALL THE COMPONENTS WE
MENTIONED AND HOPEFULLY AVOID
GOING DOWN. THE CAREEN TOWARD.
MANY CLIENTS OF ARE EXPERIENCE
SO- YOU KNOW THAT IS ONE ONE
CONCEPT THAT WE THINK IS A
VIABLE PATHWAY FOR THE CARE COR
PROGRAM AND I THINK DEMONSTRATES
HOW WE'RE MOVING YOU OUT OF THE
SYSTEM THAT IS OFTEN ENTIRELY
INVOLUNTARY WHERE DECISION
MAKING IS SUBSTITUTED FOR
CONFINEMENT I OFTEN THE-
FINANCIAL SIDE OF PLACEMENTS
INTO ONE THAT IS DEEPLY
COMMUNITY BASED WORKS TO REALLY
BRING THE DESIRES AND WISHES AS
MUCH AS THOSE CAN BE CLEANED AND
EVOLVED OVER TIME OF THE
PARTICIPANTS INTO THE PLAN. AND
FOCUS IS ON HOUSING- THERE'S A
CORE PILLAR TENANT AND I WILL
JUST LIFT UP ONE CONCEPT THAT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S
ABSOLUTELY SORT OF THE ONE TWO
PUNCH OF TREATMENT AND HOUSING
YOU CAN'T DO ONE WITHOUT THE
OTHER AND I THINK THE CARE
COURT- FRAMEWORK REALLY PUSHES
THAT FORWARD. SUCCESSFULLY OKAY
IT'S. SO FIND I'M NOT GOING AND
KEEP GOING BACK TO THIS I THINK
THERE'S SOME. I'M NOT QUITE SURE
I'M COMPLETELY CLEAR ON IT BUT
YOU DID AN EXCELLENT JOB OF
TRYING TO MAKE IT CLEAR SAID
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANT TO
SHIFT NOW TO- WHO'S GOING TO
EVALUATE. THIS PROGRAM AND THEN
THE GUARANTEE OF WELL I'VE GOT
THREE THINGS HE'S GOING TO
EVALUATE THE PROGRAM. NEW ANY OF
CARE SOMEONE ACTUALLY GRADUATES
FROM THIS PROGRAM BECAUSE I SEE
I GUESS I SHOULD GET BACK TO I
SEE THE BILL THAT IT SAYS THE
CARE COURT- IT'S- A TWELVE MONTH
PROGRAM. GUESS ADDITIONALLY
INITIALLY AND THEY CAN BE
EXTENDED A YEAR CORRECT OKAY N.
PRESUMABLY THE- PERSON WOULD
HAVE TO AGREE TO CONTINUE FOR
YEAR YES OKAY- AND THEY COULDN'T
BE FORCED TO DO IT FOR TWO YEARS
CORRECT OKAY MAKING SURE- SO.
THE CONTINUITY CARE ONCE THEY
GRADUATE- AND WHILE ALL INTEREST
AT FIRST SO. HE WANTS TACKLE IT
SERVICE- SURE I WILL. YOU KNOW
THE CONTINUITY OF CARE- CONCEPT
IS ONE THAT I THINK IS A DEEP
PART OF NOT JUST CARE CORPORATE
. YOU KNOW CARE AT ALL MANY
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH CHALLENGES AND WE HOPE
AND EXPECT THAT BECAUSE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CARE CORE
PLAN THE IMPLEMENTATION OVERTIME
A YEAR MAYBE EVEN LONGER UP TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. AFTER THAT
PERIOD IN THE GRADUATION YOU
MENTIONED THE BILL TALKS ABOUT
DEAD THAT- CLINICAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CARE TEAM. SAID THE
HOUSING WOULD BE MAINTAINED
BEYOND THE CARE COURT PERIOD NOT
THAT SOMEONE GRADUATES AND GUESS
WHAT YOU LOSE YOUR STABLE
HOUSING PLACEMENT IN A COMMUNITY
THAT YOU'RE NOT CONNECTED TO THE
IDEA THAT IS THAT ALL OF THESE
COMPONENTS WILL. WILL CONTINUE
THE INDIVIDUAL WILL REMAIN
ELIGIBLE FOR- SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THE HOPE
EXPECTATION JUST LIKE WE DO WITH
CLINICAL MEDICINE FOR JUST ABOUT
ANY MEDICAL OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHRONIC CONDITION IS THAT THAT
CONTINUITY WILL BE EXPECTED THE
CLIENT OF COURSE CAN MAKE
CHANGES AFTER THE CARE PLAN
DECIDE I WANT PAYING. WHERE ARE
MY CARE GROUP FROM ONE CLINIC
ANOTHER. DOUBLE IN TWO TO AND SO
I IS THERE ANY. EXPE DATE IF YOU
WILL TO HOW LONG ONE COULD
CONTINUE TO GET SERVICES ONCE
THEY'VE GRADUATED THE PROGRAM
THOSE SERVICES TO INCLUDE- ALL
THE THINGS YOU LIST INCLUDE
HOUSING. HERE SO YOU KNOW THE
CONCEPT OF LONG TERM PERMANENT
HOUSING IT IS ONE THAT WE ASPIRE
TO AND BURKE I THINK THE HOUSING
FIRST MODEL THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS OP CONCEPT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING- WE
TALK ABOUT THE SUPPORT OF PART
OF THAT HOUSING BUT THE
PERMANENT PART IS SOMETHING THAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS SO
LONG AS- THE INDIVIDUAL AND IT
IS. VERY HARD TO THANK FOR SOME
QUALIFIES FOR CARE CORP WON'T
QUALIFY FOR SPECIALLY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR QUITE SOME
TIME EVEN POST GRADUATION THEY
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
SERVICES. YOU KNOW PAID FOR AND
SUPPORTED THROUGH MEDICARE ALL
THROUGH A LOT OF THE FUNDS THAT.
SO LONG AS THEY'RE ELIGIBLE THEY
CAN MEANS IN THOSE CONNECTIONS
AND RELATIONSHIPS OF THAT
ALREADY ESTABLISHED- INTO THE
FUTURE BUT IT'S INDEFINITE.
THAT'S SO LONG AS THEY QUALIFY
THEY CAN. AND IT'S AVAILABLE IT
IS YOU KNOW ITS ONGOING
CONTINUOUS WILL JUST LIKE
ANYBODY ANY CALIFORNIA SO FOR
EXAMPLE A VOUCHER IF YOU IF YOU
REMAIN POOR. THEN YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR CERTAIN- CERTAIN
SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE HEALTH
ISSUES IN YOUR MEDICAL ELIGIBLE
YOU REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR CERTAIN
HEALTH- SUPPORT SO WHAT WITH THE
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS BE FOR
SOMEONE TO CONTINUE AFTER
GRADUATION. TO RECEIVE- ALL OF
THE BENEFITS THAT ARE
ENCOMPASSED IN THIS BILL SO. SO
THE HOUSING COMPONENT RIGHT IF
THE PROGRAM IS THERE THE IN THE
SUPPORT IS THERE THE- CURRENT.
SITUATION MANY OF OUR COMPANIES
IS THAT INDIVIDUAL STAY IN THOSE
UNITS WE HOPE AND SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO MOVE ON
TO OTHER UNITS AND- MAYBE MOVE
BACK WITH FAMILY OR OTHER
SITUATIONS BUT SO LONG AS THAT'S
AN APPROPRIATE UNIT IN HOUSING
SITUATION. THE PLAN HOPE THEY
STAY THERE AS FAR AS MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY TO PSYCH SENATOR-
BURKE ARE REFERENCED IF THE
PERSON MEETS THOSE CRITERIA
THERE'S A LONG LIST OF PRICE.
OFFERS HEALTH SERVICES SAID SO
LONG AS THEY ARE MATT AGAIN IN
MY OPINION IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO. QUALIFY
FOR CANACCORD. S. FOR YOU AND
YEARS TO COME WOULD NOT BE
HEALTH SERVICES THAT THEY WOULD
THEN. HAVE ACCESS TO THE FULL
SUITE OF CLINICAL SERVICES
INCLUDING. MEDICATIONS AS
APPROPRIATE AS PART OF THAT
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH CARE
IT'S NOT I DON'T ENVISION MANY
CALIFORNIANS FAKING
SCHIZOPHRENIA TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF SENATE ON OREGON
LICENSE SUGGESTING THAT THEY
WOULD FACE SCHIZOPHRENIC I'M
TRYING TO GET TO THE HEART. OF
THIS BILL AND UNDERSTANDING HOW
THIS PROCESS IS GOING TO WORK-
SO. YOU WERE SAYING THAT- THOSE
WHO HAVE THESE TYPES OF MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS LIKELY IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE ARE GOING TO HAVE
THESE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES FOR
QUITE SOME TIME. ON THAT THEY
DON'T. THEY'RE NOT JUST GOING TO
GO AWAY AND THEY WOULD- BE
ELIGIBLE FOR- YOU KNOW THE
MEDICAL SERVICES OBVIOUSLY
HOUSING ANYTHING ELSE COMES
ALONG FOR. PRESUMABLY FOR. FAR
INTO THE FUTURE SO I JUST I'M
TRYING TO BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING HAS TO GO ALONG WITH
THIS AND IF WE ARE GOING TO-
MAKE THE PROMISE OF SUPPORTING.
THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE THEN. YOU
KNOW DO WE HAVE THE RESOURCES IN
PLACE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT LONG
TERM IT'S A GREAT WE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE PROGRAM
BUT WE HAVE SO MANY WHO ARE
ACTUALLY AREN'T. LEAVING THE
PROGRAM. CICERO I THINK THE BEST
AN ORIGINAL APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION IS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
. SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT SEVERE AND PERSISTENT
MENTAL ILLNESS THAT THERE IS A
CRYING NEED CITY TO MANY OF THE
DIAGNOSES THAT WERE TALKING.
THROUGH AND- YES THEY NEED.
DELETE EVALUATED CONFIRMED AND
THEY ARE BY CLINICIANS ON A VERY
REGULAR BASIS IN OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND PART
IN THOSE EVALUATIONS INDIVIDUALS
WILL CONTINUE TO EITHER MEET TO
WERE NOT MEET THE DIE-
DEFINITIONS AROUND SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND THEN
QUALIFY FOR THEM SO I DON'T WANT
TO SAY THAT. ONCE DIAGNOSED IT
IS IT POND. INDEFINITELY BUT
THROUGH THOSE EVALUATIONS COULD
TRAIN CLINICIANS IN TEAMS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WE EXPECT
AND HOPE TO THE CARE CORPS
PROGRAM WILL. REALLY UNDERSTAND
AND KNOW THE CLIENTS OF THE
WORKING WITH CAN MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS ON A CASE BY CASE
PROFESSIONALS OKAY THANK YOU DR
KELLY I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH- MY
FINAL QUESTION WOULD BE. THE
AUTHORS IS THE- ISSUE OF. YOU
KNOW THE LAST JUDGES AVAILABLE.
I KNOW MY COUNTY I MEAN WE'RE
SHORT I THINK PROBABLY FORTY
FIVE FIFTY JUDGES YOUR COMPANIES
MAY BE IN A SIMILAR SITUATION.
BUTTON YOU KNOW WE ARE HAPPENING
TO THEIR WORKLOAD THEY ALREADY
CAN'T GET EVERYTHING DONE AND WE
HAVE YOU DID WHAT JEFF THIS IS
BEING DELAYED YOU KNOW. SO NOW
IT IS FIT INTO THIS CURRENT
SITUATION THAT WE HAVE SO- WE
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT WAS
SENT TO ROTH. IS THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT CHALLENGES FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH ONE IS
CAPACITY- YES. THIS IS THANK.
WORKLOAD INCIDENT SOME AND SIR
JURORS. SO WE NEED INCREASED BUT
NOT JUST BECAUSE OF. BUT ALSO
THE SKILL SET OF JUDGES BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT-
NATURALLY COMES FROM LEGAL
TRAINING THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT NATURALLY COMES EVEN
NECESSARILY FROM LEGAL
EXPERIENCE. AND SO- HAVING
JUDGES ADEQUATELY TRAINED TO BE
ABLE TO. MONITOR THE SITUATION-
B. IN ESSENCE SUPERVISING THE
PLAN OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
SUPPORTER IS DOING HIS OR HER
JOB ADEQUATELY IS GOING TO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THAT'S PART OF THE PROJECT
THERE'S THERE ARE GOING TO BE.
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES THAT ARE
DEVOTED- WE'RE WORKING WITH
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ASSESS
EXACTLY WHAT THAT MEANS- BUT
BUT- I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTED DO SO WELL. I HAVE YOU
I MEAN. HAVE YOU WORKED THROUGH
WHAT EXACTLY THAT LOOKS LIKE
WHAT WHAT SPECIAL SKILLS THESE
JUDGES WOULD NEED AND THEN WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO COME FROM IS
THERE. EDITION ON TRAINING
THAT'S PROVIDED OR I MEAN. HOW'S
THIS GOING TO WORK IT UP. THE I
AM AWARE OF TRAINING MODULES
THAT AE AVAILABLE BUT TO THE
EXTENT THAT HAS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IS AN INDEPENDENT BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT- IF THEY AGREED
TO- THAT. THEY HAVE AGREED THAT.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THAT THE EXACT AMOUNT
AND THE EXACT TRAINING HAS NOT
BEEN- FLESHED OUT THIS POINT.
OKAY- BECAUSE AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE EXPECTING
RESULTS- YOU KNOW FROM. AT AND A
BOLD- POLICY LIKE THIS ONE. ON
THIS. I DON'T SEE IN HERE THIS
THE APPROPRIATE NOW THE
PREPARATIONS THIS WOULD GO INTO
EFFECT- WHEN IS THERE ANY
URGENCY ON THIS. IS NOT URGENCY
BUILD BUT- THE ADMINISTRATION-
AND WE ARE ANXIOUS TO GET THE
FRAMEWORK IN PLACES AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE- I THINK WE'RE LOOKING
FOR LEASE HAVING THE FRAMEWORK
IN PLACE BY JULY ONE. WHEN WOULD
YOU ANTICIPATE JUST A FIFTH THIS
FAR HAD IT WHEN WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS- HOLDING IS
READY TO ROLL. WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW START. PUTTING
PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM AND START
ASSESSING PERFORMANCE YES WELL
IN AND HAVING THE JUDGES IN
PLACE AND ALL THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS A PLACE AND- AND
THE- HOUSING IN PLACE. SO AT
THIS POINT I THINK THIS IS WHERE
THE CONVERSATION WITH THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THEIR ROLE
KEY. PRIORITY ROLE IS- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY PART OF WHERE WE ARE
IN THE CONVERSATION SO HARD TO
ANSWER SPECIFICALLY BUT I AGREE
WITH SENATOR UMBERG THAT. THE
GOAL IS TO REALLY SIT DOWN WITH
ALL THE PARTIES WHO ARE INVOLVED
DETERMINED. NOT TO STOP WHAT IS
NEEDED BUT REALLY HOW QUICKLY WE
CAN PUT IT INTO PLACE SO THAT WE
CAN START- YOU KNOW HAVING IT
AVAILABLE AS A TOOL IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO WOULD YOU GUESS.
ESTIMATE THAT IT WOULD BE A YEAR
FROM NOW OR SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
AND A HALF I MEAN BEST GAS. WELL
I A LAST DOCTOR GALLEY BUT I
BELIEVE THAT THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE LIKED THE FRAMEWORK IN PLACE
BY JULY ONE RIGHT NOW I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE WHOLE. THANK
DON'T HAVE A DATE YET YEAH OKAY
BUT IN AND NO OKAY HARD TO GUESS
I DON'T WANT TO ASK YOU TO GO
GAS AND BRING THAT I JUST
THOUGHT YOU MIGHT HAVE
CONTEMPLATED THAT. OKAY- WELL
OUR YOU KNOW KUDOS TO YOU FOR
TACKLING A VERY DIFFICULT- ISSUE
THAT HAS PLAGUED CALIFORNIA FOR
QUITE SOME TIME AND IT'S ONLY
GOTTEN WORSE OVER THE YEARS- I
WILL BE PERFECTLY CANDID WITH
YOU AND TELL YOU THAT I HAVE A
GREAT NUMBER OF CONCERNS WITH
THE THINGS THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
WORKED OUT YET- I. EXPECT YOU
WILL BE WORKING ON THOSE ALONG
THE WAY AND PRIVATE MAIL
PARTNERING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BUT AS OF TODAY
THOUGH I AM NOT OPPOSED TO WHAT
YOU ARE. PRESENTING I AM NOT
COMFORTABLE. VOTING FOR WHAT'S
IN PRINT RIGHT NOW BUT I WANT TO
CONTINUE ON THE DISCUSSION
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE ON
THE RIGHT PATH THANK YOU. OKAY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. OKAY SAYING ON HIS IT'S
NOT A TURNOUT- SO AGAIN I THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- THE QUICKLY THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERNS WE HEARD
EXPRESSED BY THE OPPOSITION- ONE
OF. I GUESS ONE OF THE CONCERNS
OF THE HOUSING AND- I KNOW-
BURCU AND I'D HAD A- CHANCE TO
TALK AGENTS TOXIC RIGALI.
SACRAMENTO COLLEGE I SAID NOT A
CHANCE TO CHAT WITH YOU ABOUT
IT. IN THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
. BUT I HOPE TO ALSO EXPLORE
THAT WITH YOU. SO WHAT THINGS WE
HAVE NOT WE'RE NOT DOING TODAY
IS THAT- ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW I'M
BY MY STAFF HAVE. WORKED ON SOME
IDEAS FOR AMENDMENTS WE'VE NOT
ACTUALLY TAKING A MOMENT STATE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT- TRY TO FIGURE
OUT LANGUAGE FOR SOME OF THOSE
THINGS THE PRICE NEEDS MORE WORK
SO- SO WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK OUR
GUESTS IS BABYSIT MORE OF A SET
OF COMMITMENTS TO WORK ON. ON
THESE ISSUES. SINCE WHEN ASKING
FOR SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS TODAY.
SO WHAT ON THE HOUSING HOUSING
AND- IS THAT- I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS WERE
LOOKING AT- BUT- AND I THINK
WE'VE HEARD THE TESTIMONY. ON
BOTH ACTUALLY FROM. BOTH THE
OPPOSITION BUT ALSO FROM THE
PROPONENTS THOUSAND SEPARATE
GOLLY THE PORTENTS OF HOUSING
RIGHT IF SOMEONE'S GOING THROUGH
THE CHEMICAL PROCESS AND
THERE'S- NO HOUSING IS CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO DELIVER TO
VARIOUS SERVICES- AND THE
PLANET. FOR THE ACTOR. FIREMEN'S
AND BILL IN THE MAIL FOR THE
CARE COURT ACTUALLY HAVE A
HOUSING PLAN. RIGHT THERE'S NOT
A REQUIREMENT TO ORDER TO
HOUSING BUT YOU HAVE TO HOUSING
PLAN- SO. THE WAY THINGS- I
WOULDLIKE TO SEE. PLAYER FUTURE
AERATION THE BILL BEFORE IT HITS
THE FLOOR- CONCEPTUALLY IS THAT
THEN- THAT SOMEONE WHO'S IN CARE
COURT WHICH WE SERVE THE FIND
THIS YOU KNOW THAT THE PERSON
LIKE RIGHT AT THE- PERFECTLY AT
THE BREAK A GOOD SERVICE. RIGHT
I MEAN IT'S IT YOU HAVE TO BE.
UP IN A- JOHN SITUATION THAT AT
LEAST AT THAT HAVE- I WOULD SAY
FIRST PRIORITY ON ANY HOUSING
CONSISTENT WITH THE HOUSING PLAN
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW FOURTH WE
CAN'T PREDICT EXACTLY WHAT THAT
IS- BUT- YOU KNOW IS IT WORKING
OUT THE CARE COURT PLAN. THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE OF. SOME SORT OF
YEAH WELL I'LL SAY FIRST
PRIORITY RIGHT- IF THEY'LL MAYBE
AT THE VERY TIME THAT WORD
THERE'S NO OF DEMAND BUT- MAY
SHOW UP THE NEXT DAY. AND MAY BE
THERE THAT DAY THAT CENTER- THAT
WE TALK THAT IN FACT I THINK
SECTOR GOLLY TALKED ABOUT. AND
HE TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW.
THEY'RE NOT IN THE LINE WELL
LET'S PUT IT AT THE FRONT OF THE
LINE WHEN IT COMES TO THE
HOUSING PART BECAUSE ALL THE
OTHER PARTS ARE GONNA REALLY
WORK THAT WELL. ABOUT IT. THEN I
WOULD SAY IS THAT AT LEAST WHILE
THEY'RE UNDER THE CARE COURT
PLAN HOWEVER LONG IT ISN'T- AND
ASSUME YOU KNOW THEIR COPIES OF
THAT. THAT THEY ARE SURE
CONTINUED HOUSING SO THAT
DOESN'T S. IMMEDIATE SANDY SAXON
PLACE THAT WERE INITIALLY SIGNED
BUT- THEY CAN'T BE DESTRUCTION A
PLACE WITH ANOTHER PLACE TO GO
TO KNOWS YOU CAN'T JUST THIS
CHARGE AND ON TO THE STREET. NOW
OF COURSE THEY'LL COOPERATE AND
OTHER THINGS THEY FALL OUT
ALREADY IN THE CONSERVATORSHIP.
ALL THE BUT AT LEAST WHILE
THEY'RE- IN THE PLAN. SO I GUESS
I'D- ASK IS THAT. SOMETHING ELSE
AT THE LEASING CONCEPT IS THAT A
COMMITMENT YOU WILL NEED TO MAKE
AND MAYBE AUTHORS IT. IN
DIFFERENT DIRECTOR AND THE
HEARING ALSO DISSECT OLLIE IS
WELL THE. CEASES TO GET IT. WE
MAKE OKAY EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT AS
A- OLLIE. COMMENTS ON THE CON.
SORRY FOR THE RECORD YOU HAVE TO
BE AT THE OF. SUCH ARGUE FOR UP
IN IN A CA WE MAKE TO KEEP
WORKING THIS VERY ESSENTIAL
ABOUT OKAY ALL RIGHT AND MAYBE
IT'S JUST IF I DO HAVE YOU STILL
SORRY IN THE IT'S NOT. CITY TOO
MUCH IS A GOOD FOR ANYONE ANYWAY
WILL BE THE CITY A LONG TIME-
AND THEN THE OTHER THE OTHER
ISSUE THAT- ALSO. ENGINE IS THAT
- FEDERAL DO APPRECIATE SO. I
HAVE A I THINK I'VE EXPRESSED ON
SOME OCCASIONS THAT- YOU KNOW.
THE COURT IS NOT DESTROY THE
FRIENDLIEST PLACE IN THE WORLD.
BUT INSPECTOR GUY USE ONLY MAKE
THE CASE THAT UNFORTUNATELY IS
THIS ON FROM THE IS IT MAY BE.
AND OUR DESIRE THAT THAT'S NOT
THE NECESSARILY THE INITIAL
COUNTER YOU WANT IT CENTER OF
THAT UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT IS. BUT THAT
IT THE BILL SO IT'S NOT THAT
WE'RE SWAPPING OUT LOWER
GUIDANCE ON THE COURT. AND THEY
WOULD HAVE GONE TO COURT AND
FORTY DELIVER. COURT BEFORE SHE
MAY BE A CRIMINAL COURT THERE
ARE SOME OTHER TYPE OF COURSE
WHICH IS ACTUALLY AND PERHAPS
EVEN LESS FRIENDLY THAN
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. BEAT SO I GET
THAT- I AT IT IN TERMS OF THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. VALERIE'S
BECAUSE WHEN BEING THE WANT THEM
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE A PLAN.
EVEN IF THE FOR SHOW UP TO THE
COURT. I WANT TO THINGS I THINK
WE LOOKED AT WAS ABOUT. FINES
AND I HAD A DISCUSSION BIGELOW
TWELVE. I DO I READ. THAT. THANK
WE DID CRAFT THIS IDEAS SOME
THOUGHT CITY IN THE END THAT'S
AND POLICY ABOUT THE TRY ONE
PERHAPS LITTLE CLOSER TO SOME OF
THE THINGS ARE T. WHERE HAVE A
EVALUATE BEFORE I KNOW WE ALSO
TALK ABOUT WELL COULD BE THAT
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S FAIRLY.
YOU KNOW WHO WHO- THERE'S
CONCERNS BUT IT- BUT BEFORE THEY
EVEN GO THROUGH THE CARE COURT
PROCESS THAT PERHAPS WE SAY WELL
START THIS TREATMENT YOU'LL
FOLLOW UP WITH ME IT'S ADDRESS
AND WHAT TRIGGERS THE CARE COURT
IS THAT THEY DON'T START
TREATMENT ARE THEY DON'T DO THE
FOLLOW UP TO SEE HOW TO DO IT
AND THEN THE THIRTY CONVERSATION
FURTHER. AND THE END SO- BUT- OF
LITTLE CONCERN ABOUT THE- ADDING
IT TO IT BUT ALSO IF YOU'RE
YOU'RE SAYING SO I GUESS I'M
LOOKING ALSO FOR WORKING ON SOME
LANGUAGE TO SHORTEN THAT
TIMELINE RECOGNIZING THAT MAYBE
IT'S NOT SO MUCH A STRICT LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN SEEING AN EXCIMER
MONTH BUT THAT SO THAT THAT YOU
ARE IN. A ACTUATION WHERE YOU'RE
AT LEAST UNDER SOME ON GOING
DOWN THE WHAT'S CARE IS RIGHT
WORK IS CLEARLY DROPPING OFF AT
THE END BUT THAT THERE ARE BUT
THAT THERE ARE SOME. I'M GOING
FLAT OUT MONITORING- FOLLOW UP
TO THAT THAT'S- BUT THIS IS MORE
SEND ARE FILLED. ATTEMPT BY
FACEBOOK BUT- THAT. THAT THAT WE
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE
CARE FOR TO CARRY COURT WHEN THE
LAST TIME THEY ACTUALLY HAD.
BOTH THREE AGO. YES- IS AS WE
SPOKE BEFORE I THINK IT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
YOU WANT EVALUATIONS THAT ARE
ARMENIAN FULL YOU GUYS ARE UP TO
DATE WE UNDERSTAND THE RELAPSING
REMITTING NATURE ESPECIALLY WITH
THE TREATMENT OF THE CONDITIONS
THAT ARE FOCUSED ON FOR CARE
COURTS SO I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS I SAID- WE-
HAVE A NUMBER OF IN. WILL LIKELY
COME BE REFERRED TO CARE COURT
THROUGH SUN THESE YOU KNOW
SEVENTY TWO FOURTEEN DAY HOLD
PROCESS HE'S IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN JUST TO THE POINT TAT YOU
MADE ON. THE INVOLVEMENT OF
COURTS FIVE. WE LOOK- I KNOW THE
FELONY I S. T. DATA BETTER BUT I
USED TO KNOW THE MISDEMEANOR S.
T. DATA WHILE I WAS IN. HOW
BEFORE 47% OF THE WHO WORK. FOR
A ADOPTED DOWN IS TO CALL AND
CONFIRM AND BECOME FELONY ICE
TEA HAD NO CLINICAL SERVICES NOT
A SINGLE MEDICAL ENCOUNTER SIX
MONTHS BEFORE FOR THE SIX MONTHS
BEFORE THEIR ARREST SO THIS
NOTION THAT. SO MANY INDIVIDUALS
DIDN'T HAVE ANY ACCESS TO CARE
ISRAEL AND SO THE HOPE IS THAT
WE MAKE SURE INDIVIDUALS WHO
BEFORE THEY GO INTO THE CRIMINAL
COURT PROCESS HI THERE IS A
MISDEMEANOR OR A FELONY WE HAVE
A CHANCE TO CHANGE THE DATA
POINTS AND ENSURE SOME OF THE
MOST. VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS GET
THE CARE THEY NEED EARLIER
THANKS- ALL RIGHT AT A SEVE
MICHELLE COMPARES FETCHES AND
WAVING US THROUGH A LOT OF TIMES
I'M HERE FOR IF YOU LIKE I'LL
GIVE HER A CHANCE TO. GRAB
STRATEGIST SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT CAME UP HERE AND THEN I
MIGHT Q. DOCTORS ARE TECHNICALLY
TO RESPOND THANK YOU DR PAN AM
MICHELLE AND I WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOC GEN AND ON THAT POINT I
THINK IT DOES SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE OTHER ELEMENTS THAT I'VE
BEEN ANXIOUS TO SERVE TIME IN
ON- ONE OF THE THINGS I WANT TO
FLAG IS THAT. MUCH OF THE WORK
THAT WE DO AND TO BE HERE. NOT
UNDER MEDIC UNDER PRIVATE AND-
THERE WE NEED TO BE CHANGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL INCLUDING AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO ALLOW FOR US
TO REIMBURSE FOR THESE SERVICES
AND I THIN ONE OF THE BIG FAULT
LINES HERE IS THAT WE HAVE A
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WHO MANAGES INSURANCE.
MAY PULL INSURANCE CLAIMS NAY
SAY AHA. COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
NEGLIGENT THEY'VE DONE NOTHING
HERE. WHEN IN FACT WHAT HAPPENS
UNDER CARE COURT S. IS WITH THE
CASE TODAY IS THAT THE TIME THAT
WE SPEND OUT IN THE FIELD
WORKING TO ENGAGE SOMEBODY WILL
NEVER BE SEEN AS A MEDICAL
CLAIM. SO THERE WILL BE NO CHILL
THERE WILL BE NO EVIDENCE OF THE
WORK THAT HAPPENED THAT WE
LARGELY FUND THROUGH AN HSA
DOLLARS. THEY'RE ALSO HAS
SENATOR EGGMAN KNOWS. NOT WELL
ACCOUNTED FOR. AND SO WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE DEGREE
OF THE OUTREACH SERVICES THEY
WERE GONNA HAVE TO DO UNDER CARE
COURT BECAUSE NONE OF IT IS
COMPULSORY WE ARE LITERALLY
GOING TO HAVE TO GO. SEARCHING
FOR PEOPLE. AND THEN BEGGING FOR
THEM TO COME AND WORK WITH US
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GO
BEFORE A JUDGE. IS GOING TO HAVE
QUESTIONS AND WON'T UNDERSTAND
THE NUANCES OF INSURANCE
REIMBURSEMENT WHICH IS.
COMMITTEE IS IT COULD BE BETTER
UNDERSTOOD AND APPRECIATED HOW
MUCH OF THIS WORK IS ACTUALLY US
HAVING TO TRACK PEOPLE DOWN
DRIVE THEM TO COURT. AND ALL OF
THAT STUFF TIME WILL NOT BE
REIMBURSED UNDER MEDICARE. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT WITH THE
MONEY THAT WE HAVE TODAY WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO LEVERAGE MORE AND
MORE MONEY WITHIN MEDIC HOW TO
BRING IN FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION AND THAT IS OUR
LARGEST COST CENTER RIGHT NOW.
WE GET THE MOST MONEY FROM OUR
HELP REIMBURSEMENT SO- JUST
WANTED TO BE CLEAR ABOUT SOME OF
THOSE ELEMENTS ABOUT STAFFING
AND REIMBURSEMENT AND THERE'S NO
NEW MONEY BEING PUT ON THE TAPE
BURKE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL ZERO
DOLLARS. SO THAT IS IMPORTANT WE
THINK CAN AND HAVE NOTS AGAINST
TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT JUST TO
CLARIFY BECAUSE UNDER MEDICARE
HOW DID BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ACTUALLY RUNS A- CENTURY OF
BIAFRA HEALTH MANAGED. IN THE
ZONE TERMS OF SO IT'S NOT. I
MEAN YOU'RE YOU'RE DOING RISK
BASED RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT CAPITATED A RISK BASED
AT ALL WE'RE FEE FOR SERVICE AND
COST BASED WHICH MEANS EVERY
MINUTE OF OUR TIME HAS TO BE
DOCUMENTED. IN ORDER TO GET
REIMBURSED ON A FEE FOR SERVICE
RATES. SO NO THAT'S THE THING I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY REPURPOSE GRAYSON
CAPITATED MIGHT BE A DIFFERENT
STORY BUT IT'S NOT OKAY SO I
GUESS THE OTHER ISSUES THEN IS
THAT- I GUESS IS. STE SO HOW DO
YOU TRY TO CAPTURE SOME OF THOSE
CURRENT EXPENSES DETERMINED
OBVIOUSLY YOU SAY ME AND I GET
REIMBURSED FOR THE CLAIM DEALS
FASTEST INVISIBLE IT'S OFF BOOK
TO MEDICARE. WELL WHICH IS PART
OF THE PACKAGE. OKAY AND I GETS
OFF BOOK THE MEDIC COW BUT IT
BUT YOU'RE TRACKING THAT RIGHT.
WELL I MEAN WE HAVING WE HAVE.
CONTRACTS AND WE HAVE YOU KNOW
AT TIMES- SYSTEMS TO DOCUMENTED
BUT IF IT'S NOT IN INSURANCE IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY GET AN
OPTION OF THE CLAIM AT THE
CONTRACT AND SO. I THINK THAT
THAT IS PART OF THE ISSUE THAT
WE'RE STRUGGLING WITH IN THE
MECHANICAL WITH PRIVATE
INSURANCE. YEAH A LOT OF THIS
STUFF IT'S NOT GONNA BE PAID FOR
AND THERE WILL BE NO ABILITY TO.
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS
WE WERE PROPOSED. ACTUALLY TO.
PRIVATE INSURANCE SIDE OF THE-
NOTHING'S GONNA COVER ANYTHING
SIXTY GOLLY DID YOU WANT TO
PERHAPS RESPOND TO THIS ISSUE
BEING RAISED BY THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF THEIR SAYING LIKE OKAY
THIS IS A NEW BURDEN ON US IT'S
NOT GONNA BE REIMBURSABLE UNDER
MEDICARE WELL YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
WORKING WITH YOUNG STATE BUDGETS
AND SO FORTH- WHAT. WILL YEAH
THAT WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD SO TO
COMMENTS ONE ON THE- COMMERCIAL
OR THE PRIVATE YEAH I'D AGREE-
HAVE SHARED WITH- MICHELLE THE-
WILLINGNESS CERTAINLY TO LOOK AT
WHERE. THINGS NEED TO BE TIGHTER
IN LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
ON DO RESPONSIBILITY- IS ON THE
COUNTY IN THAT WAY THAT IS-
REIMBURSED IN TERMS OF. THE TIME
IT'S RIGHT I MEAN. YOU KNOW AS A
CLINICIAN I KNOW AS A CLINICIAN
THAT THERE ARE MANY THINGS WE
END UP DOING THAT DON'T FALL
INTO A CLAIM BRONZE ON THE
MEDICAL RECORD THAT WE TRIED DO-
TO HELP FACILITATE THINGS FOR
PATIENTS I DON'T WANT TO
DISAGREE IN ANY WAY. I'VE LIVED
IT MYSELF DOING THAT ENGAGEMENT
GOING DOWN- THROUGHOUT.
DIFFERENT PARTS FOR STATE TO
ALSO MEET INDIVIDUALS AND ON THE
ENGAGE IN PEACE THE- ATIONS. TO
A- CAN LOOK UP. WHAT SOME OF
THOSE OUTSIDE OF MEDICO- IT
MINISTRY TO FALL OR NON
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS LOOK
LIKE AND UNDERSTANDING WHERE- WE
TAKE THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE SUPPORT IS THERE
THAT DOES NOT THOUGH- IGNORE.
THE RESPONSIBILITY UNDER
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE CORE SERVICES THAT
INCLUDE SOME OF THAT ENGAGEMENT
WORK SOME OF THAT OUTREACH WORK-
ECCENTRICITY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ACCOUNT FOR BOTH
PIECES. AFFECTED AND SUPPORTED-
IN THE APPROPRIATE MANNER AS WE
LOOK AT THIS OVER THE WEEKS TO
COME OKAY SO SUCCESS I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS WOULD BE IN. SEE
WHAT. IT'S GOING TO BE
REIMBURSABLE UNDER MEDICARE I'LL
WHAT'S NOT OR WHAT'S GONNA BE
REIMBURSABLE WHAT'S NOT AND HOW
WE ADDRESS THE UNREIMBURSED PART
THAT WE MAY NOT BILL DROP DOWN
HEALTHCARE DOLLARS FOR RIGHT SO
WHETHER DEPRIVE INSURANCE
MEDICARE ALL OR WHATEVER OTHER
SOURCES. UNDER IT'S AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNDER YOU
KNOW DIRECTORS MEDIKAL THURSDAY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE RIGHT AND
UNDER THE HSR VARIOUS AND
WITHOUT GETTING TO ALL OF THE
COMPLEXITY IS WHICH I THINK MANY
OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS IN
COLLEAGUES UNDERSTAND BOTH
WITHIN GOVERNMENT AND OUTSIDE OF
GOVERNMENT BUT THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO LOOK AT THAT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE WERE
SUPPORTING THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD AFFECTED. OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO CERTAINLY OF INTEREST IN
SAYING THAT OF ALL- AND AGAIN I
THINK- AND I NOTICED- CENTER
LEYVA MENTIONED DEALS WE HAD IN
OUR POLICY COMMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS SOME HOPING THAT
THOSE CAN- THOSE WOULD BE
ADDRESSED IN THE FUTURE- AS.
WELL AND THE SYSTEM. AND THEN.
SO WE'VE HAD- WE TALKED ABOUT-
WILL BE ON THE- FINANCING END OF
THINGS- AND THEN- AND THEN SERVE
TIME LINES AS WELL AS WELL AND I
KNOW YOU YOU KNOW WHAT WE HAVE
TO CONVERSATION WORKING ON THE
ONE. LANGUAGE THE LANGUAGE THERE
AND THEN I GUESS FINALLY. AND I
DO APPRECIATE THE PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION ABOUT. THE
VOLUNTARINESS ARE LACK OF
VOLUNTARINESS AND I KNOW SOME
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED AND I
THINK SOME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY SOME OF THE ADVOCATES
ABOUT- NOW I THINK THERE. ARE
TIMES WHERE AND JOBS I SUPPORT
LAURA'S LAW AND STUFF- SO I KNOW
MAKES SOME PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH
THAT I THINK THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES- BUT ESPECIALLY.
BUT IT'S ALSO A LAST RESORT AND
I THINK IT I THINK EVERYONE
AGREES EVEN OF US ARE STILL-
JUST WANNA BE SURE WE HAVE
CLARITY IN THE LANGUAGE ABOUT.
WHATEVER WOULD TRIGGER ARE MAYBE
NOT IN THE CARE COURT GREAT LIFT
THE SITUATION BUT- AGAIN TO BE
SURE WE RESPECT THE AUTONOMY OF
PATIENTS AND ADULTS ONLY TRULY
A- LAST RESORT. WHERE THERE'D BE
CIRCUMSTANCE WHAT THEIR DAD LOOK
ACTUALLY. RECORDER.
FIVE MAKE DECISIONS WE JUST
DON'T AGREE WITH AND- YOU KNOW
AND SO FORTH AND WE HAVE TO
RESPECT THAT RIGHT. SO OKAY SO I
SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
I'D LIKE TO SEE IS THAT WITHIN
MY PROPOSED FORMAL AMENDMENTS-
THE SITE AFTER A CONVERSATION WE
HAD DRAFTED SUM UP BUT- OKAY
GIVE YOU SOMETIME TO WORK ON IT
SOME THE LANGUAGE ANYWAY BEEN
REALLY HARD TO WORK OUT. SO BUT
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS I'D
LIKE TO SEE MOVING FORWARD. AND
I'M HOPING THAT- YOU CAN
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT- THIS
IS. A SPORT. YES AT THE START.
RIGHT YEAH I FOLLOW UP WITH
DOCTOR GALLAGHER. DR AS WE HAVE
JUST IN THE PAST AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW MUCH BETTER THAN I. THE- I
MET BACK IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES RESULTED IN FUNDING
INEQUITY IN OUR COUNTIES NORTH
OF SELF SERVING COASTAL TO
INLAND. AND I'M CONCERNED A
LITTLE BIT I'M STILL SUPPORTING
THIS. BOTH FEET IN BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THE IT SOUNDS LIKE THE COUNTY'S
EFFORTS IN THE OBLIGATIONS OF
COUNTIES. WILL NOT LIKELY BE
REIMBURSED AT LEAST UNDER THE
CURRENT RULES. AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHERE THE COUNTIES GET THE
FUNDING. TO DO THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT ARE CONTEMPLATED BY
THE CARE ACT OBVIOUSLY VALUABLE
AND ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS THAT
NEED IT PERFORMED BUT OF COURSE.
SOMEBODY HAS TO FIND THE MONEY
TO COVER THE COSTS. IT IS AND I
KNOW WE'RE IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND WE'LL HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
IN A DIFFERENT FORM. BLOOD IT
WILL THE LIGHTS WHICH BRIEFLY
DONE ON THE CARE ACT. BEFORE WE
DETERMINE WHAT THE SOURCE OF THE
FUNDING WILL BE FOR COUNTIES
PARTICULARLY THOSE COUNTIES THAT
ARE UNDER RESOURCE NOW SOME OF
THEM MAY BE EXPERIENCING A
SURPLUS OF SOME SORT AND FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN YEARS BUT I'M SURE
THAT SURPLUS WON'T GO VERY FAR-
IF THERE'S NOT ANY ADDITIONAL
MONEY FLOWING. TO THEM. CAN YOU
. PROVIDE ANY- WARMTH TO ME ON
THAT SUBJECT I WILL TO DO MY
BEST TO ASSIST YOU AND I HAVE
ENGAGED ON THE SAME CONVERSATION
IN THE PAST THE FIRST THING TO
SAY IS THE COMMITMENT WE TALKED
ABOUT IT EARLIER ABOUT WHAT'S
BEING WORKED OUT IN TERMS OF
INVESTMENTS GO INTO SOME OF THE
NEW COMPONENTS OF THE CARE COURT
PLAN THE SUPPORTER ROLE AS AN
EXAMPLE IS SOMETHING THAT. WE'RE
WORKING ON EXACTLY WHAT THE
FUNDING THE MATTER THE MECHANISM
AND HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK BUT
THAT WILL BE AUGMENTED FATHER
AUGMENTATIONS ARE ALSO EXPECTED
WORKING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE
ARE COUNTY ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
MIGHT BE ON SOME OF THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
THAT MIGHT BE INVOLVED HERE BUT
I WILL UNDERSCORE I THINK THIS
WAS HIGHLIGHTED IN SENATOR
ADMINS COMMENTS THIS DOES NOT
ADDRESS THE REALIGNMENT IN
EQUITY THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING
HISTORIC OVERTIME I DON'T THINK
THAT I HAVE THE TOOLS TODAY TO
ADDRESS THAT FULLY FOR YOU BUT
THE IDEA THAT. THE RESOURCES IN
COUNTIES COULD BE AND MAYBE SOME
OF US BELIEVE SHOULD BE DEPLOYED
TO. WE ARE. EVEN FIRST A
PRIORITY I THINK IS PART OF WHAT
WE ARE FOCUSED ON AND SO- MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
COUNTIES BEING CLEAR. SAID THIS
IS A POPULATION OF PRIORITY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND ENSURING THAT
THOSE DOLLARS- EVEN THOUGH THEY
MAY NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO DO
EVERYTHING- THE HEAD THAT ARE.
BILL THAT COUNTY MADE. TO DO
FOUR FIVE EXPECT THEMSELVES TO
DO THIS IS A PRIORITY POPULATION
THAT THOSE DOLLARS SHOULD BE.
SUPPORTING AND THEN SIMILARLY
THE CONCEPT AROUND HOUSING TO
MAKE SURE THOSE INVEST SO WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT HAVE GONE INTO
THE STATE BUDGETS OVER THE LAST
TWO YEARS THAT ARE PROPOSED TO
AUGMENT. THIS YEAR ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN BEHAVIOR
HOPE BRIDGE HOUSING AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
REALLY TARGETING HOUSING
SOLUTIONS FOR EXACTLY BUT NOT.
ONLY FOR BUT INCLUDING THE CARE
COURT POPULATION THAT WE
ANTICIPATE BEING REFERRED WELL I
DIDN'T INTEND TO BEAT YOU UP ON
MENTAL HEALTH REALIGNMENT THAT'S
A PROBLEM THAT MAY EVEN BE. AT
LEAST. MODERN TIME BUT BUT IT
DOES HIGHLIGHT THE FACT THAT IN
SOME COUNTIES IN SOME REGIONS
THE- THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
AVAILABLE IS- REMAINS WILL FEEL
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO SERVICE
THE POPULATION GROWS SINCE WE
WERE DEALING WITH. MENTAL HEALTH
REALIGNMENT AND IT IT IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE SITUATION WHERE
SOME COUNTIES MAY NEED A LITTLE
HELP- TO DO THESE THINGS
ASSOCIATED WITH CARE COURT
BECAUSE THERE SIMPLY ISN'T
ENOUGH MONEY BETWEEN PROP SIXTY
THREE AND- MENTAL HEALTH
REALIGNMENT OF TO FUND WHAT. THE
CORE FUNCTION. NOW INCLUDING
CARE COURT AND I ASSUME WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS IS THE BUDGET
MOVES FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY WE
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY TO WORK. TO
MAKE TO GO TO PROVIDE THE
RESOURCES TO MAKE THIS THING
WORK THAT'S THAT'S MY ONLY
COMMENT PRESHEAF CHU TOLERATING
ME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. OKAY ANY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT SAYING NONE- JENS. THANK
YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION- HOPING
YOU CAN COMMENT ON THE
COMMITMENTS- AND YOUR CLOTHES-
CENTER- BERGEN EGGMAN WHICH I
LIKE TO CLOSE. I'M SURE. OF
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. A
COUPLE POINTS NUMBER ONE TODAY
IS DAY TWO OF LEGISLATIVE
JOURNEY AND THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS- WE WILL COMMIT TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE CHAIR AND THE
CONCERNS OF OTHERS. THE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE HAVE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT YESTERDAY
AND LET ME JUST. ADDRESS ONE
ASPECT IN ONE CONCERN AND THAT'S
THE CONCERN THAT THAT SOME MAY
HAVE. HAVING HAD. BAD
EXPERIENCES OR SCARY EXPERIENCES
IN THE COURTS I'VE BEEN IN COURT
MANY TIMES I'M STILL STILL
SCARED WHEN I COME TO COURT I.
OFTENTIMES SO I CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
NEED TO BE THAT WAY THERE ARE
COURTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
OPERATING TODAY WHERE THERE ARE
JUDGES WHO CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT
A VERY SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT
AND THAT'S THE VISION THAT'S
PART OF THE VISION OF THE CARE
COURTS IS THAT WE HAVE A SUPPORT
OF APART BUT WE- ALSO HAVE
ACCOUNTABILITY. SOMEBODY NEEDS
TO BE. UNDER THE- HM IS ACCOUNT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS GETTING THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY REQUIRE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE'VE HAD THROUGHOUT GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN IT IS MY HOPE
AND DESIRE THAT WE BUILD THAT
INTO THE SYSTEM SO THAT WE THE
BEST WE CAN POSSIBLY DO TO REACH
THE GOAL THAT YOU WANT IN THAT
WE WANT AND THAT ALL OF US WANT
IN TERMS OF STABILITY AND- A
RETURN TO- A SITUATION THAT IS
LIVABLE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE.
ILLNESS AND SO WITH THAT I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY JOINT AUTHORS
CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU AND I
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONVERSATION TO THE OPPOSITION
TO THE SUPPORTERS. INTEND TO THE
ENGAGEMENT- WE DO COMMIT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS IS IN
OUR WORKS IT IS OUR SECOND DAY
IN IN THE- IN COMMITTEES- AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS THAT THE GOAL IS A
COMPASSIONATE PLACE WE PROVIDE
CARE FOR THOSE MOST IN NEED.
THEY GIVE ALL SAID THE STATUS.
QUO IS NOT OKAY BUT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING IS NOT BEEN WORKING WE TO
TRY DIFFERENT- WE ARE WE ARE
FULL IN IN AND MAKING WORKING
RISK ASK FOR I. PHONE. THANK
THANK YOU I DON'T I'VE HAD
SECOND. ALL RIGHT SAID I THINK
CENTER GOT THERE FOR. SO SECOND
CENTER ROCK THAT. WE THAT FOR.
AGAIN I WANT THANKS A THREE
DOLLAR FOR BEING. AND TAKING
TIME AND QUESTIONS WELL. I CAN.
TO SO THE- IS PASS REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PROP. AND IT'S
BEEN SECOND SET. TO ROTH.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. CAN I CAN I MELINDA'S. EGGMAN
EGGMANAYE CAN SALAS. GROVE
FURTADO LEYVA LEYVA I LIMON
LIMON I ROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER
BY GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I. OKAY THE
BILL'S CURLY EIGHT ZERO HOLD THE
BILL- YOU REFER- ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANKS VERY
MUCH OKAY- NEXT ITEM IS ACTUALLY
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB FOURTEEN
FORTY SIX BY CENTER STERN
WELCOME AND BASS FISHING YOUR
PATIENTS. THAT OF ALTHOUGH I
THINK OUR DISCUSSION ON YOUR
BILL THAT WAS INPUT HOPEFULLY BE
INFORMED BY DISCUSSION WE JUST
HAD. AS WELL. I WAS GOING SAY I
MIGHT HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THE
COMMITTEE- BUT I DON'T MEAN TO
BE TOO PRESUMPTUOUS SO DOCTOR
PAN. CAN I PROCEED IS ENTERING
THIS QUICKLY YES THANK YOU. SOME
I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX AND I
APPRECIATE THE- LISTENING TO
THIS ROBUST CONVERSATION THAT
THE COMMITTEE JUST ENGAGED IN.
AND I SHARE. NUMBER THE CONCERNS
FROM FROM THE ADVOCATES AS WELL
AS FROM THE MEMBERS- WHEN YOU
GET INTO THE ISSUES THAT.
SURROUND SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
FOR SO MANY PEOPLE WHO FEEL LEFT
BEHIND. EVERY TIME THEY ENTER
THE SYSTEM. THEY'RE EITHER
TRAUMATIZING FORCED
HOSPITALIZATION OR THEY SPEND
SOME TIME IN THE CENTRAL JAIL OR
MAYBE GET SOME KIND OF TEMPORARY
HOUSING ARRANGEMENT BUT- THE
SOLUTIONS AT THIS POINT ARE NOT
PERMANENT. WHAT'S MISSING RIGHT
NOW IS AN ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THIS BILL IS
CONCEDED LEE ASPIRATIONAL AND-
HIGH LEVEL AND SCOPE. WE WOULD
ACTUALLY PUT FORWARD A RIGHT I%
GUARANTEE IN LAW TO THE PEOPLE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. TO
ANYBODY WHO'S NOT LIVING SAFELY
IN THE COMMUNITY THE RESULT OF
EITHER THEIR SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS OR OTHER ISSUES THEY'RE
FACING. THEY WOULD BE GUARANTEED
TREATMENT HOUSING. AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER. A LOT OF LONG LIST OF
ISSUES THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE
RESOLVED IN TERMS OF HOW THAT
RIGHT WOULD ACTUALLY BE
FULFILLED- HOW WOULD BE PAID FOR
. TALK ABOUT WHAT'S OFF BOOKS IN
ON THE BOOKS WHEN IT COMES TO
MEDICARE NOW. WE TALKED ABOUT
THE SPORADIC NATURE OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES- AND THE LACK OF
ONGOING FUNDING AT THE STATE
LEVEL. BUT THIS BILL WOULD SEEK
TO REMEDY. AT LEAST THE INTENT-
CAN I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS ENGAGEMENT ON THIS AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT. THIS BILL DOES
NOT HAVE THE LEVEL OF DETAIL
THAT. DO YOU REQUIRE FOR BILLS
THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE I MEAN.
YOU ALL THE HIGH STANDARD AND-
AND THERE'S A LOT OF WORK IN
PROGRESS OUT THERE. I WOULD
SUBMIT TO THE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THOUGH THAT. THAT
THIS WORK IN PROGRESS. IS
NECESSARY TO MOVE AS WERE HAVING
THESE OTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
CARE COURTS. OR THIS OTHER KIND
OF TREATMENT THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING. HI MY MINOR TO HAVE.
CENTER EGGMAN HAS BEEN FRANKLY
LEADING. THIS CONVERSATION AS AS
OUR PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR HERE AND
- THE BASIC PIECES OF THE BILL
IS THAT ONE TIMES NOT GOING TO
DO IT WHEN YOU HAVE TO TAKE CARE
OF SOMEBODY. FINANCIALLY FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIFE. AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE. DISABLED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DUE TO A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY HAVE
THAT GUARANTEED RIGHT. AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT. SOMEONE RECEIVED FOR
THEIR INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY PER BED
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH NINETY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
THE CURRENT BOARDING CARE
LEVELS- A SUBSTANTIALLY LESS
THAN THAT AND WE'RE THOUSANDS
THE BED SHORT. AND I THINK THIS
GOVERNOR'S BEEN BOLD IN THIS
WITH THIS ONE TIME FUNDING
PROPOSAL TO LOOK AT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND TO LOOK AT
INFRASTRUCTURE- BUT- WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. IS OFFER A
DIFFERENT WAY IN- NOT JUST
LOOKING AT THE TOOLS OF WHAT
CARE. WOULD DO- BUT IN CHANGING
THE UNDERLYING STRUCTURE AROUND
THE PROGRAM. NO I HAVE. IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS MISTER CHAIR- YOU
KNOW I OFFERED SOME SOME IDEAS
THAT SOUNDED LIKE MIGHT
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
MAYBE THE COMMITTEE OR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT.
LITIGATION RISK AROUND THIS
LEGISLATION IF YOU CAUGHT A FIRE
RIGHT IN LAW TO GUARANTEE
TREATMENT HOUSING. WITH EVERYONE
JUST START SUING EACH OTHER TO
LOCK IN THAT RIGHT. COULD THE
COUNTIES TO THE STATE. COULD
PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS TO COUNTIES-
YOU KNOW COULD INDIVIDUALS
THEMSELVES SEEK RECOURSE. I
DON'T WANT TO GO THERE YET WITH
THIS LEGISLATION SO YOU KNOW
WHAT IF THE BILL DOES MOVE FOR
TODAY I JUST WANT TO ASSURE
COMMITTEE THE CHAIR. THAT WE
WANT TO PRESCRIBE THIS
LEGISLATION WE WANT TO
COORDINATE OFTEN CONSTRAIN IT-
IN A WAY THAT. WOULD NOT GIVE
ANYONE A PUBLIC OR PRIVATE RIGHT
OF ACTION- WOULD NOT OFFER THAT
THAT ABILITY TO. TO SAY STALL
OUT OR DECIDE THROUGH THE COURT
SYSTEM AS OPPOSED TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS EXACTLY HOW- WE GET
TREATMENT AND HOUSING TO
EVERYBODY WHO NEEDS IT. BUT I DO
THINK THERE'S POWER IN CODIFYING
IN CALIFORNIA LAW THAT THIS
OUGHT TO BE A RIGHT. THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE SUFFERING OR HAVE. THE
GUARANTEE THAT GOES BEYOND A TWO
YEAR CYCLE. ENDS I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THE BILL
. ENTER A DEBATE THIS BUT- JUST
FOLLOWING ON AFTER THAT LAST
LEGISLATION AS- I'M NOT SAYING
THIS IS THE SOLUTION- I THINK
THERE COULD BE A MORE TAILORED
APPROACH WE COULD PROBABLY SOLVE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS BUT WHEN WE WHEN
WE HEAR ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
EXPIRING TOWARDS. SOME ASSURANCE
THAT HEARD THE WORD ASSURANCE.
LET'S PUT THAT INSURANCE. LET'S
PUT LET'S PUT OUR- OUR MOUTHS
WERE MONIES. RIGHT LET'S
ACTUALLY LOCK THAT INTO LAW
SOMEHOW THE SAME WAY WE DO WITH
THE HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER. WHERE
WE SET IN STATE LAW EVERYONE HAS
A RIGHT TO SAFE DRINKING WATER
IN CALIFORNIA. WE DIDN'T ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GO TO EVERYBODY AND
LOCK THAT IN WE NEGOTIATED
SOLUTION OVER COMING YEARS. BUT
WE PUT OUR INTENT. INTO THE
CALIFORNIA CODE AND THAT HAS
POWER AND I HOPE THAT YOU KNOW
IN OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH ACLU
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALVO ACES
WESTERN CENTER BEHAVIOR HEALTH
DIRECTORS ALL THE FOLKS HERE THE
COUNTY CITY STATE LEVEL DH CS
EVERYBODY ELSE. YOU KNOW. I
THINK WE ALL NEED TO COME THE
TABLE AND TRY TO FIND SOME
SOLUTIONS I WAS VERY ENCOURAGED
TO HEAR THE SECRETARY- OFFER
THAT WILLINGNESS IN THE PAST
AUTHORS- THIS BILL IS NOT JUST
LIMITED TO THE CARE COURTS I
DIDN'T DESIGN IT THAT WAY THIS
OTHER ISSUE. YOU KNOW THIS
PROPOSAL IN MARCH LONG BEFORE
THAT BUT- HOPE YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THAT. IF WE'RE GOING
TO ASPIRE WE GOT TO DO THAT IN
LAW SOMEHOW. AND THAT PEOPLE DO
NEED THESE ASSURANCE IF THEY'RE
GONNA ENTER. THE KIND OF SYSTEM
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO I'M
HONORED TO HAVE. A DIRECT
PRACTITIONER ON THE STREET. WHO
HAS TO FIND SOME WAY MEDI CAL
DOLLARS ARE NOT. BEING OR NOT
STATE FARM THEY'RE NOT WHO
ACTUALLY JUST HAS TO WORK ON
SKID ROW AND TREAT. THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE OUT THERE DR
SUSAN PART TOBY'S WHITNEY FROM.
HOMELESS HEALTH CARE LOS ANGELES
TO DELIVER. AT INITIAL TESTIMONY
ON IT. AND THEN TERESA PASQUINI
WHO. REALLY TURNED ME ON TO THE
AYE IDEA OF HOUSING THAT HEALS.
AND HER OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
CAN BE ON THE LINE SO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE. AND YES BUT IF
YOU'RE GETTING THE RIGHT THING
THANK YOU CENTER STARTED SO
LET'S- BURKE I THINK SUSAN- PART
OBVIOUS HERE YES OKAY WELCOME-
SO. WE GOT TO WITNESSES SO IT'S
TWO MINUTES APIECE TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES TOGETHER TO RUN OVER IT
TAKES TIME AWAY FROM THE OTHER
PERSON TO FOLLOW SO I'LL GIVE
YOU A POINTS TWO MINUTES I'LL
SAY TWO MINUTES. SO AGAIN
WELCOME AND PLEASE GET. HI MY
NAME IS SUSAN PARTISI I AM A
FAMILY PHYSICIAN FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND I'M THE MEDICAL
DIRECTOR FOR HOMELESS HEALTH
CARE LOS ANGELES FOR THE LAST
SIXTEEN YEARS. I STARTED THE
FIRST STREET MEDICINE TEAM IN
ALL OF L. A. COUNTY IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN I'VE WORKED IN
SKID ROW NOW FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND STARTED THE FIRST STREET
MEDICINE TEAM THERE IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN UNDER HOUSING
FOR HELP UNDER DR MARK GALLI.
WHAT KEEPS ME AWAKE AT NIGHT
HOWEVER ARE MY SEVERELY MENTALLY
ILL PATIENTS. I'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT LACK OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL COULD BE POLITICAL BUT I'M
A DOCTOR. MY DUTIES TO SAVE
LIVES BELIEVE ME WHEN I TELL
YOU. KNOW WHO'S GOING TO DIE. IN
MONTHS AND THERE IS VERY LITTLE
I CAN DO BECAUSE THERE'S NOWHERE
FOR THEM TO GO VERY FEW BOARDING
CARES THAT TAKE CARE OF THOSE
WITH SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ADEQUATE
FUNDING STREAM AVAILABLE AS
SOCIETY PAYS THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
A DAY WHICH IS IN ADEQUATE WHERE
IS BECAUSE THE WINTER MINUTE ACT
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL- OR
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES. CAN
LIVE IN A GROUP HOME WITH TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN STAFF WHERE THE OWNER
THAT. RECEIVES UP TO NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER MONTH. FROM
THE STATE TO CARE FOR THEM WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN
ADULT WITH DEVELOPMENTAL OR
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES AND
ADULTS WITH UNTREATED
SCHIZOPHRENIA. I A PHYSICIAN AND
A PSYCHO BIOLOGIST I KNOW THAT
BOTH HAVE A BRAIN DISEASE OFTEN
REQUIRING TREATMENT. OFTEN NOT
ABLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES
NEEDING VARYING DEGREES OF
SUPPORT HOW DID WE DECIDE. WHICH
BRAIN DISORDER GETS TREATMENT
AND WHICH DOESN'T- THE SEVERELY
MENTALLY LITTLE. ILL END UP
LIVING ON THE STREETS IN AND OUT
OF JAILS IN AND OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL THIS IS NO WAY TO LIVE.
ONE MAY ASK WHERE IS THE MONEY
GOING TO COME FROM BUT DO WE ASK
WHERE THE FUNDS FOR
VACCINATIONS. NO BECAUSE WE KNOW
VACCINATIONS ARE LIFESAVERS
WOULD WE SAY KIDS WILL GET.
THEIR VACCINES IF THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY THIS FISCAL YEAR NO THEY
GET THEM BECAUSE THEY DO A GREAT
THING TO DO. TWO MINUTES DOES IT
. YOU GETTING INTO MIDDLE OVERS
OVER SEVEN ELITE IN THE TREES
YOU CAN FINISH UP IT'S OKAY I
DON'T WANT TO TAKE AWAY FROM
TREES OKAY. ARE THANK YOU-
MODERATOR PLEASE BRING ON THE
LINE TO RESET PASQUINI. THANK
YOU THE LINE IS OPEN ALL RIGHT.
TO SUPPRESS TWENTY PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND BEGIN.
THANK YOU CARE HANDING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT. SENATOR THAT THE
FOURTEENTH FORTY THIRTY. SALES
AT FOURTEEN THOUSAND ALL RIGHT
RECENT AND HAVE YOUR EFFORTS I
FIND. WHO ARE THE FAMILIES LIKE
MINE WE ARE THOSE WHO SLEPT OPEN
ITSELF NO FAULT REPORTER. BOB
THERE VOLUNTARY DECISION MAKING
HAPPY IF THE STATE CARE WE ARE
OF ALL THAT WE WOULD BE LUCKY TO
GET OUR HELP CHILDREN INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BECAUSE
THAT WAS THE BEST EVER. EIGHT
OUT. RIGHT ACROSS THE STATE IT
IS A OUR CHILDREN WALK SILICON
AND EIGHT O'CLOCK. BECAUSE THERE
ARE SO ALL PRETTY OCT IN OUR- WE
DESPERATELY TRY TO PREVENT OUR
LOVE PLAN AND BE FORCED INTO.
FAILED REPORT OFFICE WHICH ARE
THEN RESTRICTIVE FOR EVER ALL.
AND YOUR. UNDERGOING BIRTH FELT
CALLING OUT THE NAME PARKING LOT
YEAH NOW A- SENATORS- EFFORTS
ARE FIVE. EIGHT THE WRIGHT RATE
ON OUR STREETS AND HAVE FRAYED
HOW YOU'LL THAT. WHAT IS BOTH IN
THE FIELD IT IS FOR HELP AFTER
CARE AND LOCAL SERVICE. AND
INTERPRETED REDUCE FREE IN A
HEALING IN THE FOR PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT ALL THAT THE AND OR EXTENT.
RIGHT OR THERAPEUTIC POLITICS OR
ARE ABLE TO HELP BUILD THIS IS
NOT A BAD OF YOUR FOR YOUR
PRICES IT TAKES PRICES THE
MARKET VANITY AT WORK FOR LOVE
BITES INTO GIVEN THE FULL
CELEBRATE BEING PLAYED OUT
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC PRIVATE ALSO
INCLUDE JUSTICE AND CALIFORNIA.
I MAKE THE WEIGHT YOU BETTER
ROUTE THE. DROPOUT COMPLETE
ARAFAT WENT THREE FOR THREE
ITSELF- THE CARD THREE. WEEKS
THE BILL AND THINGS ARE SECURELY
THANK YOU LAKE ALL. THANK AND
YOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT- NOW WILL
THE FROM ADDITIONAL AND OF
BEFORE FORTY SO FOR CERTAIN HERE
ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. SEEN ON
APPROACHING MODERATOR OPEN LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHICH ATTESTS IN
SUPPORT SB FOR SIX. EXPRESS
SPORT THIS BILL ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE ARE. THE FIRST LINE
TWO FORTY FIVE. PART. I'M SORRY
CAN YOU REPEAT THAT ON THE PHONE
PLEASE OKAY THIRTY FEET AFFECT
BECAUSE POLICY ANNAPOLIS OKAY
THE PROPOSAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
AFTER IT WORK THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER LINE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
FOR COMMENT REPORT ONLINE PORTAL
THREE DESPLAT. THE CURRENT
NUMBERS EIGHT. SEVEN I KEPT
ALIVE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
FRIENDS HE'S OF THE WORK WHICH
IS THE FOURTH ITSELF. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NORTH CAROLINA
GOODNESS ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WHEN L. MOVED TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SIX THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
REGISTERED FOR TESTIMONY SO WILL
NOW TAKE ADDITIONAL OR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY- FOR SB
FOURTEEN FORTY SIX WILL BEGIN
HEARING ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED. SIR
ANYONE TESTIFYING. I KNOW IT'S A
PROTEIN MICROPHONE HEALTH ALL
RIGHT. HI MY NAME IS SANDRA
NUMBER CODE **** MEDICINE HE
FROM SAN. OKAY THANK YOU. I SEE
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE- WE ARE GOING TO-
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN FORTY
SIX. FIFTY OPPOSITION FIELD
PRESS ONE AND THEN THOROUGH.
THIS IS. NO I THINK YOU ALL
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH TO BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER CENTER ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER JUST THE REALLY
A STATEMENT I SUSPECT WE ALL
AGREE THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT. SHOULD HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND HOUSING. THE
PROBLEM TODAY AND I KNOW THE
AUTHOR RECOGNIZES THIS IS WE
CAN'T MEET THE EXPECTATIONS OF
THOSE IMPACTED OR MEET THE
MOMENT IS THE GOVERNOR WOULD
SAY. WE CAN'T MEET THE
GUARANTEE. I DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR CLARIFYING THAT THE BILL
IS ASPIRATIONAL IT'S AN
ASPIRATION I SHARE I SUSPECT MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DIETS TO WAS
WELL. BUT THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A RITE OF ACTION RIGHT TO
SUE- AT LEAST AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. SO BASED ON THAT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY AND
I THINK THEY OUGHT TO BRING IT
FORWARD. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I RECOMMEND
I WOULD ALSO SAY. I WOULD CONCUR
WITH MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES- BUT
I'M A CO AUTHOR ON THIS IS A AS
WELL I FULLY BELIEVE IN A MUCH
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO- BUT HASN'T BEEN
SECONDED YET I WILL DO THAT AM.
I REMOVED SOME OF OUR SO OKAY-
AND- THANK YOU. OKAY YES SIR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN- SENATORS STERN I. I'M
NOT AN UNDERSTANDING- SENATOR
RIGHTS COMMENT THAT IT DOESN'T
CREATE A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
OR THAT IT WOULDN'T ALLOW
SOMEONE TO SEE YOU- BECAUSE IT
SAYS RIGHT HERE IN THE BILL
THAT- IT WOULD TAKE STROLLER
RIGHT ON PEOPLE FOR HOUSING IN
THE SERVICES SO. IS A COMMITMENT
TO MAKING IN I'M IN AMENDMENTS
THAT I WOULD PROMISE TO THE
COMMITTEE DIDN'T WANT TO SUGGEST
ANY AMENDMENTS AT THIS POINT SO
THEY'RE NOT OFFICIAL COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO. BE TAKING THAT SPECIFIC
AMENDMENT TODAY BUT WE'VE- WE'VE
DRAFTED THAT LANGUAGE JOB AND
I'M I WON'T BE BRINGING THIS
BILL UP SHOULD IT LEAVE THE
COMMUNITY I WON'T BE BRINGING UP
ON THE FLOOR. OUR TRYING TO MOVE
IT OUT OF OUR HOUSE WITHOUT THAT
KIND OF- GUARDRAIL IN THERE TO
REALLY CLARIFY THAT. DESPERATION
HERE. AND NOT LITIGATION- OKAY
SO YOU WERE GOING TO AMEND THE
BILL. TO NOT MAKE IT A
GUARANTEED RATE IS TO AM I
UNDERSTAND IT CORRECTLY I WOULD
AMEND THE BILL TO NOT AUTHORIZE
A PRIVATE OR PUBLIC RIGHT OF
ACTION OKAY- I GET THAT THERE'S
A- OKAY THAT'S IT I JUST WANT
ENGINE SURE OKAY. AND SO- WE
HEARD SOME COMMENTS ABOUT-
HEARING THE PREVIOUS BILL
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE HERE FOR A
LARGE AREA MOST OF THE TESTIMONY
IN THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF- PROVIDERS AND WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR THIS
PARTICULAR AND COMMUNITY SO. I
GUESS I'M WONDERING HOW. YOU
PLAN TO ADDRESS THAT I MEAN
BECAUSE MAKING A STATEMENT DO
YOU THINK IT'S A RIGHT FOR
HOUSING IN A RIGHT FOR SERVICES
IS ONE THING THE FOLLOWING
THROUGH ON THAT IS SOMETHING
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT SO WHAT IS
WHAT IS THE PLAN TO BRING THAT
TO FRUITION. IN YOUR BILL. I
MEAN I BASE THE LAST DEBATE- I
YOU KNOW I HOPE THAT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND NOT A
SEE THROUGH THE JUDICIAL PROCESS
TO RECTIFY THAT NOW THAT WOULD
BE MY HOPE I MEAN. THE ANALOG
BEING ON THE- CLEAN WATER-
ISSUE. CODIFIED IN TWENTY TWELVE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER IN
CALIFORNIA. TOOK FOR FIVE YEARS
OF ADVOCACY NOW THERE'S ONGOING
FUNDING TO DEAL WITH SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. SO IT WOULD TAKE A
SEPARATE ACT BEYOND THIS
LEGISLATION AYE AYE I WILL
CONCEDE THAT THIS IS NOT A
COMPLETE. BILL BUT- I THINK. THE
PERSON I THINK IS IT FROM A
VALUES PERSPECTIVE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL STATE
THAT. IT'S INSUFFICIENT TO LEAVE
ANYBODY BEHIND AND THAT. THE
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON SUSTAINED ON GOING FUNDING IN
THAT REGARD SO- IT THE
DIFFERENCE THOUGH BETWEEN THE
PREVIOUS SPELLING YOUR BILL IS
THAT THE PREVIOUS BILL-
ADDRESSED A VERY SPECIFIC GROUP
OF PEOPLE GAYS WHO WERE EITHER
HAD VERY SEVERE. MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WHERE YOUR BILL- DOESN'T
IDENTIFY THAT THIS IS JUST
ANYBODY WHO IS- YOU KNOW DOESN'T
HAVE HOUSING FOR- BECAUSE I
DON'T SEE I MEAN YOU TALK ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH IN HERE BUT THE
OLD JUST SAYS THAT- LET'S SEE
HERE. AN INDIVIDUAL WHO LACKS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND IS OTHERWISE
NOT LIVING SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT
TO RECEIVE YOU KNOW ALL THESE
DIFFERENT IPS IT'S NOT SPECIFIC
TO SAY SOMEONE WHO HAS
SCHIZOPHRENIA OR SOMETHING THIS
IS JUST ANYBODY WHO'S WHO'S ON
HOUSE. WELL NO NOT NECESSARILY
IT HAS TO BE AND IT ENDED AT
DANGER TO THEMSELVES OKAY SO
THAT DOESN'T SAY THAT IT WAS NOT
LIVING SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY
SO THAT PRECONDITION. AND I
WOULD I WAS NOT OKAY BUT HOLD ON
I MEAN YOU KNOW WORK. IT'S THE
WORDS ARE DEFINITELY IMPORTANT
AND SO NOT LIVING SAFELY. IS A
SUBJECTIVE PHRASE RATE IT IS I
MEAN FRANKLY IT'S NOT SAFE. IT
REALLY IN ANY CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
A LOT OF PEOPLE IF YOU REALLY
LOOK AT IT YOU CAN. BE A FACTOR
IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS AND
SAY NO ONE LIVING ON THE STREETS
EVEN IF THEY'RE IN. SOME
SECLUDED DO EVERYWHERE THEY'RE
PROTECTED LET'S SAY IT'S STILL
NOT SAFE RATE. SO YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU'RE RIGHT TO PUT YOUR FINGER
ON THAT ISSUE AND EVEN OUR
ADVOCATES IN THE- YOU KNOW. IT'S
PAST QUEENIE ON THE LINE IS
BROUGHT THE SAME THING UP I I'D
BE WILLING. TO AMEND THE BILL-
OR AT LEAST COMMITTED TO MAKING
THAT AMENDMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- TO CONSTRAIN
IT. STRICTLY TO. TO THOSE WHO
ARE SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL- AND
HAVE NO OTHER RESOURCES AT THEIR
DISPOSAL. BUT WE WANTED TO LEAVE
SOME DISCRETION IN DEFERENCE FOR
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS TO MAKE THOSE KIND OF
DETERMINATIONS ON THE STREETS.
THAT THAT WAS THE HARD PART IS
WE DIDN'T. WE DIDN'T WANT TO
DEFINE IT JUST BASED ON IF
SOMEONE SAY IS GRAVELY DISABLED
BECAUSE YOU TRIGGER THAT A WHOLE
OTHER RANGE OF QUESTIONS THAT IT
WOULD ONLY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PEOPLE UP UNDER CONSERVATORSHIP
STORE ELIGIBLE FOR
CONSERVATIVES. WE DON'T WANT TO
JUST STAY IN THAT SPACE BECAUSE
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THEM. SO-
YOU'RE RIGHT TO POINT OUT THE
ISSUE AND I AM. VERY WILLING TO
MAKE- TO PUT THAT GRANULARITY
THERE BUT I WOULD JUST SAY FOR
ALL THESE COMMITMENTS. I WILL
NOT DO THAT WITHOUT THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE SO I DON'T GIVE
YOU A CHOICE. I KNOW. I KNOW IT
ALL TOO WELL NOW AND I JUST EVEN
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO HAVE
ROOM TO WORK WITH. YOU ALL ON
THAT SO. WELL I- I APPRECIATE
YOUR WILLINGNESS AND YOUR
RECOGNITION AND SOME OF THE YOU
KNOW ISSUES WITH THE BILL-
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT IT SEEMS
VERY UNWORKABLE TO ME I'M TO
SUGGEST THAT ANYBODY. WHO
DOESN'T HAVE HOUSING WOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO IT IS YOU KNOW
OPERATE MEAN JUST THE FINANCIAL.
COST COMES ALONG WITH THAT IS
MONUMENTAL AS YOU KNOW- IS THIS
SOMETHING I JUST IT SEEMS TO ME
LIKE THIS IT SINCE YOU'RE SAYING
IT'S- YOU KNOW IT'S LARGELY A
STATEMENT OF OUR VALUES I WONDER
IF YOU'VE- EVEN CONSIDERED.
PERHAPS BE A TURNING THIS INTO A
RESOLUTION PERHAPS INSTEAD OF A
BILL THAT WOULD. CONVERT THESE
RATES ON PEOPLE. I WOULD
CONSIDER IT- JUST THE I MEAN I
WOULD JUST SAY THOUGH THAT.
ANYBODY WHO'S STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS IN CALIFORNIA
SHOULD HAVE GUARANTEED RIGHT TO
THAT TREATMENT WE TOOK UP WAS A
BILL FROM SENATOR WIENER LAST
YEAR TO PUSH THE PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURERS TO FINALLY COVER.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND THEY'VE
BEEN DRAGGING THEIR HEELS ON SO.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT'S
OVERLY BROAD AND I DON'T WANT TO
SAY THIS IS JUST FOR PEOPLE
AROUND HOUSE NO THAT THAT THAT
REALLY THAT WAS INTENTIONAL- I
RECOGNIZE THAT. OVER YOU COULD
READ THAT BILL THE SAY EVERYONE
THEN WHATEVER RIGHT TO HOUSING-
BUT THIS IS REALLY. IF WE CAN
DRILL DOWN ON WHAT IS NOT LIVING
SAFELY IN THE COMMUNITY AND TO
FIND THAT- IT MORE NARROW TERMS
I THINK. HOPEFULLY BRING SOME
ASSURANCE IN A LITTLE MORE- I.
THE FORTY VOTES THANK YOU THANKS
FOR READING THOSE ISSUES THAT
OKAY. THE OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OKAY SAYING NONE- THE
FOR THE SENATE CERTAIN I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD DIFFICULTY OVER LAST
WEEK- AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE GONNA DO- ADDITIONAL WORK
ON THE BILL I THINK WE'VE HEARD
IN THE DIALOGUE HERE A LOT OF
ISSUES- FOR EXAMPLE- AND YOU
BROUGHT UP AND WE DISCUSSED
ACTUALLY THE CURRENT THE- RIGHT
TO WATER IT'S IN AND STATE LAW
IN FACT I REMEMBER VOTING FOR
THE CENTER MONIES BILL. BUT YOU
LOOK AT THOSE THE LANGUAGE
AROUND THAT BILL SO FIRST OF ALL
I WANNA SAY THAT I APPRECIATE
ASPIRATION RIGHT SO I THINK-
APPRECIATE THE ASPIRATION THAT
THIS THIS BILL REPRESENTS- THE-
AS WE TALKED ABOUT. THE OF THE
RATE OF WATER WHAT YOU REFER TO
IN BOTH YOUR TESTIMONY WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT- THAT IF YOU LOOK
AT THAT BILL. IS THE FINANCIAL
DEBT JUST TO CLEAR THE RIGHT.
THE RELY DEFINITIONS AROUND IT
IS TO SAY YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE OTHER TITLE IT IT'S
THE CENTER RIGHT SO YOU TALK
ABOUT DEL SAYING THAT YOU'LL
TAKE AN AMENDMENT TO. PRINT
RIGHT PROGRAM ACTUALLY SO IT WAS
A HOUSE THAT ENACTED WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO HAVE A RIGHT A WATER
RATES SO- SO THERE'S A LOT OF.
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ASPIRATION DRIVES A LOT OF.
DETAIL STILL TO BE WORKED OUT- I
THINK YOU KNOW YOU CAN LOOK AT
THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT THE MONEY
BUILD BRAG ANDRE WATERS PERHAPS
THESE A TEMPLATE. THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY WITH DIFFERENT TOPICS
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT I WAS GONNA BE
THE SAME. AS A PERHAPS A
TEMPLATE FOR HOW YOUR BILL COULD
DEFAULT- THERE ARE A LOT OF
STILL QUESTIONS OUT THERE- SO.
YEAH SO I GUESS WHAT I'M GONNA
SAY IS THAT I KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS IS THAT IN AN FOR SO
I WANT TO JUST SAVE. FRONT OF
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I DO
ON. THE SCRIPT ANYONE FROM
VOTING FOR THIS BILL- OF THE
PERSONALLY MIKE. IS THE- IS YEAR
THE COMMITTEE IS THAT IT'S THEIR
SOUL SO MUCH WORK TO BE DONE.
AND CERTAINLY ONE OF TRY TO WORK
AND SEE WHAT I CAN DO TO HELP
USE THAT EVOLVES. THAT I DON'T
PERSONALLY FEEL COMFORTABLE TO
SAY TAT I'M GONNA PUT MY
PERSONAL STAMP ON IT WITH AN AYE
VOTE. BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
OPEN ENDED QUESTIONS THAT STILL
HAVE YET TO BE SORTED OUT. SO I
DON'T DISCOURAGE ANYONE
COMMITTEE FROM VOTING FOR THE
BILL TO ALLOW YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS ASPIRATION BUT-
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT STILL
TO BE DONE. AND FORTUNATELY YOU
KNOW WEIRD THE- DOORS OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT BEFORE WE
GOT TO THIS YEAR THIS IS THE
LAST POLICY HEARING- I KNOW THE
AND YELLOW BE SURE AND THEN OF
COURSE EVERY TIME YOU PUT IN
MORE DETAIL. THAN STAKEHOLDERS
START HAVING DIFFERENT OPINIONS
AS WELL SO RIGHT NOW PEOPLE LOOK
AT THE ASPIRATION THE OUT AND
WE'RE LIKE A YEAH HEY WE ALL
LIKE THAT BUT THEN. HOUSE
OPERATIONALIZE DOES GET TO BE
REALLY IMPORTANT I THINK IS SOME
OF THE MEMBERS APPOINTED OUT. SO
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION LOOKING FORWARD TO
FUTURE CONVERSATIONS WHETHER
THIS BILL PASSES OR NOT BECAUSE
I KNOW SOMETHING YOU CARE ABOUT.
SOMETHING THAT ALL OF US CARE
ABOUT. WHAT A HEALTH PARTNER
WITH YOU AND FIGURE THAT OUT-
SO- SO I'M JUST PERSONALLY GONNA
LAY OFF BECAUSE- I DON'T FEEL
THAT THE BILLS. AND STUFF TYPE
OF FORM I FEEL COMFORTABLE DOING
BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF IT MOVES
FORWARD TO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON IT PEOPLE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO. MOVE WORK
ON THIS ASPIRATION. THEN I'M
THAT'S GREAT AND THE LET'S KEEP
WORKING ON- IS A- FOR SO WITH
THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT SPACE IN THAT THAT- YOUR
YOUR HIGH STANDARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND I WOULD JUST SAY-
A LANGUAGE WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING TODAY. SIR IF YOU
EXACTLY TO THAT RIGHT TO WATER
FRAMEWORK- WOULD DO.
OPERATIONALIZE THIS IS A SORT OF
SHALL CONSIDER KIND OF CONCEPT
BUT WITHOUT A MANDATE OR A
LITIGATION OPPORTUNITY- BUT LOOK
AS I SAID IT'S BILL ON ITS OWN
IS NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS OR THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THAT SPACE- BUT I DO
THINK WE'LL- WE NEED TO. SET OUR
TERMS HERE AND AS WE ENGAGE IN
THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONVERSATION
IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR ON
HOW TO HELP. KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE FROM LITERALLY
DYING ON OUR STREETS THE KIND OF
PEOPLE THAT DR PART TOVEY LOSING
EVERY SINGLE DAY I CANNOT
IMAGINE. MEDICAL DOCTOR WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE WHEN YOU HAVE TAKE A
HIPPOCRATIC OATH. AND GO OUT TO
DO YOUR WORK. AND THEN. THERE'S
NO ONE THERE TO FULFILL THAT
DUTY BUT YOU- WE NEED TO HELP
OUR DOCTORS OUR PATIENTS AND THE
PEOPLE OUT THERE SUFFERING- FIND
A BETTER WAY SO I BELIEVE
HOUSING MEALS IS THAT WAY. I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE NOD
FROM CENTER EGGMAN IN HER
LEADERSHIP THIS YEAR AND I'M
HITCHING MY WAGON TO HER STAR.
AND I WOULD JUST REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU ALL GIVEN ME SOME
SPACE BEFORE THE FLOOR TO TRY TO
PUT SOME WORK PRODUCT BEFORE YOU
THAT THAT MAKES SENSE IN THIS
LARGER CONTEXT- AND HOPEFULLY
OUR DRIVER. SO THAT EXPECTATIONS
FOR. ARCTIC AND SHE WAS SECONDED
ALREADY REMOVED VEGAS MOVED BY
SENTIMENTS OF THE FIGHTERS OKAY
SO THE MOTIONS DO PASSED THE
FIRST RE REFER TO COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS MOVE BY CENTER
EGGMAN. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL PAN. MELINDA'S WINDOWS
NO EGGMAN EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I A GROVE HER TADO HER
TITLE BY LEYVA VOTING LIMON.
FROTH ALL RIGHT ROTH FIVE RUBIO
. RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
LIMON HI THIS IS THAT EVERYBODY
. VETERANS. THAT'S OUR MILITARY
BECAUSE THEY I NEED A LOGO OKAY
ALL RIGHT SO THAT FILLS OUT
SEVEN ONE THANK YOU RIGHT THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANKS OKAY I THINK
THE LAST ITEMS BEFORE WE GET TO
SEND CALENDARS I'M NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH IS MINE SO HE ON THE GAVEL
OVER TO. MELENDEZ WELCOME. THANK
YOU THE FINAL ITEM ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY. IS SENATOR PAN'S BILL
WHICH IS ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT. YEAH OKAY-
YOU'RE PRESENTING OKAY AND AS
OUR CHAIRMAN MAKES HIS WAY- OVER
TO THE PODIUM. MIRO IN CAN TKE
A DEEP BREATH SENATOR PAN
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY. THANK
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH- LIGHTS
YOUR BELINDA'S SENATORS- FOR
SOME TIME PLEASE PRESENT SB
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT- DRESSES
ACTUALLY- JINDRAK DRUG
MANUFACTURING PARTICULARLY-
INSULIN TELL US BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS- TO
DROP THE POLICY COMMENT ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ALICE'S TO ENSURE TO
ANY CONTRACT ENTERING INTO. TWO
FOR MANUFACTURE GENERIC DRUGS
INCLUDES MEASURABLE OUTCOMES-
YEAH BACK IN TWENTY TWENTY- I
AUTHORED WE PASSED SB EIGHT
FIFTY TWO WHICH REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO PARTNER WITH
A DRUG MAKER. TO MANUFACTURE
GENERIC DRUGS AND- SO WE KNOW
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH BOTH
ONE THE EXPENSE OF DROVE OF
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS- HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND EXPENSE THAT
COSTS CALIFORNIANS INTO ACTUALLY
RELIABLE ACCESS TO SOME OF THESE
GENERIC MEDICATION SO FOR SOME.
GENERIC PHARMACEUTICALS- THERE
MAY ONLY BE ONE SUPPLIER WHICH
EITHER OF THAT SUPPLIER HAS A
MAJOR SECTION PROBLEM SUDDENLY
NOW THERE'S A SHORTAGE OR IT
GETS BOUGHT OUT AND THEN SOMEONE
UP THE PRICE RATE AND CERTAINLY
NOW YOU'RE IN- SO THE IDEA WOULD
BE IS THAT TO HAVE CALIFORNIA.
TAKE A LEAD AND ACTUALLY
MANUFACTURING GENERIC
MEDICATIONS IN A STRATEGIC WAY
TO LOWER COSTS FOR PARTICULAR
KEY GENERIC MEDICATIONS ARE
NECESSARY. FOR CALIFORNIANS AND
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY. IN THE MARKET
AS WELL AND- SO SINCE THE
PASSAGE IN TWENTY TWENTY OF SB
EIGHT FIFTY TWO- THE
DEMONSTRATIONS BEGAN THIS. AND
PARTICULARLY IN THAT BILL WE
IDENTIFIED CALIFORNIA LABEL
INSULIN. AND IN FACT- THE-
THERE'S PROGRESS IN AND TRYING
TO IDENTIFY AWAY FOR CALIFORNIA
PARTICIPATE IN. THE ASSURING
THAT WE CAN GET INSULIN SO THIS
BILL FURTHERS THAT WORK BY
EXPLICITLY REQUIRING THE- CAL
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY PARTNERSHIP TO DEVELOP
INSOLENT IN AND TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA BASED MANUFACTURING
FACILITY. FOR GENERICS WITH THE
INTENT OF CREATING HIGH SKILL
HIGH- HIGH PAYING JOBS. THIS
POLICY IS MORE IMPORTANT
ENDEAVOR I THINK THE COVE
NINETEEN CRISIS IS CERTAINLY
PANDEMIC IS SHOWN HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS HAVE THE RELIABLE SUPPLY
CHAIN- AND TO HAVE RELIABLE
SUPPLIES OF. WHETHER IT'S- WELL
CERTAINLY WE TALK ABOUT THE P.
BUT YOU KNOW MEDICAID
MEDICATIONS OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS AS AS WELL- AND SO. IT'S
TO BE ABLE TO HELP HAVE CAPACITY
IN OUR OWN STATE. WHERE IT IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT- CAL. ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE MEDICATIONS THEY NEED
THEY NEED TO SETTING UP THE
STRUCTURE IN. WHICH THE
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS OWN DRUG
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY WILL HELP
THE STATE PREPARE FOR OTHER
TYPES OF CRISES AS WELL. SO WITH
THAT- I AM PLEASED TO HAVE A
JOKE ABOUT THOSE FROM THE A. R.
P. AND DOUGLAS AND HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ON OVER THE PHONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
SO YOUR WITNESSES ARE ON THE
PHONE LINE SO MISTER MODERATED
OR MADAME MODERATOR I DON'T KNOW
WHO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW. IF YOU
COULD IDENTIFY JOGO BONDS AS OR
AYE DIANA. DOUGLAS IN QUEUE THEM
UP PLEASE. THE FIRE. WHO DO WE
HAVE UP. OPEN I HAD A DOG OR CAT
OR CODE THE BOOK THE BOOK FOR
LIFE- OPEN HERE OKAY I AM. HAPPY
TO STARTED OUT IF YOU THINK I AM
FOR MY NEED TO PANIC AT FIRST ON
BEHALF OF ALL FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA IT RIGHT BEFORE AT.
THE PUBLIC THAT. ONE FIVE
HERTZBERG WE NEED IT ACTION DRUG
I OUR- YOUR PEOPLE AT THE THIRTY
EIGHT WILL HELP FROM FOR
CALIFORNIA AND. CONFIDENCE IN
KENTUCKY BUT THE WORKING PEOPLE
IN THE IF YOU MULTIPLE
MEDICATIONS ACTUALLY PART IT IN
CALIFORNIA UNIQUE AND-
PURCHASING POWER AND MILLION.
ALL THAT WE GET MANY PARTNERS
THAT OUR OWN CALIFORNIA LABELED
NEAR FIFTY DRUG ARTICLE FIVE. IN
ARE ACTUALLY THREE. FROM THE
MEDICAID FIRST DATA ENTRY. IN
THE ABSENCE DONATED YOU RIGHT IS
NOT YOUR I IN FACT NOWHERE NEAR
RIGHT. IF THE MINISTRY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE BUT IT
HAPPENED FOR WILL BE THE- IN THE
MARKET. ARE SB THIRTY EIGHT OVER
THOSE ARE THE REAL ME I
REQUIRING FOR PRETTY AND FUN
IT'S WRONG OR AT EIGHT THIRTY
AND AFTER OUR FLEET YOUR FELT
THANK YOU. FOR THREE. THANK YOU
. WILL MOVE ON NOW DID YOU. BY
AS YOU- TO MINUTES FOR YOUR
TECH. PLEASE BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. RELATED TOPICS- IT. EIGHT EVEN AWAKE IS THE FINAL
VOTE BETTER READY PEOPLE. I'M
HERE YOU HEAR ME LOUD AND CLEAR
WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
YEAH. BUT GREAT WITH ME GET YOU
HAD TWO MINUTES JAIL. SENATE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FAST THE EARLY
INTENT THAT ON THE LESSON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND YOU'RE
EARNING YOUR EXACT. JOKE ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE BEAR PIT
CALIFORNIA A NONPROFIT
NONPARTISAN OKAY EIGHT. AND I'M
HERE YOU HAVE ABOUT IT IN
MEMPHIS IN CALIFORNIA FLORIDA
FIFTY EIGHT THREE EIGHT. THE
BILL WITH MASTER CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO MANUFACTURE ITS
GENERIC PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION
. THE INTERNET BUT SOMETIMES
THAT EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY AM THE
CALIFORNIA ORDERED AS HE EIGHT
FIVE. TWO WHICH RAISES THE
OFFICE OF DRUG. ACT MAN THANK
THE CALL HEALTH YOU PREPARE HM
EIGHT NOW WE SUPPORT AT FIFTY
EIGHT THREE EIGHT. FORTY AM
RETURN REPORTER STEP OF AT EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE. THE RESULTS ARE AT
HE EIGHT THREE EIGHT WELL
INCREASE UP FIFTY LOWER PRICES.
AND ADDRESS BOOK IS THE MARKET
WHAT'S NEXT IT'S PAST. WHERE
PEOPLE THAT'S ALL. HAVE ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE LIFESAVING
MEDICAID. AT A. R. P. WE ARE
POOR- REFORMS THAT HELP LOWER IF
THE DRUG PRICES PROVIDE RELIEF
ALL THE MERITS AND STRUGGLING.
FOR FORTY FIVE EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT. RIGHT NOW THE FEDERAL OUR
NATIONAL. THE LACK BUT EIGHT
THAT MAPLE MEDICARE THE NAKED
STATE BOARD AND GOT RIGHT. SO
THE TWO ECONOMIC DISPARITIES- IT
HE REPORT AT EIGHT EIGHT THREE
EIGHT FIVE AMERICA GOT IT
ASSEMBLY LOWERED DOWN FRIDAY
NIGHT BUT I'M AND MY 8% LOWER
THE AVERAGE OLDER THEY WERE
QUITE PERSPECTIVE- THIRTY EIGHT
ON A DAILY. TELL YOUR IT TWO
MINUTES NOW HIRED BY WELL WE
HAVE HEARD FROM MANY CHARITY
MEMBERS OF OLDER. TO BE CLEAN.
SORRY GROCERY THE EIGHTEEN
MATTER JOE YOU ARE PAST YOUR TWO
MINUTE TIMELINE PLEASE IF YOU
COULD. YOU'RE HELPING OKAY JERRY
YOU'RE BROADLY I NEED THE THREE
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU KNOW
YOU ARE LONG PAST YOUR TWO
MINUTE. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
FREESHEET THAT. OKAY BURKE WROTE
FIVE BY. ZERO EIGHT BY PASSING
WE WILL GO TO. EVEN THOUGH IT
WILL GO TO IF WEEKEND MISTER
MONTEREY- OR NOT RIGHT FOR YOU
IF WE COULD MOVE IT OUT TO
SUPPORT HERE IN THE COMMUNITY
HEARING ROOM- ANYONE WISHING TO
COME FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WE WILL MOVE TO
SUPPORT HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM FOR S. B. EIGHT TWO
THREE EIGHT ANYONE WISHING TO.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. NO
OKAY WE WILL GET TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE WHO WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE
REMEMBER. YOU MAY OFFER YOUR
NAME THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT AND THE FACT THAT YOU
SUPPORTS THE BILL AND NOTHING
BEYOND THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AFFAIRS YOUR ORDER AT.
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT THE FIVE
POINT. EIGHT ZERO SIX FIVE.
EIGHT ZERO. OPERATOR TO GIVE
YOUR LIFE COVER THANK YOU BACK
TO YOU AND WILL BEGIN THEY
WITHOUT MY FORTY NINTH WORLD IF. FORTY NINE BEFORE AT. GOOD
EVENING NO WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. EXPLORE THE
LINE TO FORTY OUT. SALAS FROM
EIGHT REPORT. AT FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY A
BANK OR- AT. EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT TO FIFTY PEOPLE AT. I ONLY
KNOW THE AREA WITH OPEN IT FOR
US AT THE RATE. AND WE WILL
PROVIDE FOR THIRTY ONE GIRL. BUT
THIRTY ONE PROJECT S. BY EIGHT.
LAST SHOT L. A. R. S. B. ARE YOU
THIRTY EIGHT FIVE POINT THIRTY
ONE YEAR OLD. A BETTER CALAVERAS
FIVE. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR- WE
WILL NOW GO TO LEAD OPPOSITION
OF WHICH THERE IS NONE
REGISTERED SO IF THERE IS ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL SENATE
BILL EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE.
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO SB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT TO EIGHT YES SIR
PLEASE GO AHEAD NAME
ORGANIZATION AND THAT YOU OPPOSE
OR- FOR THE EASE OF MELISSA I
WILL SHORTEN MY NAME. MY NAME IS
FOR CALLING NEUTRAL HYPHEN
CLAIMANT HYPHEN WITNESS HYPHEN
POSTMASTER FOCAL MITCHELL FOR
COLIN SMITH PERIOD. FOR THE
ORGANIZATION. I PROSECUTE
CORRUPT JUDGES LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS LAWYERS ATTORNEYS.
DOCTORS CPS WORKERS SENATE
MEMBERS AND ALL OTHER
CONSTITUENTS WHO THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO. KIDNAPPER SONS AND
DAUGHTERS AND EXTORT OUR LAND
THROUGH FALSE EARNINGS
STATEMENTS SIR IT OKAY WAS THAT
THERE WAS AN OPPOSE. I BELIEVE
FRAZIER THANK YOU ARI THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS THERE ANYONE HERE YES
MA'AM GO HEAD. HI MY NAME IS
SANDRA HYPHEN CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY HYPHEN NUREMBERG CODE
HYPHEN **** MEDICINE WATER
HYPHEN. ARE YOU OPPOSED TO THE
BILL WELL I AM HERE REPRESENTING
THE PEOPLE OF THE TERRITORY OF
CALIFORNIA THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE AND- YEAH I DON'T
AGREE WITH ANYTHING YOU'RE DOING
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OF OKAY
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO POSE THIS BILL ALL
RIGHT NOW WE WILL GET TO THE
PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT- FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE ON
THE PHONE LINE REMEMBERS YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION- IN YOUR
POSITION THAT YOU OPPOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. HE BETTER CARE TO
OUR IN. THIS IS AT THE EIGHTY
EIGHT. ONE ZERO. ONE EIGHT ZERO
BUT IT SHOULD DO. IT EIGHT THREE
EIGHT THANK YOU. ADAM CARE
COMPANY IS GOING UP R. EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MODERATOR THEY'LL BRING IT BACK
UP HERE TO THE DAYS FOR
DISCUSSION ANYONE. CENTER ROTH
HAS MOVED THE BILL IS ANYONE
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD NOW OKAY
SENATOR ROTH YOU MAY CLOSE I'M
SORRY CENTER PAN YOU MAY CLOSE
AS QUICKLY AS ONE EITHER THANK
YOU. EASY PEASY OKAY THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST. AT
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CAN PAN HI
MELINDA. MELINDA'S NO EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ AND SALAS HI
GROVE HER TADO. A TOTAL OF FIVE
LEYVA LEYVA AYE LEE MOON THE
MOON I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER HI. THAT
BILL IS OUT NINE ONE. WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT SO FILE ITEM IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR JUST- AGAIN MY
DIRECT CONCERN CAL IS I'M NUMBER
TWO S. B. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
CENTER EGGMAN ITEM NUMBER FIVE
SB 1191% OR BATES ITEM NUMBER
THAT THAT'S A FACT THAT I AM
NUMBER NINE S. B. TWELVE THIRTY
ONE BY CENTER CAMBIOS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
BY MYSELF CENTER PAN AND ITEM
THERE SEVENTEEN SP FIFTEEN
HUNDRED BY THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY. SENATOR
EGGMAN AND THE PHYSICIAN THE
MOTION SELLS FOR CONSENT
CALENDAR SO US CONSULTANTS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL PAN ALL
RIGHT HAND BY MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S I EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ AND SALAS I GROVE HER
TADO FURTADO I LEYVA. LEYVA
MOANED LIMON I ROTH ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE. OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT TEN ZERO ALL
RIGHT SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND LIFT
THE CALLS WILL START FROM- JUST
THE SKILL IN ORDER HERE IN THE
FILE ORDER SO FOR START WITH I
AM NUMBER ONE SB NINE SEVENTY BY
CENTER EGGMAN- CONSULTANT TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ ON A
GROVE HER TADO FOR TOTAL BY THE
MOON THE MOON I WINNER WINNER BY
. AND THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO.
NUMBER TWO IS- CANCERS I CONSENT
ITEM NUMBER THREE SB NINE
SEVENTY NINE BY CENTER DIED I
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ HI AND SALAS I GROW HER
TADO HER TADO I LEÓN LIMON HI.
AND ZERO EIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
TEN ZERO SIX ITEMS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB ELEVEN FORTY THREE BY
CENTER ROTH- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT MEMBERS
AND SALAS GONZALEZ I'D GROW HER
TADO FURTADO IDLY MON LEE MON
FRIDAY WIENER WIENER HI. INDIA
THAT BILL IS ABOUT TEN ZERO SIX
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
TWELVE A SEVEN BY CENTER
PORTANTINO CONSOLE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ. IN SALAS I
GREW HER TADO FOR TITLE I LIMA.
THE MOON BY. WIENER TEN ZERO
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT TEN ZERO-
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TEN S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BY SIR
MCGUIRE- CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ
GROW HER TADO HER TITLE BY.
NIGER STEP THOSE OUT NINE ZERO
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
BY CENTERS- BURKE AND A COMMAND
THAT'S RIGHT I AM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT BY
CENTRE'S NUMBER AGAIN EGGMAN
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS MELENDEZ GROVE
HER TADO. FOR TITLE II. STEP
BILLS NINE ZERO. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX BY CENTER BECKER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HER TADO FOR TOTAL I LIMON THE
MONEY. AND YOUR- OKAY THAT THOSE
OUT TEN ZERO NEXT ITEMS ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE BY CENTCOM LARGER.
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MELINDA'S. GROVE
HER DAUGHTER FOR TOTAL I THAT
FILLS OUT. NINE ZERO. I THINK
STERN'S BILLS RIGHT NOW AND THIS
MIGHT MIGHT BUILD UP OKAY SO
OKAY- SO THEN JUST AS A REMINDER
TO ITEMS NUMBER SIX AND SEVEN
WERE BOTH PULLED SELKIES HILLS
WONDER IF I CENTER BATES ALL
RIGHT SO THAT. SO THAT THIS
ACTUALLY WRAPS UP ARE STILL
AGENDA THANK YOU AND- I THINK MY
VICE CHAIR AGAIN FOR CARRYING
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE FOR
A WRAP UP IS WHAT THEY AGAIN
THANK THE STAFF. FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK AND THIS IS OUR I
GUESS FOR HOUSE OF ORIGIN SO WE
STILL HAVE MORE TO GO- WELL I
THINK THE SERGEANTS FOR HELPING
KEEP ORDER OF I THINK THE
TECHNICAL STAFF AND- OUR
MODERATORS FOR KEEPING THAT FLOW
GOING AS WELL AND IF ANYONE
WANTS TO MAKE COMMENTS ON THE
BILLS AND- THEY WERE ABLE TO OR
IF YOU WANT TO DO IT MORE.
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION PLEASE
MAKE YOUR LETTERS TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH- VIA OUR
WEBSITE AND- SO WITH THAT- WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE GENDER OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
HEARING. WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.